SEPT WILL COME TO ORDER. GOOD
AFTERNOON AND AS WE CONTINUE TO
TAKE SOME PRECAUTIONS TO MANAGE
ONGOING COVERT NINETEEN REST THE
SENATE CONTINUES TO WELCOME THE
PUBLIC AND HAS PROVIDED ACCESS
TO BOTH IN PERSON AND
TELECONFERENCES PATIENT
REPUBLICAN MEANT. FOR
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT VIA THE TELEPHONE
TELECONFERENCE ARVEST
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW AND THAT NUMBER
IS. 877-226-8163 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. SEVEN THREE SIX TWO
EIGHT THREE THREE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO SUSPECTED MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS UTED. WE'RE HOLDING
OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN
THE- STREET BUILDING. AND I
NOTICED ALL OUR MEMBERS ARE
HERE. THESE THE BILL PROVIDING
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
TODAY ARE ALSO PARTICIPATING.
REMOTELY FOR OUR REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MEET YOUR
PHONES OR COMPUTERS WHICH ARE
REALLY EIGHT AND ELIMINATING
FEEDBACK. EVERYTIME YOU WISH TO
BE RECOGNIZED YOUR HANDLE CALL
ON YOU AND THEN FOLLOW THE
INSTRUCTIONS FROM THERE. TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE
BEEN A MEMBER MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE HEARING ROOM. TO
THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
AND WE WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. PUBLIC COMMENT WILL BE
HEARD AFTER ALL THE DISCUSSION
ITEMS HAVE BEEN PRESENTED.
BEFORE WE BEGIN LET'S ESTABLISH
A CORPSMAN HAVE A CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. EGGMAN
HERE FOR A MINUTE HERE MELENDEZ
. UNDEATH OF HERE PAN PRESENT
TENANTS HERE. VERY MUCH WE HAVE
A FULL A FULL MEMBERS ARE- HERE
IN TODAY'S HEARING WE WILL BE
VOTING ON VARIOUS PROPOSALS THAT
THE SUB COMMITTEE HAS HEARD AND
DISCUSSED EARLIER THIS YEAR.
WE'LL BEGIN WITH VOTING AND THEN
MOVE ON TO OUR ISSUES FOR
DISCUSSION WILL TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT AFTER ALL ITEMS HAVE
BEEN DISCUSSED AND WE'LL BEGIN
WITH OUR VOTE ONLY CALENDAR.
FIRST IT WILL VOTE ON ISSUES ONE
THROUGH TWENTY ONE. TWENTY THREE
THROUGH TWENTY NINE. THIRTY ONE
THROUGH FORTY TWO AND FORTY FOUR
THROUGH FORTY FIVE. IS THERE A
HAVE MOTION ON THE
RECOMMENDATION PHOTO TODAY'S
AGENDA OKAY THANK YOU AT ASPEN
BOB MOVED BY SENATOR PAN AND THE
MOTION IS TO ADOPT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. EGGMAN HI AND I MELENDEZ
MELENDEZ I PAN HI CAN I. IT IS
THREE ZERO THAT PASSES AND WE
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AT THIS
TIME- THE NEXT STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE- ON ISSUE
NUMBER THIRTY IS OUR MOTION ON
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT. THE STAFF
EQUIPMENT INVITATION ISN'T MOVED
BY SENATOR PAN. THE MOTION IS TO
ADOPT THE STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS
A CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. EGGMAN HI. EGGMAN I
MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ NO HAN HI CAN
I. OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
THE STAFFORD RECOMMENDATIONS ARE
ADOPTED- I USED TO KNOWS ONE AND
WILL NOW VOTE ON ISSUES TWENTY
THREE THROUGH FORTY THREE IS
THERE A MOTION ON NOTICE. RIGHT
THERE IS A MOTION CONSULTANT.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL EGGMAN AYE
EGGMAN AYE MELENDEZ. FORTY THREE
TWENTY TWO THROUGH FORTY THREE.
AND FOURTH. TWENTY TWO AND FORTY
THREE I'M SORRY. YEAH. RIGHT
OKAY. THREE I IT ITEM TWENTY TWO
AND FORTY THREE OKAY I'M SORRY
THAT WHO YOU SEE FIRST TIME
INSTINCTS SORRY- NOTHING. OKAY
SO I THINK WE'LL GO BACK TO-
WILL VOTE ON ISSUES TWENTY TWO
AND FORTY THREE I BELIEVE CENTER
PAN MOVED THAT YES OKAY SO NOW A
CONSULTANT WITH WILL CALL THE
ROLL EGGMAN BY. ADMIN HI
MELENDEZ. PAN HI CAN I. OKAY SO
THAT PASSES CENTER PANDION
EGGMAN VOTING I SENATOR MELINDA
IS OBSCENE. OKAY ALL RIGHT- SO
WE'LL MOVE ON FROM THERE ARE TO
OUR DISCUSSION ITEMS AND WILL
BEGIN WITH AN OVERVIEW OF THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE AND THE
BUDGET CONDITION FROM THE L. A.
O. THIS BILL ARE YOU HER WITH
US GOOD MORNING GOOD AFTERNOON I
SHOULD SAY GOOD AFTERNOON. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS JENNY BELLOW WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE. WE
WERE ASKED TO START OFF THE
HEARING TODAY WITH A HIGH LEVEL
OVERVIEW OF OUR INITIAL TAKE OF
THE GOVERNORS MAY REVISION
PROPOSAL. WHICH WE ACTUALLY JUST
PUBLISHED YESTERDAY. THE MAJOR
COMPONENTS OF THE GOVERNORS MAY
REVISION ARE LAID OUT IN YOUR
AGENDA ON THE FIRST ISSUE. AND
OUR OFFICE IS REALLY NEAT EARLY
STAGES OF ANALYZING PROPOSALS IN THE
COMING DAYS AND WEEKS WE'LL BE
WORKING WITH THE FACT COMMITTEE
AT OUR THINKING ON THEM.
CONTINUES TO EVOLVE. FOR TODAY
WHEN THE SUB COMMITTEE IS
DISCUSSING THE INDIVIDUAL
PROPOSALS WOULD PREFER WE WILL
BE PROVIDING SOME. MARKETING
COMMENTS ON SOME OF THE
PROPOSALS REALLY FOCUSING ON OUR
KEY QUESTIONS AND ISSUES THAT
ARE GUIDING OUR ANALYSIS AT THIS
TIME. SO AGAIN YESTERDAY OUR
OFFICE DID PUBLISH OUR INITIAL
COMMENTS ON THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISION WHICH REALLY FOCUSES ON
THE OVERALL STRUCTURE AND
CONDITION OF THE BUDGET. AND
THAT REPORT HAD SEVERAL KEY
FINDINGS WHICH I WILL HIGHLIGHT
A HIGH LEVEL HERE TODAY. THE
FIRST IS THAT AS A RESULT OF
EXTRAORDINARY REVENUE GROWTH
OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS WE
ESTIMATE THE GOVERNOR HAD FIFTY
TWO BILLION AN OVERALL GENERAL
FUND SURPLUS TO ALLOCATE IN THE
REVISION. THE LARGEST CATEGORIES
OF SPENDING FROM THE OVERALL
GENERAL FUND SURPLUS. ARE FOR
NATURAL RESOURCES AND
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS AND THE
MAJORITY OF THEM ARE ONE TIME OR
TEMPORARY IN NATURE OF 95%
ACTUALLY. THE NEXT MAJOR THING
WEFOUND IS THAT THE STATE
APPROPRIATIONS LIMIT FOR THE
SOUTH CONTINUES TO BE A
CONSTRAINT ON THE BUDGET. I'M
NOT GOING TO GO THROUGH THE
MECHANICS OF THE SOUTH TODAY BUT
IF IT IS ACTUALLY LIMITS HOW THE
STATE CAN USE. REVENUES THAT
CUTS THAT IT COLLECTS THAT
EXCEED A CERTAIN LIMIT AND WHEN
THOSE REVENUES EXCEED THAT LIMIT
WE HAVE A CELL REQUIREMENT AND
THE STATE HAS TO SPEND THOSE
REVENUES ON CERTAIN ACTIVITIES.
EXAMPLES OF THOSE ACTIVITIES
THAT THE REVENUES MUST BE SPENT
ON INCLUDE TAX REDUCTIONS OR
REFUNDS OR PROPOSALS THAT ARE
CONSIDERED TO BE EXCLUDED. AND
THOSE THAT- INCLUDE SUCH THINGS
AS EMERGENCY SPENDING CAPITAL
OUTLAY OR FLEXIBLE- DIMENSIONS
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. IT'S
BECAUSE OF THESE CONSTRAINTS
THAT WE SPEAK ABOUT WHAT WE SEE
IN THE MAY REVISION AS THAT IT
SPENDS. THIRTY NINE BILLION OF
THE SURPLUS ON PROPOSALS THAT
MEET THE STATE APPROPRIATION
REQUIREMENTS THIS IS ABOUT 66%
OF THAT OVERALL SURPLUS BEING
SPENT ON THOSE. PROPOSALS THAT
MEET THE REQUIREMENTS. THE TWO
LARGEST CATEGORIES OF THOSE
PROPOSALS ARE ELEVEN POINT FIVE.
BILLION FOR TAX REFUNDS AND
ABOUT TWENTY TWO BILLION FOR
CAPITAL OUTLAY. SO ALTHOUGH THE
ADMINISTRATION MEETS THE SOUTH
REQUIREMENTS ACROSS TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. OUR ANALYSIS FINDS
THAT THE GOVERNOR DOES LEAVE
THREE POINT FOUR BILLION AND AN
ADDRESS OUR REQUIREMENTS IN THE
BUDGET YEAR SO IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE. AND ALTHOUGH THIS
LEVEL OF AN ADDRESS SALAS IS
RELATIVELY SMALL. THE SALAS
REALLY CONSIDERED ON A TWO YEAR
BASIS SO YOU HAVE TO ALSO THINK
ABOUT IT WITH TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR. AND IN THAT YEAR WE
ESTIMATE THE STATE WOULD FACE AN
ADDITIONAL SAU REQUIREMENTS OF
OVER TWENTY BILLION. WITH ONLY A
SURPLUS THAT YEAR ESTIMATED AT
ONE POINT SIX BILLION. YOU'D BE
IN A POSITION WHERE YOU HAVE A
CELL REQUIREMENTS OF OVER TWENTY
FIVE BILLION IN THAT YEAR AND A
SURPLUS THAT IS FAR TOO SMALL TO
PAY FOR IT. FINALLY ALTHOUGH IT
IS REALLY IMPOSSIBLE TO PREDICT
WHEN THE NEXT RECESSION WILL
OCCUR. THERE ARE CERTAIN
ECONOMIC INDICATORS. THAT WE
MONITOR THAT HAS HISTORICALLY
OFFERED SOME WARNING SIGNS THAT
A RECESSION IS ON THE WAY. AND
MANY OF THOSE ARE INDICATING A
HEIGHTENED RISK A RECESSION IN
THE NEXT FEW YEARS. BUT AGAIN
NOT POSSIBLE THERE'S REALLY NO
CERTAINTY AND FORECASTING. AND
AS A RESULT OF ALL OF THESE
FACTORS IN OUR REPORT WE
RECOMMEND INCREASING THE LEVEL
OF RESERVES AFTER PARENTS THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION. WE FIND
THAT THESE ADDITIONAL RESERVES
WILL HELP THE STATE EITHER
ADDRESS THOSE FUTURE SELL
REQUIREMENTS. OR WILL HELP AND
IF THERE IS A BUDGET PROBLEM
THAT RESULTS FROM A FUTURE
RECESSION. BEFORE WE TRANSITION
TO HEAR AN INDIVIDUAL MAY
REVISION PROPOSALS FOR HUMAN
SERVICES WE WANTED TO JUST MAKE
ONE FINAL POINT. AND THAT'S THAT
ALTHOUGH THE SOUR. REALLY DOES
PRESENT SIGNIFICANT CONSTRAINTS
AND REALLY DOES NEED TO BE AN
IMPORTANT CONSIDERATION FOR THE
BUDGET THIS YEAR. WE RECOGNIZE
THAT YOU MAY WANT TO MAKE SOME
AUGMENTATIONS AS PART OF THE
BUDGET THAT DO NOT MEET THOSE
REQUIREMENTS. AND IN THESE CASES
WE REALLY RECOMMEND ASSESSING
WHETHER THE- INTENTIONS MEET
JUST A COUPLE CRITERIA. FIRST
THEY REALLY SHOULD BE THOSE
PROPOSALS THAT ARE OF HIGHEST
PRIORITY TO THE LEGISLATURE.
THEY SHOULD ALSO BE FULLY
DEVELOPED YOU KNOW READY TO GO
READY TO BE IMPLEMENTED. AND
THEY SHOULD ADDRESS UNKNOWN
NEED- AND THE FUNDING SHOULD NOT
BE MORE THAN WHAT IS REASONABLY
EXPECTED TO BE ABLE TO BE SPENT-
IN IN THE BUDGET YEAR. YOU COULD
ALSO CONSIDER PROPOSALS THAT
HAVE OTHER SECONDARY BENEFITS
SUCH AS THE ABILITY TO DRIVE
DOWN ADDITIONAL FEDERAL FUNDING.
THESE ARE JUST SOME OF THE
CRITERIA WE SUGGEST AS YOU
CONSIDER AND WEIGH THE MERITS OF
AUGMENTATION PROPOSALS AND IS.
NOW CONSTRAINED ENVIRONMENT. I
THAT CONCLUDES MY OVERVIEW OF
OUR INITIAL REACTION TO THE
GOVERNOR'S. MAYOR VISION AND
LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING ABOUT
THE OTHER PROPOSALS TODAY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOW IF
THE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. FROM
IF IT IF THE TWO BIGGEST. AREAS. THAT WORD DEBT UP TO BEING
SPENT FOR THE STAR RQUIREMENT
IS TRANSPORTATION AND CLIMATE
CHANGE IS THAT IS FOR THOSE
AREAS THAT YOU WOULD ALSO
SUGGEST THE REDUCTIONS IN. AND
MORE INTO. WELL AND THEN THE
CHALLENGE HERE IS THAT- AT THEIR
OFTEN THAT THE LARGER
AUGMENTATIONS ARE THERE BECAUSE
THEY ARE ALSO IN THOSE XXL
EXCLUDABLE CATEGORIES THE EXTENT
YOU DO NOT DO A PROPOSAL THAT IS
ALREADY YOU KNOW AT A PROPOSAL
THAT HELPS US MEET THIS HOUR
REQUIREMENT- YOU YOU ASK IT
REALLY DOESN'T HELP US WITH THE
OVERALL CELL- CONSTRAINT NUMBER
OKAY. TWO OTHER AREAS OKAY THANK
YOU THANK GOODNESS. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION AND- I DID
HAVE A QUESTION SO WHAT ARE YOUR
RECOMMENDATIONS COURSES ARE
RECOMMENDING CREASING RESERVES-
MY UNDERSTANDING IS RESERVES
ACTUALLY- STILL COUNT TOWARD THE
LIMIT. OTHER PLEASE CORRECT ME
IF I'M WRONG. SO I GUESS THE
QUESTION IS THAT- SO FOR EXAMPLE
IN THE MAY REVISE THE GOVERNOR
IS NOT PROPOSING TO INCREASE THE
SAFETY NET RESERVE WHICH WE
ESTABLISHED- TO GAN BUFFER
AGAINST RECESSION- WHICH TENDS
TO THIS PORSCHE FACTOR STATE
SAFETY NET PROGRAMS. SO WE PUT
MORE MONEY ASIDE INTO- THE LET'S
SAY SAFETY NET RESERVE SO MAKING
A RECOMMENDATION INCREASING
RESERVES. AND THEN WE END UP
SPENDING IS DOWN RECESSION HITS
COULD YOU TALK ABOUT INCREASING
RECESSION RISK AND THEY'LL LET
WE ALSO INFLATION BY THE WAY
THAT WE'RE DEALING WITH. THEN IF
THAT MONEY IS PUT INTO RESERVE
IT COUNTS STILL COUNTS AGAINST
THE LIMIT AND THEN WE SPEND THAT
MONEY BECAUSE THERE'S NOW
INCREASING CASELOAD OR OTHER
TYPES REASONS IS THAT TELL A
GALLON AGAINST THE SPENDING
LIMITS BUT SINCE WE RE ALLOCATE
RESERVE SO CAN. YOU HELP ME
CLARIFY- THAT IS IT BETTER TO
PUT INTO THE SAFETY NET RESERVE
IS A BETTER TO PRE APPROPRIATE
IT'S- MEAN. WHAT TO WHICH WE DO
TO BE SURE WE CAN ACTUALLY.
MAINTAIN A LEVEL SERVICE
ESPECIALLY IF CASELOADS
INCREASE- IS UNFORTUNATELY
USUALLY DO IF THERE'S AN
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN FOR SAFETY NET
PROGRAMS. SO CAN YOU SPEAK TO
THAT WHAT'S THE BEST STRATEGY
FOR TRYING TO DEAL WITH- GIVEN
THE FACT THAT WE HAVE A GOOD
BUDGET THIS YEAR TO BE ABLE TO
BUFFER. AGAINST ESSENTIALLY OUR
COUNTER CYCLICAL. SPENDING WHEN
IT COMES TO HUMAN SERVICES AND
HEALTH LATER WHEN WE HAVE THAT
HEARING LATER BUT WE CERTAINLY
HERE AS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE
HUMAN SERVICES. SO YOU'RE
CORRECT THAT WHEN YOU PUT THE
MONEY IN THE RESERVES IT WOULD
STILL COUNT TOWARDS- CELLS RIGHT
SO IT IT'S NOT X. IT'S NOT
EXCLUDABLE PIECE- WHAT IT REALLY
DOES IT IT IT IT INSURES THAT
WHEN YOU. HIT THAT ADDITIONAL
SELL PRESSURE NEXT YEAR THAT
WE'RE PREDICTING THAT YOU HAVE.
THE FUNDING TO BE ABLE TO
POTENTIALLY PAY FOR AND SPEND ON
THINGS THAT ARE EXCLUDABLE AT
THAT TIME SO THAT'S REALLY. OF
THE MECHANICS OF HOW IT WORKS-
SO IT'S NOT THAT PUTTING IT IN
THE RESERVE IS GOING TO COUNT
TOWARDS MEETING A REQUIREMENT AT
ALL. SO JUST TO CLARIFY SO WE
PUT MORE MONEY INTO THE SAFETY
NET RESERVE. AND THEN- LET'S SAY
CASES INCREASE NEXT YEAR LET'S
SAY THERE'S A I DON'T WISH THAT
HAPPENS BUT IF THERE ISN'T
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN NEXT YEAR THE
YEAR AFTER. AND NOW WE'RE
DRAWING DOWN FROM THAT SAFETY
NET RESERVES. THIS SO IN TERMS
OF THE CELL THE LIMIT DOES IT
DOES IT BACK GET COUNTED TWICE
ARE ONLY GET CAO ONCE BECAUSE
AFTER ALL WE'RE THIS IS WE'RE
NOW QUOTES SPENDING EVEN THOUGH
WE'RE PUTTING INTO RESERVE
AGAINST THAT NOW BY PUTTING INTO
SAFETY NET RESERVE WE ACTUALLY
DRAW DOWN ON THAT. AS THOSE
EXPENDITURES FROM THE DRAWDOWN
ACTUALLY. ALSO COUNT AGAIN OR IS
IT LIKE NO YOU YOU YOU WERE
COUNTED AGAINST THE LIMIT IN
THIS YEAR THE FIRST TIME AND SO
THAT IT DOESN'T COUNT AGAINST
THAT WHEN WE ACTUALLY SEE. YOU
KNOW. AND THAT ONE DURING THE
DOWNTURN. YES NO IT'S A IT'S A
GOOD QUESTION I'M GOING TO
ACTUALLY TAKE IT BACK THE
MECHANICS THAT I JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE YOU THE RIGHT ANSWER
I'M GOING TO TAKE THAT ONE BACK
TO OUR CELL EXPERT ON THE EXACT
ACCOUNTING WHEN YOU WOULD DRAW
DOWN ON A RESERVE IN THE
FOLLOWING YEAR. AND GET BACK TO
YOU ON THAT THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION OKAY THAT THAT WOULD BE
IMPORTANCE WERE TRYING TO
STRATEGIZE IS TO BEGIN TO TAKE A
RECOMMENDATION INCREASING
RESERVES. YOU KNOW IN TERMS OF
WHAT SHOULD BE THE BEST
STRATEGY. FOR US TO BE ABLE TO.
DISTRIBUTE THE MONEY WHETHER
IT'S PUTTING RESERVES OF FOR. IT
YOU KNOW IN PREPARATION TO. FOUR
EIGHT ECONOMIC DOWNTURN WHERE
YOU KNOW WE MAY HAVE AN INCREASE
IN. DEMAND AND INDICATE A
CASELOAD FOR OUR SAFETY NET
PROGRAMS. SO THAT WE DON'T HAVE
TO MAKE KIND OF CUTS THAT LEAST
I HAD EXPERIENCE MAKING. WHEN I
FIRST CAME THE LEGISLATURE SO
YOUR HELP AND ASSISTANCE IN
ANALYZING THAT WOULD BE REALLY
APPRECIATED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. WE DEFINITELY A DEPEND UPON
YOUR EXPERTISE AND I THINK WE
ALL WE ALL READ THE YEAH- THE
REPORT WE CAME OUT AND ARE
ALWAYS A VERY IMPRESSED WITH
HOW. HOW QUICK YOU CAN TURN
AROUND. AND LOOK FORWARD TO US
BEING ABLE TO. DIVE DEEPER INTO
THE DETAILS AS WE- AS WE GO
FORWARD. OKAY AND THEN SO MOVING
ON TO THE REST OF OUR
INFORMATIONAL- ITEMS WILL START
WITH AN OVERVIEW OF THE MEAT
REVISION PROPOSALS WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT- OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
AND THE L. A. O.'S GONNA PRESENT
AGAIN. READY. FROM THE FINANCE
FIRMS ARE DEPARTING FINANCE. I
AM THIS IS JEANNIE DR IN THE
FRONT WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I FINANCE WILL BE
PROVIDING A FREE THREE LEVEL
OVERVIEW OF THE ISSUES ARE
OUTLINED THE COMMITTEE'S AGENDA
AND WE ALSO KNOW THAT A DETAILED
LIST OF CHANGES WERE OUTLINED IN
THE MAY FINANCE WATER EVERY PART
OF THE LEGISLATURE ON FRIDAY MAY
THIRTEENTH. AND SO OVERALL THE
MIRAGEN INCLUDES ABOUT FORTY TWO
BILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
PHARMACEUTICAL SERVICES PROGRAMS
AND BUDGET YEAR- IN THAT
INCLUDES AND THAT INCREASE OF
ABOUT ONE POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS RESULTING FROM UP THE TO
KEYSTONE ESTIMATES WHEN COMPARED
TO THE JANUARY GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. REVISED HOW WORKS
CASELOAD REFLECTS AN EIGHT POINT
1% DECREASE COMPARED TO
GOVERNMENT'S BUDGET REVISED CALL
FRESH CASELOAD FOR BUDGET YEAR
REFLECTS A TWO POINT 3% DECREASE
COMPARED TO GOVERNMENT'S BUDGET.
AND THE REVISED ARE YOU JUST AS
CASE LOAD ALSO REFLECTS A ZERO
POINT 3% INCREASE COMPARED TO
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND REVISED AS
A SITE AS AS P. CASELOAD
REFLECTS ABOUT A ONE POINT 1%
INCREASE WHEN. COMPARED TO
GOVERNOR'S PROJECT- THE MEMBER
OF A ALSO IN A PER MAXIMUM AGE
PAYMENT INCREASE FOR CAO WORKS
BASED ON REVISED COVERAGE HE
SLOWED ESTIMATES AS WELL AS
PROJECTED SALES TAX AND DEALER
REVENUES. ADDITIONALLY THE MAY
RVISION INCLUDES RESOURCES FOR
COUNTY HUMAN SERVICES AGENCIES
TO COMPLY WITH CHAPTER FIVE
SEVENTY STATUTES IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE OR ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN TWENTY SIX WHICH
REQUIRED COUNTY HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCIES TO HIRE STAFF LIAISONS
THAT WOULD INTERFACE BETWEEN-
INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER EDUCATION
AND COUNTY WELFARE HUMAN
SERVICES DEPARTMENTS. I'M AT
THIS POINT I'LL DEFER TO MY
COLLEAGUEJUSTIN FREITAS FOR THE
BRIEFING ON CHILD WELFARE
SERVICES PROGRAM INVESTMENTS.
THANK YOU. OKAY MISTER FREEZE
DOES RAISE BERMAN FINANCE THANK
YOU BERMAN CHARITY- ME REGION
INCLUDES A PRICING NINE EIGHTEEN
MILLION GENERAL FINDS IN BUDGET
YEAR HER SERVICES TO CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES AND THE CHILD
WELFARE SERVICES PROGRAMS- HIGH
LEVEL SOME OF THE MAJOR
INVESTMENTS THE ADMINISTRATION
IS PROPOSING IS A ONE TIME ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION GENERAL
FUND BLOCK GRANTS AVAILABLE FOR
FIVE YEARS THE SUPPORT FAMILY
FINING. ENGAGEMENT ACTIVITIES
AND COUNTY- THIS PURPOSE SIMPLY
TRAILER LANGUAGE AND ONE OF THE
COMPONENTS OF IT IS IT'S AN
OPTION PROGRAM FOR COUNTIES AND
WOULD REQUIRE A ONE TO ONE
COUNTY MATCH. ADDITIONALLY THE
MAYOR VISION INCLUDES AN ONGOING
FIFTY MILLION GENERAL FUND- TO
ASSIST COUNTIES WITH REDUCING.
CAREGIVER APPROVAL TIMELINES FOR
FOSTER CARE GIVERS. ALSO THE-
REYES SOMEWHAT RELATED TO THAT
IS AN EXTENSION OF A GOOD CAR
AND DITION EXCUSE ME OF A GOOD
BECAUSE EXEMPTION FOR EMERGENCY
CARE GIVERS- THE CURRENT LOSS
WOULD QUIT AND BUDGET YEAR- THAT
COUNTIES REQUIRED TO APPROVE A
RESOURCE FAMILY. APPROVAL
APPLICATION WITHIN NINETY DAYS
AND AFTER THAT- IF IT TAKES
LONGER THE STATE WILL NOT.
ASSIST WITH COVERING THE NON
FEDERAL SHARE OF AN EMERGENCY
JANET IN MINUTES PROVIDED THOSE
CARE GIVERS. ARE THIS PROPOSAL
WOULD EXTEND TO THAT- THE STATE
COVERAGE OF THE NON FEDERAL
SHARE FOR AN ADDITIONAL TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS. FOR ANY
APPLICATION THAT NEEDS US
SPECIFIED GOOD CAUSE REASON. FOR
NOT BEING COMPLETED IN NINETY
DAYS. ADDITIONALLY THERE IS UP
TEN POINT THREE MILLION. OF
COURSE SHORT TERM THERAPEUTIC
RESIDENTIAL PROGRAMS- THAT ARE
CURRENTLY GOING THROUGH THE
PROCESS OF BEING CLASSIFIED
FEDERALLY AS AN INSTITUTION FOR
MENTAL DISEASES. THE DEPARTMENT
OF YOUR SERVICES IS WORKING WITH
OTHER GOVERNMENT ON A WAIVER.
YOU SEE IF WE CAN- REMOVE THAT
CLASSIFICATION FROM SOME OF
THESE PLACEMENT OPTIONS FOR
FOSTER CHILDREN. AND WHILE
THAT'S GOING ON THE STATE'S
INCLUDING OF ACTUALLY COVER THAT
WHILE SOME OF THOSE FACILITIES
TRANSITION. TO A LOWER BED COUNT
IS REQUIRED BY. THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO LOSE THAT
CLASSIFICATION. AND THEN
ADDITIONALLY THERE IS A HUNDRED
EIGHTY MILLION FUNDING THE- FOR
THE CHILD WELFARE'S- CALIFORNIA
ANIMATORS AND ENGAGEMENT SYSTEM
NOTICE YOU KNOW YES CARES. WHICH
IS THE AUTOMATED SYSTEM FOR
CHILD FOSTER FOR SERVICES THAT
COUNTIES UTILIZE OF THE STATE
FOR TRACKING. FOSTER CARE NEEDS
. AND WITH THAT I'M GONNA GO
AHEAD AND- TRANSITIONAL WORDS MY
COLLEAGUES IN ON IT BECAUSE EACH
YEAR DISCUSS ANY OF THE-
INVESTMENTS IN THE ADULT
PROGRAMS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WELCOME HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON
NAMIKAZE WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I'LL BE COVERING UPDATES
TO THE IN HOME SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES I JUST LAST PERMANENT
BACKUP PROVIDER SYSTEM. IN THE
REGION INCLUDES THIRTY FOUR
POINT FOUR MILLION TOTAL PLANS
AND FIFTEEN POINT FOUR MILLION
GENERAL FUND ON GOING TO
ESTABLISH A PERMANENT BACKUP
PROVIDER SYSTEM FOR I JUST S.
RECIPIENTS. RELATIVE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS UPDATED THE
PROPOSAL TO ALLOW FOR A
TRANSITION PERIOD BETWEEN JULY
AND OCTOBER TWENTY TWENTY TWO
WITH THE STATEWIDE
IMPLEMENTATION DATE NOW FALLING
ON OCTOBER TWENTY TWENTY TWO. I
SUCH ONE FOURTH OF THE FUNDING
IN THE MAY REVISION CAN BE USED
BY COUNTIES AND PUBLIC
AUTHORITIES FOR TRANSITION
ACTIVITIES. ADDITIONALLY COSTS
HAVE BEEN REVISED BY
APPROXIMATELY TEN MILLION TOTAL
PLAN AND FORMALLY GENERAL PLAN.
TO NOW ALLOW FOR AN EXEMPTION TO
THE EIGHTY OUR ANNUAL LIMIT UP
TO ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTY HOURS.
IN CERTAIN SEVERELY IMPAIRED
CASES. THE MEASURE SHOULD ALSO
NOTE THAT WE ARE WORKING
DILIGENTLY ON GETTING THE
UPDATES TO STATUTORY CHANGES
PUBLIC SHORTEN- WITHOUT THAT IS
IT FOR AN UPDATE TO ADULT
PROGRAMS AND I WILL PASS IT ON
TO MY COLLEAGUE. CHRIS WELCOME
IS CARS. I'M IN IMMIGRATION
SERVICES SPACE- THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSING- ONE
TIME A HUNDRED ONE HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
GENERAL FUND APPROPRIATION
AVAILABLE FOR TWO YEARS FOR THE
RAPID RESPONSE PROGRAM TO
SUPPORT MIGRANT ARRIVALS AT THE
SOUTHERN BORDER AND FUNDING FOR
A RANGE OF EMERGING ISSUES
RELATED TO MIGRANT SUPPORT
SERVICES CASE MANAGEMENT AND
TARGETED DISASTER RELIEF ARE
SIMILAR TO PRIOR RESPONSES TO
CRITICAL NEEDS. THE MARRIAGE AND
ALSO INCLUDES AT TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
AND TWENTY TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE AND TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT JUSTICE FELLOWSHIP TO
PROVIDE GRANTS. AND CONTRACTS TO
SUPPORT FELLOWSHIPS FOR
IMMIGRATION ATTORNEYS TO DEFEND
CALIFORNIA'S RESIDENTS AGAINST
DEPORTATION AND FAMILY
SEPARATION. AND THE REVISION
ALSO INCLUDES A ONE TIME TWENTY
FIVE MILLION GENERAL FUND TO
SUPPORT PLACEMENT AND SERVICES
FOR YOU HAVE BEEN IMPACTED BY
MARSHALL SEXUAL EXPLOITATION AND
TO DEVELOP A TARGETED TRAINING
CURRICULA FOR CHILD WELFARE
AGENCIES. AND THEIR MULTI
DISCIPLINARY PARTNERS WILL
INTERACT WITH IMPACT HE- AND
YOUR VISION ALSO INCLUDES- BUT
TWELVE MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND TO SUPPORT PROMISE
NEIGHBORHOODS IN CHULA VISTA
CORNING HEY WORD AND MISSION. AS
THE FEDERAL FUNDING THAT HAS
SUPPORTED THESE ORGANIZATIONS
WILL BE EXPIRING. MY GOD I WILL
PASS IT TO MY COLLEAGUES
TOMORROW WEBER CHILD CARE. THANK
YOU MCAS WEBER. YOU TO MY WEBER
DEPARTMENT CHINESE THANK YOU
CHAIR EGGMAN RUN THE FAMILY FEE
WAIVERS PROPOSAL PROVIDES A
HUNDRED THIRTY SIX MILLION IN
ONE TIME FEDERAL FUNDS TO EXTEND
THE FAMILY SEE WAIVERS FOR STATE
SUBSIDIZED CHILD CARE AND
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS FROM JULY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO TO JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY THREE.
THE HOLD HARMLESS PROPOSAL
EXPENSE REIMBURSEMENT OF CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS FOR AUTHORIZED
HOURS OF CARE RATHER THAN ACTUAL
HOURS OF CARE FROM JULY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY TO. THIRTY EIGHT
POINT TWENTY THREE AND PROVIDES
A HUNDRED FOURTEEN MILLION SIX
MILLION GENERAL FUND AND A
HUNDRED EIGHTY ONE TIME FEDERAL
PLANS. TO DO SO. THE CHILD CARE
AND DEVELOPMENT INFRASTRUCTURE
GRANT PROGRAM AUGMENTATION
PROPOSAL PROVIDES TWO HUNDRED
POINT FIVE MILLION ONE HUNDRED
NINE ONE TIME GENERAL FUND ONE
HUNDRED POINT FIVE MILLION
POINTS FEDERAL FUNDS. IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE FOR MINOR
RENOVATION AND REPAIR FOCUSED ON
CHILD CARE DESERTS AND LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES. THE
ALTERNATE PAYMENT PROGRAM
CAPACITY GRANTS PROPOSAL
PROVIDES TWENTY MILLION GENERAL
FUND TO ASSIST ALTERNATE PAYMENT
PROGRAMS IN DEVELOPING CAPACITY
TO SERVE. ADDITIONAL SLOT
COMMITMENTS AND FINALLY THE MAY
REVISION INCLUDES NINE HUNDRED
NINETY TWO MILLION TO ANALYZE
THE CHILD CARE SLOTS BEING ADDED
IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. AND TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY MILLION FOR THE CHILD-
SLOTS TO ADD INTO SCHOOL YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE.
THIS CONCLUDES THE VISION
INVESTMENTS FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES MY FINANCE
COLLEAGUES AND DIRECTOR JOHNSON
ARE AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH HELLO
ANY COMMENTS. WHEN BRISTOW WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
- I JUST WANTED TO FLAG THAT WE
ARE STILL IN THE PROCESS OF
REVIEWING MAY REVISION AND WILL
DEFINITELY REPORT BACK TO THAT
SUB COMMITTEE- WITH ANY
PARTICULAR FINDINGS BUT INCLUDED
IN OUR ANALYSIS ONE THING THAT
WE TYPICALLY LOOK INTO IS-
ASSESSING WOULD BE
ADMINISTRATIONS CASELOAD
ESTIMATES ALSO CONDUCTING OUR
OWN CASELOAD ESTIMATES- BUT
CROSS DSS PROGRAMS INCLUDING CAO
WORKS I JUST SAYS INVESTORS
SCIENCES P. AND THIS IS
IMPORTANT BECAUSE- CASELOAD
ESTIMATES REALLY MAKE UP THE
UNDERLYING COST ESTIMATES FROM
WITHIN THE PROGRAMS AND THAT.
PROPOSALS FROM THAT MAKE UP THE
MAY REVISION- ONE EXAMPLE- THAT
IS- RELATED TO THE-
ADMINISTRATION'S ESTIMATE OF THE
S. P. GRANT INCREASE- I'M
INTENDED TO BE PROVIDE IN
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY FOUR- I'M
IN JANUARY IT WAS ESTIMATED THAT
THE- THE GRANT INCREASE WOULD BE
ABOUT A TWENTY FOUR PERCENT- IT
TAKE EFFECT JANUARY TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR WITH THE COST US
ABOUT BY. TWO BIASED S. S. P. S.
ISIS BECAME SORT OF STUDENTS AND
MAY EVEN RESTRICTIONS NOW
ESTIMATING THAT THE ACTUAL GRANT
INCREASE WILL BE ABOUT 20% SO
SLIGHTLY LOWER- WHILE THE ACTUAL
ISSUES BE GRANTED CREASE WON'T
BE FINALIZED UNTIL NEXT YEAR-
THIS IS JUST ANOTHER REASON WHY
WE'RE LOOKING AT- CASELOAD- TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND. THE ESTIMATES
BEHIND EITHER BUDGET YEAR OR
FUTURE. COSTS PROPOSALS- BUT
THEN ALSO GETTING A BETTER SENSE
OF- TRACKING WHAT THAT ACTUAL SP
GRADING CREASE COULD BE AS WE'RE
CONTINUING TO TRACK- FACTUAL
CASELOADS AS THEY COME AND- AT
THIS POINT I'M GOING TO TURN TO
MY COLLEAGUE ANGELA SHORT TO
PROVIDE COMMENTS ON CHILD
WELFARE FOR POLLS. THANK YOU
WELCOME A SHORT. THANK YOU AGAIN
AND LET'S START WITH THE L. A-
O. GOOD AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS
JUST A FEW HIGH LEVEL COMMENTS
ON SOME KEY AUGMENTATIONS- FOR
CHILDREN'S PROGRAMS THESE ARE
THE PROPOSAL'S DESCRIBED ON PAGE
SEVENTEEN OF YOUR AGENDA.
OVERALL BASED ON OUR PRELIMINARY
REVIEW WE DO FIND THAT THESE
PROPOSALS ALIGNED WITH THE GOALS
OF THE CHILD WELFARE CONTINUUM
OF CARE REFORM- AND IN CONCEPT
WOULD SUPPORT CRITICAL
COMPONENTS OF OVER ARCHING CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM FUNCTIONING. SUCH
AS ENSURING THAT SUFFICIENT
NUMBERS OF RESOURCE FAMILIES ARE
APPROVED IN A TIMELY MANNER HAT
EMERGENCY CARE GIVERS RECEIVE
FUNDING WHILE COMPLETING
RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL. AND
THAT FOSTER USED CAN BE PLACED
WITH RELATIVES AND FAMILY BASED
SETTINGS TO THE EXTENT POSSIBLE
- IN PARTICULAR WE DON'T JUST
WANT TO NOTE THAT THE CARE GIVER
APPROVAL AUGMENTATION AND
PLACEMENT PRIOR TO APPROVAL- AT
PROPOSAL. WOULD PROVIDE
AUGMENTATIONS IN AREAS WHERE WE
PREVIOUSLY HAVE RECOMMENDED THE
LEGISLATURE CONSIDER ADDITIONAL
FUNDING- THAT SET. UP WILL BE
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO ENSURE WE
UNDERSTAND HOW THE SPECIFIC
AUGMENTATION AMOUNTS WERE
DETERMINED. AND WILL BE SURE TO
RAISE ANY- QUESTIONS OR OR
CONCERNS FOR THE LEGISLATURE AS
WE CONTINUE OUR IF YOU. AND
FINALLY JUST IMPOSING I WANTED
TO KNOW WE HAVE- A FEW OTHER L.
A. O. COLLEAGUES ON THE LINE
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS REGARDING- TOWERS
CHILD CARE OTHER DSS PROGRAM
AREAS- ALTHOUGH WE DON'T HAVE
ANY OTHER SPECIFIC COMMENTS ON
THOSE AREAS AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU. OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND I ALSO SEE DIRECTOR JOHNSON
HAS JOINED US OF THANK YOU
DIRECTOR FOR BEING HERE AS WELL-
BUT YET WE THINK THE L. A-
ESPECIALLY LOOKING AT. THE
PROJECTED CASELOAD BECAUSE WE
KNOW. THEY HAVEN'T BEEN AS
CONSISTENT DURING TO THE
PANDEMIC WE HAVEN'T SEEN SOME OF
THE RISES AND SOME OF THE AREAS
THAT WE THOUGHT WE'D SEE AN- AND
CERTAINLY INCREASES IN OTHER
AREAS SO THAT'S I THINK GOING TO
BE. VERY IMPORTANT. AND I TO THE
L. A. O. OR MAYBE TO THE-
DIRECTOR JOHN TONIGHT. MY
PARTICULAR AREA OF INTEREST AND
CONCERN IS- AROUND CHILD WELFARE
AND SOME OF THE- SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT WE HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE
TO HIT AND I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE TRYING TO SOLVE.
THE RIGHT THE RIGHT PROBLEM IN
THE RIGHT WAY AND IF WE NEED IF
WE NEED SOME OF LEGISLATIVE
ADJUSTMENTS ENABLED TO DO THAT-
WITH THE- ENABLE TO GET KIDS OUT
OF. THE RESIDENTIAL THERAPEUTIC
PROGRAMS THAT HAS BEEN A BIT
DIFFICULT AND ALSO I KNOW IT'S
DIFFICULT TO FIND LOVING. HOMES
FOR KIDS WITH A LOT OF HIGH HIGH
LEVEL VERY COMPLEX NEEDS AND
WHILE THAT IS. A GREAT GOAL TO
SHOOT FOR IT'S HARDER IN
REALITY. SO I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT AS WE CONTINUE TO TRY
TO FIND- WHAT'S EXISTING AND
WHAT WE CURRENTLY REQUIRE. IF
THAT'S ACTUALLY THE BEST WAY
THAT WE SHOULD BE GOING ABOUT
DOING THINGS FOR THE KIDS-
TORONTO IF DIRECTOR JOHNSON IF
YOU JUST HAVE ANY INPUT IN INTO
THAT ANY THOUGHTS ABOUT THAT. I
MEAN ARE WE JUST THROWING GOOD
MONEY AFTER BAD TRYING TO MAKE.
MAKE IT HOW WE HAVE IT
STRUCTURED RIGHT NOW WORK OR DO
WE NEED TO DO. SOMETHING
DIFFERENT. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION SURE CAN JOHNSON
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES AND I WOULD I WOULD
JUST ECHO AS I THINK BELIAU JUST
NOTED THAT THE INVESTMENTS THAT
WE'RE PROPOSING IN MAY REVISION
ARE REALLY FOCUSED ON ENSURING
THAT WE CAN REACH THOSE OUTCOMES
THAT WE KNOW. THAT RESULTS IN
THE BEST OF FOR OUR YOUTH IN THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM SO IT'S
REALLY LOOKING AT THAT. ABILITY
TO BOTH RECRUIT AND RETAIN THE
AND HAVE LESS DESTRUCTION AND
PLACEMENT FOR FOSTER YOUTH WITH
THE- AT PACKAGE OF INVESTMENTS
THAT YOU HAVE IN FRONT OF YOU.
ARE THAT THAT SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT IN THE FAMILY FINDING
ENGAGEMENT AND SUPPORT
COMPONENT- IS REALLY GEARED TO
DO JUST THAT IT IS ALSO BASED ON
SOME OF THAT HIGHLY YOU SEEN IN
SOME COUNTIES THAT HAVE RESULTED
IN THOSE OUTCOMES THAT WE ARE
TRYING TO CHEAT SO AGAIN WE'RE
LOOKING AT THE EVIDENCE. WE ARE
ENGAGING OUT WEST USE THAT WITH
THE COUNTY SPLITS THE ACTIVITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS AND
PROVIDERS. ADDRESS THE PACKAGE
OF INVESTMENT YOU HAVE FOR US TO
REACH THOSE GOALS. AND OUTCOMES
THAT WE'RE STRIVING TOWARDS
TOGETHER. OKAY THANK YOU- WE
WILL KEEP. WILL KEEP MONITORING
THAT AND CERTAINLY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WORK. BUT APPARENTLY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU- JUST MAYBE
A FEW- JUST DETAILS TO ROUND OUT
AB SO. UNDER THE CHILD WELFARE
CHILDREN'S PROGRAM THE FINDINGS-
FAMILY FINING ENGAGEMENT- I KNOW
YOU PROPOSING UNDER FIFTY
MILLION THE ONE TIME.
UNDERSTANDS THAT AND IS THAT THE
ONE WHERE YOU'RE REQUIRING A
COUNTY MATCH AND CAN YOU MAYBE
SPEAK TO THE REASON FOR THE
COUNTY MATCH OURS I MEAN. SURE
SURE CAN JOHNSON WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES AT
SENATOR YES WE ARE PROPOSING A
COUNTY MATCH IN THIS.
INVESTMENTS IN THAT SUIT FIRST I
WOULD JUST SAY THAT THE FAMILY
FINDING ENGAGEMENT COMPONENT IS
A CURRENT RESPONSIBILITY. AT THE
COUNTIES ARE ENGAGED AND SO WHAT
WE ARE LOOKING FOR IS BUILDING
AND LEVERAGING AT THAT RESOURCE
AND COMMITMENT I WITH THIS
ADDITIONAL FUNDING CHANGE IN
SURE WE'RE UTILIZING AGAIN THE
EVIDENCE AND THAT THE PARTNERS
THAT WE HAVE THE SPACE TO HAVE.
THAT RESULTED IN THE GREATEST
OUTCOMES AND GOING FORWARD SO
WE'RE LEVERAGING LOCAL MESSENGER
DOESN'T OPTIONAL ADD PROGRAM FOR
PARTICIPATION AS WE ARE
PROPOSING OKAY AND- WILL THE
DEPARTMENT BE MONITORING TO BE
SURE WE DON'T ACTUALLY INCREASE
DISPARITIES BETWEEN COUNTIES SO
THERE MAY BE SOME COUNTIES WHO
ARE WILLING TO PRIORITIZE AND
INVEST MORE. IN FAMILY FINDING
AND- GRADY COUNTIES THAT DON'T
DO AS MUCH SO WITH THE MATCH.
IT'S POSSIBLE THAT WE COULD SEE
GREATER DISPARITIES BETWEEN
COUNTIES AND THEIR EFFORTS TO DO
SO RIGHT. SO IS THAT SOMETHING
THE DEPARTMENT'S GONNA
MONITORING SO THAT WE CAN.
ENSURE THAT- BOSTROM ARE YOU
KNOW OF. YOUTH WE'RE TRYING TO
FIND TO PAY IT'S A ARE AT THAT-
WILL THAT. WHERE WHICH COUNTY
THEY'LL IN DOESN'T TO BE A- AND
WHETHER THEY'RE GOING TO BE ABLE
TO PLACE AND THE PLACE THEIR
FAMILIES. ABSOLUTELY APPRECIATE
THAT QUESTION AND THAT AND WE
HAVE A COMMITMENT TO DOING THAT
SENATOR AND I WOULD JUST NOTE
THAT THE- KIND OF FINDINGS IN
THE AND THAT WORK IN WHICH WE
ARE SEEING THOSE GREATEST
OUTCOMES WILL BE SHARED ACROSS
COUNTIES NO MATTER WHETHER R
NOT THEY PARTICIPATE. IN THIS
PARTICULAR INVESTMENT SO BUT I
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT POINT AN
ABSOLUTELY PART OF OUR PROCESS
OKAY ALL RIGHT SO I THINK JUST
IMPORTANT TO MONITOR THAT- YEAH
THE QUESTION ACTUALLY IS THE
CHILD WELFARE SERVICE THE-
CALIFORNIA MADE RESPONSE
STATEMENT. WHICH I UNDERSTAND IS
A- FOR RED YOU KNOW. TECHNOLOGY
APPLE- IS THAT SOME OF MONEY
ACTUALLY FOR THE ACTUAL.
IMPLEMENT THOSE AS DESIGN
DEVELOPMENT IMPLEMENTATION SO I
JUST WANNA CLARIFY SO ARE WE
GETTING FOR OUR MONEY IS OVER
GETTING A NEW SYSTEM IS JUST THE
PLANNING PHASE. WHAT WHAT IS IT
THAT WERE ACTUALLY PAYING THE
HUNDRED EIGHT MILLION FORCE DO
WE GET A NEW USE TECHNOLOGY
SOLUTION FOR THIS ISSUE OR IS
THAT ONLY PART OF THE- COST. YES
SENATOR AGAIN JIM JOHNSON THE
DEPARTMENT ADVANCED AT THE
FUNDING THAT WE NEED AT IN LINE
WITH OUR LATEST SPECIAL PROJECTS
FIVE ESTIMATE FOR THIS PROJECT
SO. THAT I THINK TOWARDS THAT
THE CREATION OF THAT NEW SYSTEM
THAT'S CORRECT SO THE SUM OF
MONEY. WHEN YOU COME BACK TO US
AND SAID OKAY WE WERE ABLE TO
COMPLETE THE PROJECT WE HAVE THE
SYSTEM IT'S UP AND RUNNING IT'S
ADDRESS THAT'S THAT THAT'S THE
SUM OF MONEY IT TAKES TO DO THAT
THAT WE'RE ESTIMATING RIGHT NOW
CORRECT. CORRECT OKAY ALL RIGHT
JUST AS WELL BE SURE SITES IS
ALWAYS NOT CLEAR WHAT. WHEN IT
COMES TO TECHNOLOGY MONEY
EXACTLY WHAT WE ACTUALLY. HOW
MUCH WE'RE PAYING FOR- WHAT'S
PAYING FOR SO- AND THEN- OKAY-
AND THEN THE OTHER- AND I GUESS
THE OTHER QUESTION IS IN TERMS
OF. CHILD CARE AND STAND IN THE
MAY REVISE- WELL I SEE THERE'S A
CORRECTION ERROR IN THE PREVIOUS
BUDGET. THERE'S NO THERE'S NO
PROPOSAL TO INCREASE LOTS OR
PAYMENT FOR CHILD CARE IN THE
MAY REVISE AND- IT'S BEYOND
THAT. THOSE PROPOSED IN THE
JANUARY BUDGET. THERE'S ACTUALLY
A PROPOSAL TO INCREASE OUR TOTAL
COMMITMENT FOR BUDGET YEAR FIVE
THIRTY SIX THOUSAND ADDITIONAL
CHILDCARE SUBSIDIES FOR OKAY
THAT'S A- YEAH. IT WOULD BRING
THE TOTAL TO A HUNDRED FORTY
FIVE THOUSAND. AT IN TOTALITY
CURRENT YEAR LAST BUDGET YEAR
AND THEN OF COURSE WE ARE
WORKING TOWARDS THAT GOAL AND
COMMITMENT TO EXPAND TO TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND. MITCHELL TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND SETS THESE BY
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX. OKAY SO
THAT'S NEW FOR ME REVISED IN
ADDITION TO US BECAUSE IN
JANUARY OKAY ALL RIGHT. WANT TO
CLARIFY OKAY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND WE WOULD ALSO
NOTE THAT MANY OF THE PROPOSALS
ARE- OUR TO OUR TIED TO BEING
ABLE TO ACCEPT FEDERAL FUNDING.
FOR A LOT OF PROGRAMS THAT
EXISTS A LOT OF WHAT WE'RE DOING
TODAY IS ALSO ALIGNING OURSELVES
WITH THE FEDERAL FOR POLICIES
AND GUIDELINES TO BE ABLE TO
LEVERAGE. AS MUCH OF MONEY FOR
PROGRAMS AS WE POSSIBLY CAN.
OKAY I'M GONNA HOLD THAT OPEN
AND WE'RE GONNA MOVE ALONG TO
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
AGING. GOOD AFTERNOON CHEN
MEMBERS WHETHER FOR MONDAY GAS
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
I'LL BE PRESENTING TODAY. MAYBE
VISION PROPOSALS. FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF AGING I
AM JOINED TODAY WITH DEPUTY
DIRECTOR THOMAS CAMERON. WILL BE
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE ON THESE PROPOSALS- SO THE
MAYOR VISION PROPOSES
INVESTMENTS DRAWING
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY FOUR
MILLION GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE. AND
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY SEVEN
MILLION GENERAL FUND I'M GOING
TO FURTHER SUPPORT THE MASTER
PLAN FOR AGING AND DEPARTMENT
PROGRAM OPERATIONS. MORE
SPECIFICALLY THE MAYOR VISION
PROPOSES A TOTAL OF EIGHT POINT
NINE MILLION GENERAL FUND FOR A
STAFFING- AND IN ADDITION TO
PROVISIONAL LINE WHICH-
SPECIFICALLY FOR MILLION OF THIS
AMOUNT AS ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
TO DEVELOP A NON MEDICAL
STATEWIDE ROAD MAP. IS IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES. AND TO
ALSO SUPPORT THE DEVELOPMENT OF
FARMING COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES
FOR INDIVIDUALS REGARDLESS OF
INCOME AND UNDERSERVED AREA. THE
MAYOR VISION ALSO PROPOSES THREE
POINT FIVE MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT A LONG
TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN OUTREACH
CAMPAIGN- THIS IS TO RAISE
AWARENESS OF. THE RESOURCES
AVAILABLE TO RESIDENTS AND
FAMILIES AND SKILLED NURSING
ASSISTED LIVING AND OTHER
RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES- IN
ADDITION APPROXIMATELY ONE POINT
ONE MILLION- I'M GOING GENERAL
FUND AND STAFFING. IS INCLUDED
IN THE MAYOR VISION TO ESTABLISH
THE AGING AND DISABILITY
INSTITUTE OF LEARNING AND
INNOVATION AND TO. AND TO-
DEVELOP RESOURCES TO BETTER
RESPOND TO STATE EMERGENCIES AND
NATURAL DISASTERS- FOR CARE
GIVER RESOURCE CENTER
SPECIFICALLY THE MAYOR VISION
PROPOSES TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
AND THE TRANSFER OF ROUGHLY
FIFTEEN MILLION ONGOING GENERAL
FUND. AND OVERSIGHT OF THE CARE
GIVER RESOURCE CENTER PROGRAM
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF AGING. IS REQUEST ALSO
INCLUDES- ROUGHLY SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND I'M GOING GENERAL FUND
FOR STATEWIDE TRAINING AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. THE MAYOR
VISION ALSO INCLUDES- TEN
MILLION GENERAL FUND ONGOING AND
STAFFING FOR THE CARE COURT
SUPPORTER PROGRAM- I WILL NOTE
THAT GIVEN THAT THIS IS ADAMANT
AND ADMINISTRATION SPONSORED
LEGISLATION THE MAYOR VERSION
INCLUDES RESOURCES FOR STATE
DEPARTMENT ACTION AND JUDICIAL
FRENCH COST. AND WHAT WE WILL
CONTINUE TO MONITOR AS THIS
LEGISLATION MOVES THROUGH THE
POLICY PROCESS I WILL WORK WITH
THE LEGISLATURE TO THE EXTENT
THESE ESTIMATES CHANGE- FOR THE
STATE ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS TO-
FOR. I'M AND ADDITIONALLY THE
MAYOR VERSION INCLUDES VARIOUS
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENTS ONE ON THE
TRANSFER OF THE MULTIPURPOSE
SENIOR SERVICES PROGRAM FROM-
CDA TO DH YES THIS IS TO
STREAMLINE PROGRAM
ADMINISTRATION. ADELINE HOW-
THIS PROGRAM IS A BUDGETED- AS
OTHER CDA MEDICAID PROGRAMS ARE.
AT THE SHIFT OF ROUGHLY TWO
MILLION FROM SPECIAL PLAN TO
GENERAL FUND FOR ACTIVITIES
RELATED TO THE SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY FINANCING. A PROPOSAL
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AND BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE TO ALLOW CA TO PROVIDE
PUBLICATION REPRESENTATIVES
WERE- WHEN THE DEPARTMENT IS
UNABLE TO CONTRACT FOR THE
SERVICES. THE ONE THAT WE'RE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE ON AND TAKING
SURVEYS AND PROPOSALS. THANK.
YOU VERY MUCH DEPARTMENT
FINANCE. I MEAN L. A. O. I'M
SORRY BACKWARDS. YES AND CHECK
YOU PROCEED WITH L. A. L. ALLEN
A PREVIEW MY- WE'RE STILL
COMPLETING OUR INITIAL REVIEW OF
THE MAY REVISE PROPOSAL SO WE'LL
DEFINITELY GET BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE- BUT JUST ON THE
CARE COURT PROPOSAL SOME. SOME
COMMENTS ON THAT OUR OFFICE
BLAGDON OTHER HEARING
SPECIFICALLY ON THE JUDICIAL
SIDE IS ONE- THE TEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
BEIJING IS JUST ONE OF THREE
PROPOSALS THAT MAKE UP THE CARE
COURT PACKAGE AS- DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE MENTIONED. SO THE TOTAL
COST RELATED TO CARE COURT- WHEN
YOU SOME OF THE THREE PROPOSALS
A SIXTY FIVE MILLION. AND
ANOTHER THING THAT WE WOULD
NOTICE THAT THESE DOLLARS- BUT
SPECIFICALLY TIED TO A POLICY
BILL THAT STILL MAKING ITS WAY
THROUGH THE PROCESS- SO KEY
QUESTIONS THAT OUR OFFICE- IT'S
CONSIDERING WHEN IT COMES TO
THIS BROADER CARE CORP. IS ONE
THAT. THE FUNDING RELATIVE TO
THE BELL I'M TO GETTING A BETTER
SENSE OF HOW DEPARTMENTS LIKE
THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING- WILL
DEVELOP THAT EXPERTISE- TO
SERVE- POPULATIONS- THAT WOULD-
BE SERVED TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
CARE COURT PROCESS. AND GIVEN
THAT THEY MAY HAVE DIFFERENT
NEEDS- THEN THE TYPICAL
POPULATION THAT- THE DEPARTMENT
OF AGING- CURRENTLY FOCUSES ON
ALSO GETTING A BETTER SENSE OF
THE TIMING- AND THE RESOURCES
NEEDED TO DEVELOP THAT EXPERTISE
AND ALSO- THE CAPACITY AND- THE-
LEVEL OF RESOURCE. WITHIN
EXISTING STATE AND LOCAL
PROGRAMS THAT MAY BE LEVERAGED
TO THE CARE COURT PROCESS TO
PROVIDE ANY ADDITIONAL
WRAPAROUND OR SUPPORT SERVICES-
SUCH AS- IT SHOWS THAT WOULD
PURCHASE THROUGH THE KERR
CARCROSS. THANK YOU. OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I WILL GET THIS A-
COURSE ARE STILL LOT WORK TO DO
ON THAT THAT WE DO KNOW AND
TREATMENT. INNOVATION IN BEING
ABLE TO- ADD TO DESIGNED AND
FURNACE- THROUGHOUT THE BUDGET.
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF. THANK YOU
AND- YEAH WE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY
HERE PRESENTATION ABOUT CARE
COURT AND THE BILL ACTUALLY
AUTHORED BY OUR CHAIR HERE- AND
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH.
I DID ONE DRILL DOWN A LITTLE
BIT- SINCE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
HERE AND PART OF AGING- WELL I
GUESS A COUPLE QUESTIONS RELATED
TO THE CARE COURT FROM SO ONE
YOU KNOW THERE I THINK SOME
PEOPLE RAISE. THE ISSUE BUT HE
MAYBE ELABORATE A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT LACK EXPERIENCE THE PART
OF AGING OR IS THERE SOME
PARALLEL PROGRAM- DOES NOT BY
THREE WORD BUT- THOSE THE
CAPACITY OF THIS DEPARTMENT TO
DEVELOP. THE COURT SUPPORTER
PROGRAMS OR SOMETHING SIMILAR TO
DAVE HAD TO OVERSEE OR DEVELOP.
YOU KNOW IS IT WITHIN THEIR
DEPARTMENT SO THAT CAPACITY. AND
THEN- REALIZING IT'S PART OF A
LARGER PACKAGE BUT IS YOU KNOW
THAT GIVEN THE IMPORTANT ROLE TO
SUPPORTER PLAYS AT LEAST. IN THE
NIGHT AND AT LEAST WHEN I. WAS
LOOKING AT THE LEGISLATION. IS
TEN MILLION ENOUGH- TO PROVIDE
THE SUFFICIENT SUPPORT FOR THE
SUPPORTERS AND THE OTHER
TRAINING AT CETERA FOR THE
SUPPORTERS- AND REMEMBER HOW
MANY PEOPLE ARE ANTICIPATING SO
HOW MUCH. THEREFORE HAPPENED IS
TO MEET A PERSON AT LEAST ONCE
AS ONE SUPPORTERS THAT. THAT
ENOUGH MONEY TO PROVIDE ENOUGH
SUPPORT FOR THE SUPPORTER SO I
CAN'T OFF THE TOP OF MY HEAD-
MEMBER EXACTLY HOW. WE DID THE
MATH HELD AT TEN MILLION HOW
MANY PER SUPPORTED LED. SO BUT
MAYBE MORE IMPORTANTLY- AGAIN-
IS THE PART OF AGING AB
CERTAINLY IS WONDERFUL
DEPARTMENT DOES A LOT OF THINGS
CAN YOU SPEAK TO WHY THE
DEPARTMENT AGING AND WHAT
EXPERIENCE DEPARTMENT AGING AND
SETTING UP A PROGRAM THAT.
MILLER TO THE PURPOSE COURT
SUPPORTER PROGRAM FOR CARE COURT
. SURE THIS IS THOMAS KAREN
DUFFY DIRECTOR WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF AGING-
SO WHO DEPARTMENT OF AGING HAS
SOME EXPERIENCE ESTABLISHING A
PROGRAM LIKE THIS IF YOU LOOK TO
OUR- NEWEST EFFORT THE OFFICE OF
THE LONG TERM CARE PATIENT RAP.
WE WORK WITH LOCAL PARTNERS TO
PROVIDE- UNREPRESENTED
INDIVIDUALS WITH REPRESENTATION
FOR DECISION MAKING ON CARE
TEAMS I'M ADDITIONALLY WE ALSO
HAVE A LOT OF EXPERIENCE IN OUR
LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN
PROGRAM- WORKING WITH- ADULTS IN
INSTITUTIONS AND FACILITIES
HOPING TO PROTECT AND SUPPORT
THEIR RIGHTS- AND ALSO PROVIDING
INFORMATION- SO WITH THOSE FEW.
EFFORTS AND OFFICES THAT WE HAVE
UNDER OUR PURVIEW WE THOUGHT-
THAT WE COULD STEP IN AND
COORDINATE AND WORK WITH LOCAL
PROVIDERS THAT MAY BE
INTERESTED- TO PROVIDE THE IN
PROVIDING THE CARE COURT
SUPPORT- WORK AT. THE LOCAL
LEVEL AS WELL- OKAY APPRECIATE
THAT ANSWER- I THINK THE
POPULATION IS IN THE END THAT
THEY THINK THE PART AGING DOES
YOU KNOW A REALLY. GOOD JOB AND
THOSE PROGRAMS YOU TALKED ABOUT
SO THATS COURSE- HELPFUL. I DO
THINK THE POPULATIONS A BIT
DIFFERENT SO I DAY JUST URGE
THAT THE- AGAIN WE WANT THIS TO
BE SUCCESSFUL AND THUS THE
SUPPORTERS ARE STILL SEEM TO BE
A KEY PART OF THIS YOU KNOW
POTENTIAL SUCCESS- HOPEFULLY OF
THE CARE COURT SYSTEM. AND PLAY
A CRITICAL ROLE SO- SO JUST
WANNA BE SURE THAT WE'RE
PROVIDING ENOUGH SUPPORT TO THE
DEPARTMENT AND WE HAVE TO BRING
TOGETHER GREAT SKILL SETS TO
HAVE AN EFFECTIVE SUPPORTER
PROGRAM BECAUSE IT'S PRETTY KEY
AT LEAST THE WAY I READ THE-
COURT PROPOSAL. GOING LIKE TO
FOCUS ON THE COURT SIDE I'M
LOOKING AT SUPPORTER SITE IS
BEING A REALLY IMPORTANT PART
OF- WHETHER THIS IS GOING TO BE
SUCCESSFUL OR NOT AND- ONE BE
SURE WE'RE NOT SKIMPING ON-
UNVEILED SET UP A- A STRONG
SUPPORTER SYSTEM FOR- FOR THE
PEOPLE WHO. MAY HAVE TO GO
BEFORE CARE COURT. UNDERSTANDING
AND WE CONTINUE TO PARTNER WITH-
AGENCY ADMINISTRATION AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS ON THIS EFFORT- TO
INFORM HOW WE DO THAT AND HOW WE
CAN LEND OUR EXPERTISE TO
ENSURING THE SUCCESS OF THE CARE
COURTS SUPPORTER PROGRAM AND
WILL CONTINUE TO DO THAT
COMMUNICATE. BOTH WITH THIS BODY
AND OUR OTHER PARTNERS ON
IMPLEMENTATION IF THIS MOVES
FORWARD. OKAY ALL RIGHT I
APPRECIATE THAT WELL WE'LL SEE
WE'LL WATCH THE DEPARTMENT
STRETCH OKAY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND I HAVE REACHED
THE POINT IN A COUPLE DIFFERENT
SETTINGS THAT. I THINK CASE I
THINK CASELOADS ARE ARE VERY
IMPORTANT AND- WILL CONTINUE TO
STRUGGLE WITH THE CASELOADS JUST
IN CHILD WELFARE IN GENERAL. AS
WE'RE MOVING AND DEVELOPING A
NEW SSTEM OF CARE COURTS THAT
THE RATIO. OF CASELOAD- BE
MANAGEABLE. SOME OF THE NUMBERS
I HEARD I THOUGHT WERE WAY TOO
HIGH WAY TOO HIGH. BECAUSE I
THINK THE SUPPORTERS GOING TO
HAVE A MORE. HANDS ON
RELATIONSHIP POTENTIALLY.
DEPENDING ON THE DEMOGRAPHIC MIX
IN THE- WHERE PEOPLE ARE
LOCATED. IS GONNA NEED A LOT OF
VARIATION I THINK TO- CASELOAD
SO- LET'S LET'S NOT BE A WE KEEP
ON THAT FRONT END AND END UP NOT
HAVING A PROGRAM THAT WORKS VERY
WELL BECAUSE IT'S NOT FUNDED.
OKAY THANK YOU AND LET'S MOVE ON
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION. FIFTH SEVEN
MAJOR MEMBERS- I'M DELUDE BAKER
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND I'M JOINED BY DIRECTOR
JOSEPH HERE WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF REHABILITATION AND I WILL BE
PROVIDING A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF
THE DEPARTMENT'S ARMY REVISION
PROPOSALS AND WE WILL BOTH BE
AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS AFTER.
WHAT THIS PART OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF AGING'S MAP AGING
INVESTMENTS THE REVISION
INCLUDES A TEN MILLION DOLLAR
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND INVESTMENT
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION TO ESTABLISH A
NEW PROGRAM TITLED THE COMMUNITY
LIVING FUN. IN THIS PROGRAM WILL
ASSIST NON MEDICARE ELIGIBLE AND
LOW INCOME PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES INCLUDING OLDER
ADULTS IN TRANSITIONING FROM
NURSING NURSING HOMES TO
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS AT
THIS PROPOSAL ALLOWS THE
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION TO
EXPAND. RELATED SERVICES AMONG
THEIR EXISTING PARTNERS TO SERVE
ADDITIONAL CONSUMERS AND SUPPORT
IN ADVANCING THE MASTER PLAN FOR
EACH OF THIS PROPOSAL ALSO
INCLUDES PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE
THAT WOULD MAKE THIS FUNDING
AVAILABLE FOR THREE YEARS
THROUGH JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. AND IF THERE ARE
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS WERE HAPPY
TO ANSWER THEM THIS TIME. THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
HELLO. HELLO MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS AND YOU PICK WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE-
WE'RE WITHHOLDING ANY COMMENTS
AT THIS TIME BECAUSE THE BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL HAS NOT YET BEEN
POSTED SO WE HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE
TO REVIEW. THE DETAILS OF THIS
PROPOSAL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK THEM.
I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT I THINK
THIS IS A HUGE NEEDED IT AS WE
CONTINUE TO- LOOK AT MAINTAINING
INDEPENDENT LIVING IN PEOPLE OF
BEING ABLE TO AGE IN PLACE THIS
BECOMES VERY IMPORTANT AND I
WOULD SAY NOT JUST TRANSITIONING
FROM NURSING HOMES INDEPENDENT
LIVING WITH BEING ABLE TO
MAINTAIN. YOUR CURRENT SITUATION
AND NOT HAVE TO GO INTO A
NURSING HOME SO- PROPOSAL
CLOSELY VERY INTERESTED IN THIS
BUDGET LANGUAGE AS IT COMES OUT
APPARENTLY THING ON THIS OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DEPARTMENT
OF. DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES. I'M
SURE MEANS CHRIS OF NEWMAN WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. I AM
ALSO DOING TODAY BY- DEPARTMENT
DIRECTOR NANCY BURGEONING WHO-
IS ALSO AVAILABLE TO ANSWER.
QUESTIONS AFTER THIS BRIEF
OVERVIEW. THE FOR THE PERMANENT
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES THE MAYOR
VISION INCLUDES A TOTAL OF
TWELVE POINT SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS- SEVEN POINT SIX BILLION
OF THAT WHICH IS GENERAL FUND IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. AND
ESTIMATES THAT APPROXIMATELY
400-100-0800 SEVEN INDIVIDUALS
WERE ISSUED SERVICES BY THE- I
JANUARY OF TWENTY TWENTY THREE-
FOUR HUNDRED. ABOUT 400-100-0400
EIGHTY FIVE OTHER REGIONAL
CENTER CLIENTS THREE HUNDRED
TWENTY TWO- IF THE CAPACITY ON
THE STATE OPERATED FACILITIES
SIDE. ON ONE OF THAT THIS IS A
ROOF THIS CASELOAD ESTIMATES
REVISED DOWNWARD BY ABOUT SEVEN
THOUSAND- CONSUMERS PROJECTED AT
THE TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. I'M WORK
FIRST THE- THEIR NUMBER
PROPOSALS- FOR THE DEPARTMENT-
THE FIRST- COVERAGE RETURNS OF
PROMOTING WORKFORCE STABILITY.
THE MAYOR VISION INCLUDES-
HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND ONE
TIME TO SUPPORT THE DEPARTMENT
DRAMA SERVICES IN ITS EFFORTS
TO. ADDRESS CURRENT AND EMERGING
WORKFORCE CHALLENGES STRATEGIEN
VISION AND EMPHASIZES. CAREER
PATHWAYS FOR REGIONAL CENTER
CONSUMER SERVICE COORDINATORS
AND WORKERS WHO PROVIDE DIRECT
SERVICES WHILE ALSO EXPLORING
TECHNOLOGY BASE SUPPORTS TO
REDUCE RELIANCE. ON IN PERSON
SERVICES. AND INCREASED CONSUMER
INDEPENDENCE. THE COMPONENTS ON
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT
INVESTMENTS- WHICH INCLUDED
PROVIDING PAY DIFFERENTIALS TO
DIRECT SUPPORT PROFESSIONALS WHO
CAN COMMUNICATE WITH CONSUMERS
AND- LABOUR'S MEDIUMS OTHER THAN
ENGLISH AND ALSO- ESTABLISHMENT
OF A DIRECT SUPPORT PROFESSIONAL
TRAINING PROGRAM WITH YOUR
CERTIFICATION LEVELS AND PAY
DIFFERENTIALS. THE COMPONENTS OF
THE ORIGINAL PROPOSAL INCLUDE
HUNDRED TWENTY SEVEN POINT NINE
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND TO PROVIDE
UP TO TWO FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS
STIPENDS FOR DIRECT SUPPORT
PROFESSIONALS TO COMPLETE-
TRAINING MODULES. TWENTY TWO
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND TO ESTABLISH AND THREE MONTHS TRAINING
AND INTERNSHIP PROGRAM INTENDED
TO ESTABLISH AN ENTRY POINT INTO
A DIRECT SUPPORT PROFESSIONAL
CAREER PATH- THIS PROPOSAL ALSO
INCLUDES UP. TO TWO FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLAR RETENTION STEPHENS FOR
WORKERS- OTHER COMPONENTS
INCLUDE THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND TO. ESTABLISH A
TUITION REIMBURSEMENT PROGRAM
FOR REGIONAL CENTER CONSUMER
SERVICE COORDINATORS WHO SEEK
ADVANCED DEGREES IN HEALTH OR
HUMAN SERVICES RELATED FIELDS-
AND PARTICIPANTS IN THAT PROGRAM
WOULD ENTER INTO AGREEMENTS WITH
THEIR- INDIVIDUAL REGIONAL
CENTERS OUTLINING POSTGRADUATE
XIN SERVICE REQUIREMENTS. IN THE
FINAL COMPLAINT WOULD BE- FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND TO
PILOT THE STOCK FEASIBILITY OF
THE USE OF REMOTE SUPPORT AS AN
OPTION FOR INDIVIDUALS LEAD.
MORE INDEPENDENT LIVES AND WHEN
CHOSEN SAYS- REDUCE RELIANCE ONE
SOMEONE IN PERSON DIRECT SUPPORT
- WILL ALSO THAT THIS WORK.
INCLUDES SEVEN POSITIONS- AND
WHAT ADDRESS ONGOING- CURRENT
AND FUTURE WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED
WITH THE DEPARTMENT'S WORKFORCE
INITIATIVES. ON BOTH THOSE
PROPOSING THOSE INCLUDED IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT.
EARLY START EARLY INTERVENTION
SERVICES THAT MAYOR VISION
CLEANS- SIX POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY-
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE-
INCREASING TO AN ESTIMATED
TWENTY NINE POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL SOMEBODY TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE TO SUPPORT
ADJUSTMENTS IN IDENTIFYING
CHILDREN WITH QUALIFYING SIGNS
OF DEVELOPMENTAL DELAYS. THIS
PROPOSAL INCLUDES ON THE
FOLLOWING STATUTORY CHANGES SO
FIRST REVISING THE EARLIEST HER
QUALIFICATION THRESHOLD FROM A
33% AWAY 225% AWAY IN ONE OF THE
SPECIFIED ASSESSMENT AREAS. ON
THIS WOULD BE CONSISTENT WITH
THE PRACTICE AND- IN EIGHTEEN
OTHER STATES. THE SECOND PIECE
WILL BE SEPARATING COMMUNICATION
DELAY ASSESSMENTS INTO
EXPRESSIVE RECEPTIVE CATEGORIES
AND THE THIRD PRONG WOULD BE-
HIGHLIGHTS FETAL ALCOHOL
SYNDROME AS A RISK FACTOR FOR
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DELAYS- TOGETHER THESE CHANGES
ARE INTENDED TO ENGAGE FAMILIES
SOONER WITH- EARLY INTERVENTION
SERVICES- BILLS SEEK TO ADDRESS
THE CHANGING NEEDS. OF INFANTS
AND TODDLERS- TO THE IMPACT OF
SOCIAL ISOLATION OTHER FACTORS
RESULTING FROM THE PANDEMIC. ON
SERVICE ACCESS AND EQUITY THE
TOWN MAYOR VISION INCLUDE ELEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS A GENERAL FUND
ONE TIME TO DOUBLE THE RESOURCES
IN. TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
CURRENTLY AVAILABLE FOR GDS TO
AWARD TO REGIONAL CENTERS AND
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS-
THROUGH ITS SERVICE ACCESS. AND
EQUITY GRANT PROGRAM WHICH
FOCUSES ON SUPPORTING STRATEGIES
TO REDUCE DISPARITIES AND
INCREASE ACCORDING REGIONAL
CENTER SERVICES. ON THIS REQUEST
ALSO INCLUDES FOUR POSITIONS-
THAT WOULD ADDRESS- ONGOING
CURRENT WORKLOAD ASSOCIATE WITH
THE DEPARTMENT'S ADMINISTRATION
OF THIS PROGRAM AND OTHER EQUITY
EFFORTS. ADMISSION ALSO INCLUDES
ON SEVERAL PROPOSALS RELATED TO
ADDRESSING- FLEXIBILITIES THAT
WERE IMPLEMENTED IN RESPONSE THE
PANDEMIC AND THROUGH ON THE
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY- THE
FIRST THAT WE WOULD HIGHLIGHT
ON. THE MAYOR VISION INCLUDES
SEVEN POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS
ON GOING FOUR POINT ACROSS ME
FOUR POINT FOUR MILLION OF THAT
GENERAL FUND. TO SUPPORT
PARTICIPANTS IN THE SELF
DETERMINATION PROGRAM BY
AMENDING STATUTE TO MOVE THE
COST OF FINANCIAL MANAGEMENT
SERVICES OUT OF PARTICIPANTS
INDIVIDUAL BUDGET- BUT IT'S THIS
POLICY HAS BEEN IN PLACE THROUGH
DEPARTMENT DIRECTOR FOR THE
DURATION OF THE PANDEMIC AND
MAKING THIS POLICY PERMANENT IS
ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT FOR
CONSUMERS A SMALLER BUDGET.
BUDGETS ENCOURAGING ONBOARDING
INTO THE PROGRAM- THE MAYOR
VISION ALSO INCLUDES. CHANGES
THAT CONTINUE SUSPENSION OF THE
ANNUAL FAMILY FEE PROGRAM AND
THE FAMILY BECAUSE PARTICIPATE
PARTICIPATION PROGRAM IN
STATUTE. THROUGH DECEMBER THIRTY
FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO ON
BOTH. PROGRAMS HAVE ALSO BEEN
SUSPENDED FOR DEPARTMENT
DIRECTORS THROUGHOUT THE
PANDEMIC. THE PURPOSE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE WOULD RECONSTITUTE
THE PROGRAM'S HIGH 6100% OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL FROM THE
CURRENT 4100% OF. FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL THRESHOLD AND ALSO
TASK THE DIAZ REPORTING FOR A
RECOMMENDED CARSHARING PROGRAM
BY GOVERNOR'S BUDGET OF. TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR BASE IN
COLLABORATION WITH STAKEHOLDERS.
AND THEN THE NEAR VISION ALSO-
PROPOSES STATUTORY CHANGES THAT
WOULD ADDRESS THE CONTINUED
PROVISION OF ALTERNATIVE
SERVICES WHICH WERE AUTHORIZED
YOU'RE COVERED FLEXIBILITIES
DURING THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY UNDER ALTERNATIVE
SERVICES PROVIDERS COULD REWORK
SERVICES FOR CONSUMERS IN WAYS
UNIONS AND RESPONSE THE PANDEMIC
THE PROPOSED- TRAVELING WHICH
PROVIDES PROGRAM CERTAINTY BY
EXTENDING THE AUTHORIZATION OF
ALTERNATE SERVICES THROUGH
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TO. MAKES CHANGES TO THE
TAYLOR DAY OUR PROGRAM SERVICE
CO WHICH WILL NOW ALLOW
CONSUMERS ACCESS THE SERVICE
ALONGSIDE TRADITIONAL SERVICES
AS A TURN BY INDIVIDUAL PROGRAM
PLANS AND WOULD ALSO ELIMINATE
THE HAVE BEEN DOING POLICY- I
SPECIFY PROVIDERS. OTHER CHIU OF
NOTE WE WOULD HIGHLY- THE NEW
PROPOSED THREE POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
FOUR DDS TO ALLOCATE TO THE CITY
OF COSTA MESA IN ORANGE COUNTY
TO ENGAGE IN A PLANNING PROCESS
FOR DISPOSITION OF THE FAIRVIEW
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER ST. AND
ALSO ON EMERGENCY PLANNING
PREPAREDNESS FRONT THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES EIGHT
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND I'M GOING TO
CONTINUE DISTRIBUTION OF
EMERGENCY GO BAGS AND BATTERIES-
AND- AND OTHER ACTIVITIES- IN
THIS CONTINUES INVESTMENTS MADE
IN THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET
ACT. INCLUDING THE DESIGNATION
OF EMERGENCY COORDINATORS AT
REGIONAL CENTERS ACROSS THE
STATE- AN INITIAL PROCUREMENT
HAVE GO BAGS FOR CONSUMERS- IN
AREAS OF THE STATE. ARE AT HIGH
RISK. WILL THIS ASTERS- OTHER
EMERGENCIES. IN WITH THAT.
CAPITA TAKING QUESTIONS THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISSPELLING. THANK YOU VENTURES
ON YOUR MEDICAL THE L. A. O. AND
WE ARE OF COURSE STILL REVIEWING
A LOT OF THE DETAILS OF THESE
VARIOUS PROPOSALS SO I'M GOING
TO LIMIT MY COMMENTS TODAY TO
THE BIGGEST PROPOSAL THE WORK
FOR STABILITY PROPOSAL WHICH IS-
WOULD COST A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
FIVE POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS
FROM THE GENERAL FUND IN THE
BUDGET FOR TWENTY TO TWENTY. I'M
WE THINK THIS PROPOSAL SEEKS TO
ADDRESS WHAT WE HAVE HEARD IS A
BIG AND GROWING AND SORT OF
IMMEDIATE- WORKFORCE. PROBLEM
AND THE INDIVIDUAL COMPONENTS OF
THE PROPOSAL MAY HAVE MERIT THEY
MIGHT HELP WITH THE IMMEDIATE
PROBLEM OR PERHAPS THEY WOULD
HELP WITH WORKFORCE ISSUES IN
THE FUTURE. BUT THAT IS- SORT OF
UNCLEAR- TO OUR OFFICE UPON
FIRST- FIRST REVIEW. AND IN
ADDITION SORT OF GET AWAY OF MY
COLLEAGUE- IS BELLA'S COMMENTS
THAT IN ORDER TO DEAL WITH THE
STATE APPROPRIATIONS LIMIT THIS
YEAR- THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD
CONSIDER PRIORITIZING- PROPOSALS
THAT MEET OR EXCEED A HIGH BAR
SO IN WHAT IN. SORT OF THAT
CONTEXT I WANTED TO RAISE A FEW.
OF THE ISSUES THAT WE'VE
INITIALLY IDENTIFIED WITH THIS
PROPOSAL. SO FIRST WE KNOW THAT
THERE'S NO ASSOCIATED TRAILER
BILL SO IT'S HARD IT'S HARD TO.
KNOW HOW THESE PROPOSALS WOULD
ACTUALLY BE IMPLEMENTED- SO LET
ME START FIRST WITH THE-
TRAINING COMPONENTS THE TRAINING
STIPENDS IT'S UNCLEAR- TO US
WHETHER THIS PROPOSAL WOULD
REALLY AFFECT RETENTION OF
DIRECT SERVICE PROVIDERS AND WE
DON'T REALLY KNOW IF THIS IS A
PROVEN APPROACH TO RETAINING-
STAFF- ON THE INTERNSHIP
COMPONENT OF THE PROPOSAL. WE
WOULD NOTE THAT THE INTERNSHIPS
WOULD BE PAID AT MINIMUM WAGE
AND THE END RESULT OF THE
INTERNSHIP MIGHT POSSIBLY ONLY
BE A MINIMUM WAGE JOB IN THE
FIELD AND SO THE QUESTION THIS
RAISES FOR US IS HOW THIS WORD.
WHILE IT MIGHT HAVE BENEFITS IN
TERMS OF- PROVIDING EXPOSURE TO
PEOPLE OR- TRAINING PERHAPS ON
ON ENTERING THIS TYPE OF FIELD
WHAT IT REALLY RESULT IN THE
KIND OF RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION THAT'S NEEDED- IN THE
IN THE DDS DIRECT SERVICE
PROVIDER WORKFORCE AND WE DON'T
KNOW IF THIS IS BEEN-
DEMONSTRATED TO WORK ANYWHERE
ELSE- WE'LL BE LOOKING INTO THIS
OVER THE COMING WEEKS- AND THEN
FINALLY ON THE TUITION
REIMBURSEMENT HE SAID. OF THE
PROPOSAL WE FEEL THERE ARE NOT
ENOUGH DETAILS PROVIDED- TO MAKE
AN ASSESSMENT OF THIS PROPOSAL-
SO AGAIN THINKING OF THE ISSUE
OF THE STATE APPROPRIATIONS
LIMIT- AND THINKING OF. YOU KNOW
DOE A PROPOSAL WOULD BE HARD TO
SPEND THE MONEY IN THE BUDGET
YEAR- AND IT IN LIGHT OF THAT
SORT OF CONSIDERATION WE DON'T
KNOW IF- IF THE STATE WOULD
REALLY BE ABLE TO SPEND THE
FULL. THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS ON
TUITION FOR INDIVIDUALS IF THEY
ACTUALLY HAVE TO APPLY. TO
SCHOOL LIKE HOW THAT TIMING
WOULD WORK WE'RE NOT WE'RE NOT.
CLEAR THINKING OF A SECOND
CONSIDERATION WITH THE STATE
APPROPRIATIONS LIMIT IS THE
PROPOSAL READY TO GO- WE'RE NOT
CLEAR THAT THE WORK REQUIREMENTS
FOLLOWING SO RIGHT THE PROPOSAL
SAYS THAT HAS BEEN INDIVIDUAL
COULD GET THEIR TUITION
REIMBURSED AND THEN THERE WOULD
BE SORT OF A WORK REQUIREMENT
THAT'S AGREED TO WITH THE- THE
REGIONAL CENTER. I'M WE ARE NOT
CLEAR OBSERVE WHAT THAT WORK
REQUIREMENTS WOULD BE AND IT
SOUNDS LIKE THAT- WOULD POSSIBLY
BE DETERMINED ON A REGIONAL
CENTER BY REGIONAL CENTER BASIS.
WE ASSUME THAT THE LEGISLATURE
WOULD WANT SOME KIND OF
ASSURANCES THAT THAT THE STATE'S
DS SYSTEM WE'RE TRULY BENEFIT
FROM. AN INVESTMENT OF THIS SIZE
INTO INDIVIDUALS- ON EDUCATION
EXPENSES. I'M. ONE ANOTHER ISSUE
WITH THIS THE TUITION
REIMBURSEMENT PROPOSAL IS THAT
DDS INDICATED TO OUR OFFICE THAT
ABOUT HALF OF THE REGIONAL
CNTERS ARE UNIONIZED WE'RE NOT
SURE IF THIS WOULD HAVE AN
IMPACT ON THIS PARTICULAR
PROPOSAL OR HOW THAT'S BEEN
CONSIDERED OR OR ADDRESSED AND
THEN I WOULD JUST FINE WE KNOW
THAT THERE'S A FEW SMALL DETAILS
THAT COULD POTENTIALLY HAVE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES SO FOR
EXAMPLE THE PROPOSED BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE REFERENCES- THAT THAT
THIS FUNDING WOULD HELP REGIONAL
CENTER STAFF PAID FOR. ADVANCED
DEGREES NOW BEEN DANCED AGREES
ARE TYPICALLY UNDERSTOOD AS
GRADUATE AND POSTGRADUATE
DEGREES BUT IT'S OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
DEPARTMENT WOULD ALSO WANT TO
INCLUDE- UNDERGRADUATE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR REGIONAL
CENTER STAFF SO THESE ARE JUST
THE SORT OF DETAILS THAT COULD
KIND OF HAVE A HAVE A BIG IMPACT
BUT BUT DETAILS THAT HAVEN'T
BEEN IRONED OUT YET. I'M SO WITH
THAT I ALL STOP AND- THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND-
AGAIN WILL CONTINUE TO REVIEW
THESE VARIOUS PROPOSALS AND
PROVIDE COMMENTS TO- SUB
COMMITTEE STAFF THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF GEORGE BUSH AND YOU
WANNA DO YOU WANT TO ENSURE THAT
ARE THESE SHOVEL READY AS THEY
SAY CAN WE- DO THIS AND SPEND
THESE IN A YEAR. YES THANK YOU
MATTER CHAIR AND I NEVER PERSON
DEVELOP SERVICES- SO COUPLE
THINGS I'D LIKE TO KNOW WHEN IS
THAT WE REALLY ARE VERY EXCITED
ABOUT THE PROPOSAL ON WORKFORCE-
WORKFORCE WILL TAKE DOESN'T COME
INTO COMPONENTS WITH THE DIRECT
SERVICE PROFESSIONALS. OUR
SERVICE PROVIDERS HAVE BEEN
EXPRESSING THE CHALLENGES. OF
BEING ABLE TO RETAIN AND TO BE
ABLE TO RECRUIT AND- HAVE
ADDITIONAL STAFF IN THE KIND OF
THE STAFFING DEMANDS WE KNOW
THAT THIS IS A NATIONAL
CHALLENGE. YOU KNOW IN FIGHTING
DRUG SERVICE WORKERS- IN AND SO
MANY SUPPORT AREAS ON NOT ONLY
WITHIN DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES
THIS IS THAT. A SIGNIFICANT
ISSUE. SO WE REALLY WANTED TO
THINK OUTSIDE OF THE BOX BUT
ALSO TAKE A LOOK AT WAYS THAT WE
COULD USE EXISTING- APPROACHES
THAT HAVE PROVEN TO BE
SUPPORTIVE OF DRUG SERVICE
WORKERS. I'M SO THE FIRST ONE IS. WITH THE TRAINING STIPEND. SO
REALLY I'M HAVING THE UP THERE'S
AN EXISTING. A NATIONAL. THAT
HAVE EXISTING TRAINING
COMPONENTS THAT ARE UPDATED
THEIR MODULES THAT. HAVE BEEN
UNDERUSED BY SO MANY DIFFERENT
PROVIDERS AS WELL AS OTHER
STATES. SO WE WOULD BE ABLE TO
ACCESS SOME EXISTING OFF THE
SHELF- TRAINING- THAT WOULD BE
AVAILABLE- THRUWAY AID REMOTES-
MECHANISM SO IT WOULD NOT HAVE
TO BE COORDINATED OR OR-
RESTRUCTURED DEVELOPED IN IN A
WAY- AND SO AND BEING ABLE TO DO
THAT AND RECOGNIZING THAT. THOSE
OPPORTUNITY FOR TRAINING WHILE
WE'RE STANDING UP FOR DRUG
SERVICE PROFESSIONAL UNIVERSITY
IS REALLY A GREAT OPPORTUNITY
FOR THAT SERVICE PROVIDERS TO
HAVE THIS ADDED LAYER TRAINING
BUT ALSO- A RECOGNITION OF THE
WORK THAT THE DRUG SERVICE
PROFESSIONALS WITHIN
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES- CAN
HAVE. SO THAT PROPOSAL IS FOR
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS THAT WOULD
GO TO THE DRUG SERVICE- WORKERS
AND THEN THERE'S AN ADDITIONAL
ADMINISTRATIVE OF A HUNDRED
FIFTY DOLLARS THAT WOULD GO TO
THE SERVICE PROVIDER TO HELP ON
THE ADMINISTRATIVE SIDE. AND
THEN I'M TALKING ABOUT THE- THE
WORK ON THE- INTERNSHIP. SO
AGAIN IS THIS THIS IS WHAT I'M A
NEW IDEA THIS IS WE ARE REALLY
TRYING TO THINK ABOUT WAYS THAT
WE CAN. HELP BRING IN-
INDIVIDUALS TO WORK WITHIN THE
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES SYSTEM
AND- SUPPORTING OUR CONSUMERS.
THIS IS A DIFFERENT MODEL THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT- WE DO WANT TO
BE ABLE TO HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO TRY. OF BEING ABLE TO.
VISUALS ON THREES AS AS SUCH I'M
GONNA USE FOR LACK OF A BETTER
WORD LIKE A STAFFING AGENCY.
THEY CAN TRAIN THEY CAN GO AHEAD
AND THEN COORDINATE WITH THE
PROVIDER FOR A INTERNSHIP
PROGRAM. REALLY SEEKING TO WORK
WITH MAYBE THOSE COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE THAT- HAD ACCESS TO
PROVIDE SERVICS ON. MANY
PROVIDERS WILL GO AHEAD AND HIRE
SOMEBODY- IN WANTING TO HAVE
SOMEBODY WITH EXPERIENCE. THIS
WOULD BRING PEOPLE AND TO HAVE
THAT- AS AN IN. WITH HIS WITH
THE- FOR THREE. ON TO BE ABLE TO
THAT EXPERIENCE WE WOULD BE ABLE
TO GO TO COMMUNITY COLLEGES WORK
WITH COLLEGE PROGRAMS WORK WITH-
WITH EDT I'M REALLY TRYING TO
BRANCH OUT AND OCT ALSO AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY DIVERSIFY
OUR WORKFORCE- REGARDING THE-
REGIONAL CENTER- PRINT SERVICE
COORDINATORS TO. INCREASE OVER
THE NEXT- YEAR WE'RE REALLY
LOOKING TO INCREASE SERVICE
COORDINATOR THE NUMBER OF
POSITIONS. SO BASED ON THE
PROPOSALS AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THAT WAS APPROVED FOR- REDUCING
SERVICE COORDINATOR CASELOADS.
AND THEN ALSO WITH THE- NEW
PROPOSALS- IN GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
TO REDUCE SERVICE COORDINATOR
RATIOS FOR BIRTH- YOU'RE FIVE
YEARS OLD- WE'RE WE'RE
ESTIMATING ANYWHERE FROM
THIRTEEN HUNDRED TO FIFTEEN
HUNDRED SERVICE COORDINATORS.
THAT ARE NEEDED OVER THE NEXT
YEAR THAT IS NOT INCLUDING THE
TURNOVER RATE. MANY COUNTIES
CENTER THREE THAT THEY LOSE SOME
OF THEIR STAFF TO COUNTIES AND
OTHER SOCIAL SERVICE ENTITIES
THAT HAVE TUITION REIMBURSEMENT
PROGRAMS AND SO REALLY HELPING
THE REGIONAL CENTERS HAVE A
MECHANISM TO HAVE. NOT ONLY AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SUPPORT THEIR
STAFF BUT ALSO TO- HAVE SOME.
KIND OF COMPETITIVE NATURE AND-
THE WORK FORCE THAT IS IN HIGH
DEMAND- AND SO- HISPANIC EXACTLY
CORRECT WE DO WANT TO BE ABLE TO
NOT ONLY SAFER EXISTING SERVICE
COORDINATORS BUT THOSE MANY
WORKERS THAT ARE WORKING AT
REGIONAL CENTERS THAT MAY NOT
HAVE A- UNDERGRADUATE DEGREE
THAT THIS MAY ALSO BE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO- OPEN THE DOOR
FOR THEM TO- BE SERVICE
COORDINATORS- EVEN AS THEY'VE
BEEN COMMITTED TO WORKING AT A
REGIONAL CENTER. I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS-
I WANT ONE LAST THING I WOULD
NOTE ON THE THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS. FOR THE TUITION
REIMBURSEMENT THAT ACTUALLY THE
LANGUAGE- WOULD PROVIDE US THE
ABILITY TO- YOU. EXPEND THE
FUNDS THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
. AND IS INTENTION TO PROVIDE.
BUDGET TRAILER LANGUAGE. WE
DON'T HAVE ANY PROPOSED- ON
LANGUAGE I'M HAPPY TO WORK WITH
THIS COMMITTEE AND LUNCH STAFF
ON- AREAS THAT THERE MAY BE OF
INTEREST- BUT WE DO WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE FLEXIBILITY
IN- THE WORK AT THE REGIONAL
CENTER LEVEL AND KNOWING THAT
EVERY CATCHMENT AREAS VERY
DIFFERENT THEIR RECRUITMENT
EFFORTS ARE- FACED BY DIFFERENT
CHALLENGES- SO BEING TOO
PRESCRIPTIVE MAY NOT WORK WITH
ONE REGIONAL CENTER VERSUS
ANOTHER REGIONAL CENTER AS AN
EXAMPLE- SO HAPPY THAT- YOU HAVE
THAT CONVERSATION- WITH WITH.
THE COMMITTEE OKAY AND I KNOW IT
FOR THE LAST COUPLE YEARS WE'VE
REALLY FOCUSED ON THIS AND
REALLY TRIED TO GET CAREER
PATHWAYS AND ANNA AND A NETWORK
OR SO I'VE I APPRECIATE AND
RESPECT ALL THE WORK THAT THAT
YOU FOLKS HAVE DONE- AND I AM OF
THE MANAGING DOESN'T DOESN'T LAY
THAT OUT HERE BUT THERE WILL BE
A LOT OF INTERACTION WITH- WITH
H. CHI. I JUST DON'T GET NERVOUS
ARE THE ONES WHICH WILL BE DOING
A LOT OF THIS WORK FORCE
TRAINING AND ALL OF THAT BUT
MAKING SURE THERE'S COORDINATION
WHEN DEPARTMENTS CAN HAVE THEIR
OWN THEIR OWN PROGRAMS THAT
THERE'S COORDINATION BETWEEN
THOSE TWO SO. WE'RE NOT. IN
COMPETITION WITH EACH OTHER.
pNEEDED WHEN- DEPARMENTS AND-
AGENCIES- WE WOULD WOULD BE
HAPPY TO DO THAT. THANK YOU DR
PAN. THANK YOU AND- I DO
APPRECIATE- SILICA THE COMMENTS
ABOUT THE WORK FORCE ABILITY AT
THE END OF THE QUESTION IS
WHETHER WE NEED IT I THINK THE
QUESTION IS THAT ARE. YOU KNOW.
WE HAVE THE GUIDELINES IN PLACE
AND- APPRECIATE THAT THE
TESTIMONY ABOUT- FLEXIBILITY
BUT- I ALSO NEED TO BE TAUGHT
ABILITY SO WE'RE PUTTING HUNDRED
TWENTY SEVEN POINT EIGHT MILLION
TO DESTROYING TWENTY STIPENDS.
BUT THE LAW SEEMS TO BE A LITTLE
OPEN ENDED OBVIOUSLY WE YOU KNOW
WE WANT FOR THE HELP IMPROVE
RETENTION AND RECRUITMENT INTO.
THE REGIONAL CENTERS AND OTHERS-
BUT I THINK HAVING- FIGUEIRA
HAVING SOME STANDARDS THAT WE
CAN THEREFORE HAVE
ACCOUNTABILITY IS GOING TO BE
IMPORTANT- I WOULD MAKE A NOTE
THAT AND INITIAL TESTIMONY- THE
LEASE WAS MENTIONED AND OF AN
AREA THAT IS GREAT INTEREST TO
ME IS A- AS CHAIR OF THE API
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUSES BE SURE WE
HAVE ORE. SERVICE PROVIDERS WHO
CAN SPEAK IN LANGUAGE. AND THAT-
AND THAT LANGUAGE SKILLS ARE
RECOGNIZED- THOSE THOSE. IT WAS
SET IN THE NATIONAL PRESENTATION
BUT- THERE WASN'T A FOLLOW
THROUGH IN TERMS OF LIKE WHAT
PERCENTAGE OF WHAT HOW MUCH OF
THESE RESOURCES ARE GOING TO BE
TO RECOGNIZE OR TO TRAIN. PEOPLE
TO BE ABLE TO RIDE IN LANGUAGE
SERVICES SO. I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU'RE ABLE TO COMMENT ON THAT
ARE NOT UNDER TO WORK FOR
STABILITY PROPOSALS. THANK YOU
DR PAN NANCY FOR TREND ABOUT
LITTLE SERVICES. SO REGARDING-
AND REALLY APPRECIATE
HIGHLIGHTING AGAIN BE
OPPORTUNITY THAT WE HAD- IN THE
BUDGET AFTER TWENTY TWENTY ONE
OF THE BILINGUAL PAY
DIFFERENTIAL- AND THAT WAS
REALLY INTENDED TO INCREASE
THAT. SO WE WOULD STILL- IN OUR
OUR RECRUITMENT AND- ALSO
LIFTING UP. AND MAKING SURE THAT
THOSE DIRECT SERVICE WORKERS
AND- AND MAYBE EVEN SOME OF
THEIR LANGUAGES THAT THEY'RE
MOST COMFORTABLE AND LEARNING
IN- MUCH OF THE TRAINING THAT IS
PROVIDED IS ACTUALLY IN MULTIPLE
LANGUAGES- AND THEN ALSO THE
RECRUITMENT OF THE WORKERS. IN
LOOKING AT THE- INTERNSHIP.
WE'LL BE REALLY IMPORTANT TO BE
ABLE TO- IT EXPLORE HOW WE ARE
REACHING- VARIOUS COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE OUR- CONSUMERS THAT WERE
SURVEYED ARE VERY DIVERSE AND
THEIR NEEDS ARE VERY DIVERSE AND
WE WANT TO BE RESPECTFUL OF
THAT. THIS IS A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO DO SOME
REAL INTENTIONAL OUTREACH IN
THOSE AREAS- AND CERTAINLY WHEN
WE TAKE A LOOK AT REGIONAL
CENTER TUITION REIMBURSEMENT THE
OPPORTUNITIES TO BE ABLE TO HELP
SUPPORT THOSE THAT. MAY NOT HAVE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THOSE-
OPPORTUNITIES FOR UNDERGRADUATE
OR ADVANCED DEGREES. OKAY AND-
. PRESUME THAT- THINGS LIKE
TUITION REIMBURSEMENT PROGRAM SO
FORTH- WELL I SHOULD SHOULD
PRESUME BUT- THERE'S SOME
OBLIGATION TO CONTINUE WORK AND-
AND DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES FOR
AT LEAST A FEW YEARS- IN
EXCHANGE FOR THEIR-
REIMBURSEMENT. SO FORTH THAT WE
AS A FIRMER SUSPENSION
STANDPOINT. OR NOT TWENTY PEOPLE
TO LEAVE. YEAH ABSOLUTELY AND
YOU KNOW IT'S SAID WITH THE
INTENT OF A YOU SEEN THAT
TUITION REIMBURSEMENTS YOU
REALLY KIND OF BUILD THE
CAPACITY WITHIN DEVELOPMENT. IS
IMPORTANT- SO CERTAIN SERVICE
EXPECTATIONS WOULD. BE TIED TO
THAT ALL RIGHT THANK YOU THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT GET FREE STATE ID
JUST ONE MAYBE QUICKLY MENTION
TO TWO THINGS IN THE MAY REVISED
I DO APPRECIATE A TAKER EARLY-
THE EARLY START ELIGIBILITY IS A
DEVELOPMENTAL PEDIATRICIAN- THAT
WE'RE STARTING TO TOP THE
STANDARD IT'S- SIMILAR TO OTHER
STATES WITH 25% DELAY. POINT OUT
THAT- ESPECIALLY DURING OUR
EARLY START AGES THOSE ARE
CRITICAL PERIODS OF DEVELOPMENT
AND THE WINDOWS PASSED BY TAKES
A LOT MORE WORK TO ADDRESS THE
DEVELOPMENTAL DELAYS SO BEING
ABLE TO GET SOMEONE REFERRED TO
EARLIER AND TO GET HELP EARLIER
IS GOING TO BE IMPORTANT. THEN
OF COURSE WE'VE BEEN DELAYED
HALF THE BILLING FOR A WHILE SO
ACTUALLY IT WAS ONLY TWENTY IT'S
ONLY TWENTY EIGHT TO TWENTY
MILLION OR ONE POINT NINE
GENERAL FUND SO. WELL CERTAINLY. OF ANYTHING ELSE. MILLER THE
L. ONE POINT NINE MILLION SIR
NOT INTO OF YOU MAILING BUT THE
CONTEXT OF THE WHOLE STAY
BUDGET- TO BE ABLE TO. THAT FOR.
THAT AND- IS WORTH IT MY BUT
THANKS MUCH FOR YOUR THE
PRESENT. MADE THINK YOU. OKAY
MOVING ON TO THIS CAL. UNDER. TO
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
JULIA BAKER WITH A PART IN
FINANCE AND I'M JOINED BY CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR MR CAN TO ROSA
OF THE STATE COUNCIL ON
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES I'LL
BE PROVIDING A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF
THE COUNCIL'S MAYOR VISION
PROPOSALS AND WE WILL BOTH BE
AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS AFTER.
SO THE MAY REVISION PROPOSALS
FOR THE STATE COUNCIL INCLUDE A
ONE TIME INCREASE OF NINETY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN FEDERAL FUND
EXPENDITURES ALREADY. FOR THE
COUNCIL TO RECRUIT HIRE TRAIN-
PUBLIC HEALTH WORK BUT PUBLIC
HEALTH WORKERS THAT WOULD
RESPOND TO THE CODE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC AND PREPARE FOR FUTURE
PUBLIC HEALTH CHALLENGES. OF
THIS REQUEST WOULD ALLOW THE
COUNCIL TO EXPAND THE GRANT THAT
THEY RECEIVED IN MARCH. OF
TWENTY TWENTY TWO I'M IN THE
BUDGET YEAR IN THIS PROPOSAL
ALSO INCLUDES PROVISIONAL%
LANGUAGE TO MAKE THE GRANT FUNDS
AVAILABLE FOR ENCUMBRANCE OR
EXPENDITURE- THROUGH JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY FOR AN
ADDITIONAL YEAR TO PROVIDE FOOD.
FLEXIBILITY FOR THE COUNCIL TO
EXPAND THE FUNDS BY THE END OF
THE GRANT PERIOD. ADDITIONALLY
OTHER MEMBER VISION INCLUDES A
ONE TIME INCREASE OF THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN REIMBURSEMENTS
ALREADY- TO ENABLE THE COUNCIL
TO EXPAND. A GRANT THAT THEY
RECEIVED. FROM THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION- SO THEY
COULD PURCHASE AND DISTRIBUTE
EMERGENCY GO KITS WHICH CONTAIN
A VARIETY OF ITEMS THAT ARE
USEFUL FOR FOLKS WITH
INTELLECTUAL OR DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. I WHEN THEY'RE
VACUUMING FROM THEIR HOMES
DURING A NATURAL DISASTER. AND
LASTLY THE NEIGHBOR VISION ALSO
INCLUDES EVERY APPROPRIATION OF
FEDERAL FUNDS FROM THE VACCINE
ACCESS GRANT. PROVIDED BY THE
FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION FOR
COMMUNITY LIVING. IN THE CENTER
FOR DISEASE CONTROL TO ALLOW THE
COUNCIL TO FULLY EXPAND THESE
FUNDS AND THE FOLLOWING YEAR IN
THE BUDGET YEAR. AND THAT
CONCLUDES THE MAYREVISION
PROPOSALS FOR THE STATE COUNCIL
WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
HELLO. WHEN YOU PUT IT WITH THE
L. A. WE DO NOT HAVE CONCERNS
WITH THIS PROPOSAL THANK YOU I
DON'T EITHER. OKAY LET'S MOVE ON
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF COMMUNITY
SERVICES AND DEVELOPMENT FIESCHI
. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
IN THIS YOU WILL BAKER WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I'M JOINED
BY CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR JASON
WEMBLEY OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
COMMUNITY SERVICES AND
DEVELOPMENT. I'LL BE A PROVIDING
THE BRIEF OVERVIEW AND WE'LL
BOTH BE AVAILABLEFOR QUESTIONS
AFTER. SO THE FIRST FOR BOESEL
ADAM IN THE MAY REVISION FOR CST
IS THE CALIFORNIA RICH PAYMENT
PROGRAM THAT CALIFORNIA RICH
PAYMENT PROGRAM OR CAP WAS
ESTABLISHED IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BUDGET. AND ADMINISTERED OWN WAS
ADMINISTERED BY C. S. D. S. YES
D. SUCCESSFULLY DIRECTED ONE
BILLION DOLLARS IN FEDERAL STATE
FISCAL RECOVERY FUNDS- AS
ASSISTANCE TO REDUCE OR
ELIMINATE PASS DO. ENERGY BILL
BALANCES THAT WERE CREW BY
CUSTOMERS DURING THE COPA
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. THE MAY
REVISION INCLUDES AN ADDITIONAL
ONE POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS IN
GENERAL FUND TO HELP ADDRESS
ENERGY- RIDGES THAT WERE FURTHER
ACCUMULATED BY CALIFORNIA
HOUSEHOLDS DURING THE COPA
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. AT THE TWENTY
TO. TWENTY TWENTY TWO CALIFORNIA
RICH PAYMENT PROGRAM WILL
CONTINUE THE STATE'S DISASTER
RESPONSE EFFORTS TO ADDRESS THE
ECONOMIC IMPACTS OF THE RECENT
PANDEMIC CALIFORNIA IS CURRENTLY
SEEKING CLARIFICATION FROM
FEDERAL FEDERAL OFFICIALS TO
CONFIRM. AND THAT THE STATE CAN
ADMINISTER THESE FUNDS
CONSISTENT WITH FEDERAL GUIDANCE
ON THE TAXABILITY OF DISASTER
RELIEF THAT. WAS PREVIOUSLY HELD
FOR THE CALIFORNIA RICH PAYMENT
PROGRAM. THIS PROGRAM. WILL ALSO
INCLUDE PROVISIONAL LANGUAGES
STATUTORY CHANGES TO ENSURE A
SUCCESSFUL AND EFFICIENT
IMPLEMENTATION OF CAPS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AND THE
ADMINISTRATION LOOKS FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE ON
THIS PROPOSAL. WE CAN GO OUT AND
TAKE A MOMENT NOW IF THAT'S
APPROPRIATE. FROM WHICH CONTINUE
ON. OUR THEY GOING TO MORE IN
THE SECTION. YES THE NEXT THERE
WAS A REBEL PROPOSAL THE LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLD WATER
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM WHICH WOULD
PROVIDE FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE TO
LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS TO HELP
MANAGE THE RESIDENTIAL WATER
UTILITY COST. THIS PROGRAMS
BETTER KNOWN AS LYE WHAT WHICH
WAS CREATED UNDER THE FEDERAL
CONSOLIDATED APPROPRIATIONS ACT
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
CALIFORNIA'S SHARE OF THE ONE
TIME ALLY WHAT GRANT FUNDS WAS
ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS. AND THE MAYOR REVISION
INCLUDES AN ADDITIONAL TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT IN ONE TIME FEDERAL
STATE AND LOCAL FISCAL RECOVERY
FUNDS TO SUPPLEMENT THE FEDERAL
ALLOCATION FOR THE LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLD WATER ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM AND TO CONTINUE THE
PROGRAM AFTER THE EXISTING
FEDERAL FUNDING EXPIRES OR IS
SET TO EXPIRE IN SEPTEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD ALLOW THE PROGRAM
SHOULD BE CONTINUED THROUGH JUNE
THIRTIETH 202-020-2020 SIX AND
WITH A ALLOW THESE FUNDS TO BE
LIQUIDATED THROUGH DECEMBER
THIRTY ONE TWENTY TWENTY SIX AND
THIS PROPOSAL INCLUDES RELATIVES
WERE RELATED PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGES AT STORY CHANGES AS
WELL ENSURE THAT THE FUNDS CAN
BE SUCCESSFULLY EXPANDED TO THE
SPIRITS THAT WE JUST MENTIONED.
AND LASTLY THERE IS A REQUEST IN
THE MAY REVISION TO INCREASE.
FEDERAL FUNDED STORY BY ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE MILLION. FOR
THE I. C. U. S. D. TO UTILIZE
SUPPLEMENTAL GRANT FINDINGS THAT
THEY RECEIVED FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY FOR THEIR
WEATHER WEATHERIZATION
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM THE
DEPARTMENT WAS NOTIFIED IN MARCH
TWENTY TWENTY TWO THAT IT WILL
BE RECEIVING AN AUGMENTATION IN
ITS ANNUAL WEATHER
WEATHERIZATION ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM ALLOCATION. DUE TO
RECENT INCREASES WITHIN THE
BIPARTISAN INFRASTRUCTURE LAW
DEPARTMENT PLANS TO BEGIN
SPENDING THESE FUNDS IN THE NEXT
FISCAL YEAR AND SUBSEQUENT WE
ARE WE'RE WE'RE REQUESTING.
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL FUNDING FOR
THE FOR THIS REQUEST. WITHOUT
THAT CONCLUDES THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSALS FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
COMMUNITY SERVICES AND
DEVELOPMENT AND WE'RE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS
SHORT. THANK YOU AGAIN ANGELES
SHORT WITH THE L. A. O. I'M JUST
A BRIEF COMMENT REGARDING THE
CALIFORNIA AVERAGE PAYMENT
PROGRAM- THAT FIRST PROPOSAL
DESCRIBED UNDER CST IN YOUR
AGENDA. WE'RE WAITING FOR
DETAILED PROPOSAL AND BUDGET
LANGUAGE TO BE ABLE TO FULLY
ASSESS THE IMPLEMENTATION
DETAILS OF THIS PROPOSAL- WE DO
BELIEVE IT HAS MERIT- THE
INITIAL ONE BILLION PROVIDED FOR
CAP- WAS ALLOCATED QUITE QUICKLY
AND EFFICIENTLY IN THE CURRENT
YEAR- AND PROVIDED MORE THAN ONE
MILLION CALIFORNIANS WEST
UTILITY DEBT RELIEF DURING THE
PANDEMIC. AND AS YOU ALSO JUST
HEARD FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ARE UNDERSTANDING AS THE
PROPOSED AUGMENTATION OF AN
ADDITIONAL ONE POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS- WOULD ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT TO ADDRESS THE
IDENTIFIED REMAINING RESIDENTIAL
UTILITY- RAGES- ACCRUED DURING
THE PANDEMIC. IT WILL CERTAINLY
RAISE ANY NEW ISSUES FOR
LEGISLATIVE CONSIDERATION ONCE
WE HAVE THAT LANGUAGE AS I
MENTIONED- BUT JUST WANTED TO
USE YOU TO RESPECT COMMENT AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH IN THIS IN THIS
CONSTANT TOWARD OUR CELL IS THAT
CORRECT THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
WE CAN DO TO HELP PEOPLE RIGHT
AWAY. AND IT DOESN'T GO TO
ONGOING COSTS. RIGHT THIS IS A-
STUDENT- PROPOSED. OKAY GREAT
AND IDA- JUST LIKE SAVE A FAN AM
OF THE- THE WEATHERIZATION AND
ALL OF THOSE PROGRAMS ARE JUST
HUGE HUGE HELPS FOR PEOPLE
ESPECIALLY LIVING IN THE VALLEY
WITH VERY HIGH RATES. I WAS
TALKING TO ONE OF MY FRIENDS WHO
USES A LOT OF OUR PROGRAMS AND
SO I GET TO HEAR ABOUT THEM
FIRST HAND THAT HE WAS GETTING.
POOR PEOPLE SOLAR AND WAS SO
EXCITED THAT HIS POWER BILL IS
GOING TO GO. FROM OVER THREE
HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH TO UNDER
A HUNDRED SO. WE'RE DOING GOOD
WORK WITH THANKS DR.
OF CHILD SUPPORT SERVICES. RIGHT
LASTLY HERE WITH THE TROUT
DEPARTMENT OF CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES I AM JOINED BY DIRECTOR
DAVID KILGOUR OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF CHILD SUPPORT SERVICES AND I
WOULD PROVIDING THE BRIEF
OVERVIEW AND WE'LL BOTH BE
AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS- THIS
MAY REVISION PROPOSAL INCLUDES A
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENT FOR THE-
DEPARTMENT OF CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES IN THEIR LOCAL
ASSISTANCE ITEMS BASED ON
UPDATED DATA FOR CHILD SUPPORT
COLLECTIONS OF THE DEPARTMENT
ESTIMATES THAT COLLECTIONS. I
WILL DECREASE BY APPROXIMATELY
ONE MILLION DOLLARS WHICH
REDUCES THE AMOUNT OF LOCAL
ASSISTANCE FUNDS AVAILABLE IN
THE CHILD SUPPORT RECOVERY FUND
AND WHEN THIS FUNDING INCREASES
A CORRESPONDING INCREASE IN THE
DEPARTMENTS FEDERAL FUNDS IS
NECESSARY TO MAINTAIN SUFFICIENT
LOCAL ASSISTANCE FUNDING
CONSEQUENTLY A NET ZERO
ADJUSTMENT BETWEEN THE CHILD
SUPPORT COLLECTIONS RECOVERY
FUND IN FEDERAL FUNDS IS NEEDED
AND THAT IS WHAT THIS REQUEST IS
FOR- AND WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH EARLIER.
THANK YOU PERSONALLY- NUMBER
WITH THIS PROPOSAL OKAY I DON'T
HAVE ANY CONTRACT TRANSLATING ON
US- THANK YOU I GUESS- CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE PROPOSING
HERE I DO WONDER WHETHER- AND I
KNOW THAT THERE ARE SOME
CONVERSATIONS WITH- THE CHILD
SUPPORT DIRECTORS AND SO FORTH-
WHETHER WE SHOULD BE. THINKING
WE WORK HARD TO ENSURE THAT WE
CAN- HAVE EFFECTIVE AND
EFFICIENT- CHILD SUPPORT PROGRAM
AND I KNOW THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION AND LET'S THEIR
WORK TOGETHER AND IN DOING THAT-
AND I DO APPRECIATE THAT IN THE-
JANUARY BUDGET- DID YOU
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED SOME
ADDITIONAL FUNDS TO TRY TO
COMPLETE THAT PROCESS- BUT ALSO.
MY THINK ABOUT WHETHER THERE ARE
SOME ADDITIONAL FUNDS ARE NEEDED
TO BE SURE THAT- WE HAVE EQUITY
YOU CROSS THE COUNTIES AND THAT-
WEEK- AND IN FAIRNESS TO ENSURE
THAT WE CAN- HAVE EFFECTIVE-
WELL FISH INTO CHILD SUPPORT.
COLLECTION OF PROGRAMS THAT- I
THINK IN THE END- COURSE GETS
MORE RESOURCES TO FAMILIES IN
NEED SO- SO YET APPRECIATE- SO
HOPEFULLY WE CAN HAVE FURTHER
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THAT AS
WORKERS WERE MVING FORWARD-
BUT- I DO APPRECIATE THEN THE
JET ENGINE GENERAL PROPOSAL BUT
WONDERING WHETHER WE SHOULD BE
LOOKING. AT IS THAT STILL
SUFFICIENT OR NOT BUT- OKAY. YOU
VERY MUCH. OKAY I THINK
INCLUDES- OUR AGENDA ITEMS FOR
TODAY WE THINK THE L. A. O. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
APARTMENTS FOR ALL OF THEIR WORK
WAS OUR STAFF HERE IN THE SPRING
AND NOW WE WILL MOVE ON TO
PUBLIC COMMENTS THAT WE SEE
PEOPLE HERE IN THE IN THE-
HEARING ROOM. ARE WELCOME THE
FIRST PERSON HI. HI SENATORS AND
MADAM CHAIR- CRISTINA BUS
HAMILTON I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE ECONOMIC SECURITY PROJECT
ACTION. AND HE WAS NOT
ADDRESSING THE GOVERNOR'S NEWLY
REVISED HOWEVER WE ARE SPONSOR
OF SENATOR. IZZY'S PROPOSAL TO
CREATE THE CALIFORNIA SUCCESS
OPPORTUNITY AND ACADEMIC
RESILIENCE GUARANTEED INCOME
PILOT PROGRAM. THAT IS FOR
HOMELESS HIGH SCHOOL SENIORS. IT
WOULD PROVIDE FIVE MONTHS. OF
THE- GUARANTEED INCOME OF A
THOUSAND DOLLARS A MONTH. DURING
THE CRITICAL MONTHS BETWEEN
APRIL. AND AUGUST. THROUGH APRIL
AS THEY APPROACH HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATION. UNTIL COLLEGE BEGINS
IN AUGUST IS. SHOWN TO BE THE
MONTHS OF DROP OFF WE'RE
STUDENTS AND THIS IS ACROSS THE
INCOME SPECTRUM BUT ESPECIALLY
BAD FOR LOOK. STUDENTS IT. IS
THE- TO SECONDARY EDUCATION
HOWEVER BETWEEN GRADUATION AND
REAL LIFE HAPPENS YOU REALIZE
YOU NEED TO PUT A DOWN PAYMENT
ON A AN APARTMENT. YOU REALIZE
YOU HAVE COSTS THAT
COVERED BY FINANCIAL AID
ETCETERA. SO THE GOAL OF THIS IS
A PILOT PROGRAM IS ONE YEAR. OF
A THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR FIVE
MONTHS AND THAT IS AN EIGHTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR REQUEST. ANY
WOULD THE PROPOSAL IS TO HAVE IT
THE ADMINISTERED THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT. MY NAME IS BECKY THE AND I
THE EXACT DIRECTOR OF THE CAL.
SAYS OR DON'T THEY SIR.
REPRESENTING TWO HUNDRED SEA
BASS AND EIGHTY P. PROGRAMS IN
CALIFORNIA. OUR BUDGET ASK WAS
NODDING DID IN THE MAY BUDGET
REVISED. WE CONTINUE TO URGE YOU
TO SUPPORT OUR BRIDGE TO
RECOVERY IT'S A ONE TIME FUNDING
REQUEST OF SIXTY ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION. THIS PROPOSAL ALSO
MAYORS A CHILD CARE- FACILITY
MAKER. THAT WAS ALREADY FELT IT
IN THE BUDGET IT'S IMPERATIVE WE
GET THIS FUNDING SO CENTERS CAN
PROVIDE A SAFE TRANSITION. TO IN
PERSON SERVICES IT ADDRESSES
COVERT RESPONSE BY HELPING
CENTERS MAKE NECESSARY FACILITY
IMPROVEMENTS. EASES WORKFORCE
ISSUES TRANSPORTATION ISSUES AND
IT KEEPS CALIFORNIA'S MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATION SAFE. THIS
REQUESTED BECOMING- AS THERE IS
NOW A POTENTIAL JULY FIRST AND
TWO TEMPORARY ALTERNATIVE
SERVICES THAT HAVE BEEN APPROVED
APPROVED THROUGH THE PANDEMIC.
BUT AS THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY ENDS IF THIS FUNDING
IS NOT APPROVED CENTERS A WON'T
HAVE THE RESOURCES THEY NEED TO
STAY OPEN. A CRITICAL BECAUSE
WITHOUT THIS FUNDING CENTERS
WILL CLOSE. I WILL LOSE THE
SERVICES AND SUPPORT THEY NEED
AND CLIENTS AND THERE'S OVER
FORTY THOUSAND SENIORS INFILL
DISABLED ADULTS THAT RELY ON OUR
SERVICES IN CALIFORNIA WILL LOSE
SERVICES MOST OF THIS FUNDING
WORK. AGAIN EXEMPTS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT PERSON PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON- MICROBES IN HERE
ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL FOR- INCREASE FOR NEW-
AND WE'RE JUST PAYMENT PROGRAM
WOULD ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEE TO
LOOK AT ENSURING THAT THERE'S
DISTINCT PARKS AS A WASN'T
TWENTY ONE BETWEEN THE- UTILITY
TYPES. AND DESPITE THE STATE
HOUSE OUT TO LIMIT- MANY COURAGE
LOOK AT THE FACT THAT YOU USING
LEFT OVER FEDERAL FUNDS BECAUSE
THERE IS A TAX ADVANTAGED HERE
RATE PAYERS IN USING THAT MONEY
SO. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
EXPRESSION PLEASE. HELLO CARE
MEMBERS THE SENATE JIMENEZ HERE
WITH GRACE AND CHILD POVERTY
CALIFORNIA. AND THIS YEAR WE ARE
URGING THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR TO PRIORITIZE A TEN
BILLION DOLLAR PACKAGE TO FIGHT
POVERTY- WE KNOW THAT THE PAIN
OF THE PANDEMIC COULD NOT FALL
EQUALLY ON THE- COME COMMUNITIES
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR- THE
LEGISLATURE THE GOVERNOR. TO USE
THIS PHONE PRESIDENT BUDGET PLUS
. GET RELIEF TO THE POOREST OF
THOSE IN CALIFORNIA-
SPECIFICALLY WE WANT TO THANK
THE GOVERNOR FOR INCLUDING A
TWELVE MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND FOR PROMISE NEIGHBORHOODS
IN HIS BUDGET OF COURSE WE ARE
SEEKING FOR FURTHER FUNDING ON
THAT BECAUSE WE WANT TO. OUR
POSTS ARE ONLY SUPPORTED- AND WE
ALSO ARE PEOPLE FOR THE
GOVERNOR- INCLUDING WAVING A
CHILD CARE FAMILY FEES FOR AN
ADDITIONAL YEAR- I DO HOPE THAT
THIS CAN CALL FOR AN ADDITIONAL
A TWO UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY FOUR-
UNLESS YOU JUST WANT TO. THANK
OUR THANK THE SENATE FOR IN
INCLUDING ITS BUDGET-
PRIORITIES- NEED TO- INCREASE
CAL GRANT UP- ABOUT THE FIVE
FEDERAL POVERTY LINE FOR ALL
FAMILIES- AND ALSO ENSURING THAT
1100% PASS THROUGH A CHILD
SUPPORT FOR CHILDREN ON CAL
WORKS OF THANK YOU SO MUCH TO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. PERSON HI
MADAM CHAIR OF MY WITH THE WEST
THANK YOU FOR HEARING TODAY I'M
A FEW COMMENTS ON WE DO
APPRECIATE THE FUNDING THAT'S IN
THE BUDGET FOR THE CALPERS FRAN
INCREASE- THAT'S THROWING A- SO.
LONG OVERDUE BUT AS AN OVERALL
MATTER WE FIND AT THE MAY
REVISED BUDGET I'M REFLECTS A
MISSED OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY
ADDRESS POVERTY- WE'RE MUCH MORE
IN SUPPORT OF WHAT WE TALK ABOUT
OF THE SENATE A COUPLE WEEKS
AGO- WE ARE. FOR EXAMPLE JUST
MATHIS MENTIONED BEFORE- WE WANT
TO IN THE POVERTY MAKE HOURS
PROGRAM WE SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL
TO DO THE ASSISTANCE UNIT PLUS
ONE EFFORT THAT WOULD GET US TO
THE NO CHILD LIVES IN POVERTY.
CALIFORNIA WE- ACCELERATING SSI
SS B. GRAY. THAT WAS THREE TWO
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR TO ACCELERATE
THAT INTO THIS YEAR'S BUDGET SO
THE FAILED THE SSI RECIPIENTS
GET THAT MONEY NEXT YEAR NOT
HAVE TO WAIT ANOTHER TWENTY.
FOUR MONTHS BEFORE THEY GET THAT
MONEY- WE SUPPORT THE SENATE'S
PROPOSAL TO EXT- AS YOU JUST
MENTIONED DR PAN. TO STEM
PROPOSAL PASTOR CHILD SUPPORT
PAYMENTS TO EXIT. FAMILY THE ALL
OBVIOUS THOSE FAMILIES WHO FOR
ARC HOURS BUT WE- ALREADY HERE
THE CURRENT CALPERS FAMILIES WHO
REALLY NEED THAT MONEY AND THEN
LASTLY WE WANNA CALL UP THE
INCREASE IN THE RESERVE THAT WAS
ALSO DISCUSSED EARLIER. IN THIS
PAIN WE THINK IT'S A PRETTY WITH
THE SENATE THAT WE NEED DID WE
NEED TO PREPARE FOR THE FUTURE
AND HAVE RESOURCE SET ASIDES
THOSE AT. IN LEVELS DON'T GO
DOWN IN THE FUTURE- AND THEN WE
LAST WE DO SUPPORT ALL THE
CARROTS- AND THAT'S JUST ONE
TIME PAYMENT CENTER REFERENCE IN
THE SENATE. PROPOSAL COME
THROUGH CDSS DID A REMARKABLE
JOB OF GETTING THIS OUT FOR
CLIENTS LAST YEAR- I KNOW I
THOUGHT THAT WAS MY LAST THING
BUT I LIED. ALSO FOR ELIMINATE
THE- PATH OF THE COUNTY SHE- OF
. CANNA PENALTIES THAT WOULD BE
IMPOSED IF WE FAIL TO MEET WORK
PARTICIPATION. RIGHT NOW ALL OF
THAT IS REALLY AREN'T HARMING
OUR EFFORTS TO MOVE TOWARDS. CAL
OR AND CAL WORKS TWO POINT NO
MORE MODERN VIEW OF CAL WORKS-
AND MUCH LIKE WE SEE WITH CHILD
SUPPORT. THE STATE UNFORTUNATELY
IS PLACING ITS INTERESTS. AHEAD
OF THE NEEDS OF OUR FAMILIES.
AND WE SIMPLY CAN'T HAVE THAT WE
NEED TO GET RID OF THIS FAMILY
ON THE COUNTIES. JUST LIKE WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
FAMILIES AND CHILD SUPPORT. GET
THE MONEY THAT'S INTENDED FOR
THEM THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT PERSON PLEASE. WELL OPEN DIDN'T DO TOO MUCH
DAMAGE. WELL RICHARD PAN I WILL
TACKLE WHAT WAS MADE BY MARK
PREVIOUSLY CALIFORNIA FOR SSI
COALITION WILL ALSO SPEAK TO
FROM THE- CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF
RETIRED AMERICANS I WILL ALSO
SPEAK TO AS FAR AS DEALING WITH
THE DISABILITY COMMUNITY OF ALL
OF THE CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN
BROUGHT FORWARD TO YOU SOME OF
ANY COLLEAGUES THE WRONG THE
APPROPRIATE COMMITTEE PLEASE
ASSIST PLEASE THE GOING THROUGH
IN ANY WAY POSSIBLE IT AGAIN
HERE BECAUSE OF. THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO WORK WITH THE
STATEMENT THAT THE LIKE WAS I
BELIEVE THE GOVERNOR. COULD
COULD AND SHOULD HAVE DONE A LOT
MORE THAN HE LEADS- I HOPE THE-
THE SENATE IS DONE A GREAT JOB
I'M HOPING THAT THE ONE YOU LOVE
. ASSEMBLY ISSUES DO LIKE WHAT
WHEN I WAS LAST WEEK HEARING
THROUGH SPOKE. UP VERY. PORT
ABOUT THAT I HOPE YOU DIDN'T
SURE THIS GETS FALL OF. YEAH IF
YOU'LL KNOW YOU'LL SEE ME AGAIN-
AS IT IS IN NOW. SO THAT'S MY
FOR THIS. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OKAY SEE NOBODY ELSE
IN THE HEARING ROOMS WILL GO TO
THE PHONE LINES. OPERATOR IS
THERE. YES MA'AM SURE WITH
JEALOUSY OVER THIRTY BONDS SOLD
COMMENT PRESS ONE ZERO QUESTION
WILL SEVEN HUNDRED MOVIES FROM
THE PEOPLE. AND OF COURSE WE GO
TO LINE NUMBER TWENTY TWO WE
STILL HAVE. THANK YOU MADAM
NUMBER PERFECT BUT VETERANS THE
PROJECT. SAYS HE IS. FOR GREAT
FOR THE TIME YOU FELT WITH A
MISTER TO ENSURE NEED FOR WELL
UNDER THAT. I'M I'M- ARE ABOUT
WITH VERY VERY. I WANT TO
PROVIDE BEST POSSIBLE FOR FROM.
THE FAMILY WALDRON COOPER DAHLE
INDIVIDUAL EIGHT. MILLION AREAS
OF CONCERN FLAG CONSIDER THAT
STEPS AND ROUNDING OUT BUT
PACKAGE. THE COUNTY POLITICAL
THE OPERATE AND- AFTER THE VOTE
THE MEMBER MEASURE. WOULD COME
BOTH HOW FAR. AND CAL WORK
ABILITY OPERATE AT AT A TIME
WHENBEFORE. ARE PROJECTED IT.
IN BOTH. HOW ARE PUBLIC PARK
TOWN. SUPPORT FOR MOST THERE. I
THE SAME TIME WE WILL BE BACK AT
BEING RE ENGAGING FAMILY ARE
IMPLEMENTING CAL AND THE HELP
AND SUPPORT. HOW FRANKLY FOR THE
PRISON'S THE- OKAY IN. WE HAVE A
WONDERFUL TO PROVIDE SIXTY
MILLION FUND AND COST. AND FIFTY
FIVE MILLION GENERAL FUND INCOME
. TRIMS EUREKA WHICH TRULY ARE
CUT TO SERVICES FOR LOWER CAL.
DO NOT OCCUR AND ECONOMIC HELP
SERVICES VERY WE'VE VERY THE
GOAL THAT. IN THIS AREA WE HAVE
YET TO BE TO BILL A THE PROPOSED
FORM AND FIFTY NINE DOLLARS
GRANT PROGRAM BUT UNDERSTAND
THAT IT IS FOR WELL IT'S NARROW
FOCUS SET OF SERVICES AND
SUPPORT. BUT ALSO FOR. WE
RECOMMEND THAT THE PLUS THE
FIFTY MILLION DOUBLE FIVE
BECAUSE THE GIVER APPROVAL IS
THE FRONT THE REAPER AND IF COST
THEY ARE INCURRING WHICH IS ONE
HUNDRED DOLLARS ANNUALLY IN THE
REQUESTED OSCAR CHRISTMAS WITH
AT THE PORT OR- PROGRAM WHAT
ALSO IS ONE OF MILLION DOLLARS.
THESE ITEMS HAVE BE EIGHT TO
PROVIDE THE KNOWLEDGE AND
WITHOUT A ME MAN REQUIRE WELFARE
OF THIS FEEDBACK THE TRAILER
BILL SPOKE AT THE STATE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANKS COLOR
PLEASE. NEXT LINE NUMBER. ONE
YEAR ONE IS OPEN WITH. I GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN JIM WITH
HELLO CLIMATE AND I GREW NETWORK
LOCAL OF FAMINE ARGUE ARE ORGANS
. BECOME VERY BUDGETING TROOPS
FUNDING FOR IT IS SLOW HOME
WHETHER THEY PRO. BUT IT DOES
NOT INCLUDE FUNDING FOR THE
FARMER AND THE POOR AT THE- AND
SO WE'RE THINKING AN ADDITIONAL
FIVE MILLION FROM THE FORMER
CLINTON COME OF THIS IS PROGRAM.
IF YOU TIRTEEN IMPACT FARMER
ARE FOR THE OF EXPERIENCING
HEALTH FROM AND WILDFIRES. AND
FARMWORKERS FACE MUCH GREATER
RISK OF HEAT RELATED DEATHS
TWENTY TO THIRTY FIVE FOLD
INCREASE COMPARED TO OTHER
WORKERS. AND FARMERS ARE
VULNERABILITIES EXTREME HEAT
SMOKE CAN BE ADDRESSED IN A
NUMBER OF FRONTS INCLUDING
IMPROVING FARM WORKER HOUSING.
WE NEED. ADDRESS IT FAX SYSTEM
ENERGY MY SO PLACE LANXESS.
FARMWORKERS AND SHOULD BE AN
ONGOING STRIDES TO DRAW HE TAKES
. OF PRESIDENTIAL ALL CHEATING-
AND SAVINGS AND EMISSION RATE.
FORMER REALLY INVESTMENTS ARE
LARGELY MISSING IN THE JANUARY
IN BUDGET PROPOSAL AND WE HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO CORRECT THAT
OVERSIGHT IN THE FINAL BUDGET BY
INVESTING STATE AND FEDERAL
DOLLARS SPECIFIC TO THE
FARMWORKERS COMPONENT OF THE LOW
INCOME HOME WEATHERIZATION
PROGRAM THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANKS CALLER PLEASE.
MISALIGNED WITH TWENTY NINE
GOING UP. TWENTY NINE GO AHEAD
PLEASE. TWENTY NINE OF WHAT THE
QUEUE ON THE LINE NUMBER THIRTY
ONE THIRTY ONE SOFTWARE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR. DEL
DENTALS ON BEHALF OF THE PPO YOU
DID UP THERE I'M CALLING FOR THE
H. CARE ACT PREP BEFORE FOR THAT
PERTAINING TO TRUCKS ARE ON THE
PHONE NUMBER FOR YOU. NAME ONLY
THE FAMILY FEEL WAIVER HARMLESS
FILE IT. FELT GOOD ABOUT TWENTY
FIRST. AND OKAY THANK MEANT
BURKE KEPT UP GRANT AS A CHILD.
BOB PROVISIONS PROVIDED BY THEY
MAY. WE'RE REQUESTING FIVE
HUNDRED THANK YOUNG GOING AND A
HUNDRED MILLION ONE TIME TO
FULLY FIND HEALTH CARE THE
RETIREMENT BENEFITS. AS WELL-
BIG BOXES ARE TYPICALLY USED
JOINT LABOR MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE
RECOMMENDATION. THIS BENEFITS
ARE CRITICAL. TO BELIEVE IF THE
POLITICAL THE CHILD CARE
WORKFORCE WE APPRECIATE THE
HEARING TODAY IT THEN-
RECOGNIZING THE NEED FOR MORE
FUNDING TO PROVIDE BENEFITS FOR
FAMILY CHILD CARE PROVIDERS. AB
REFLECTED BY THE- BLUEPRINT-
LOOK FORWARD. LOOKING DEEP
DISCUSSION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ON
THE LINE FORTY ONE FORTY ONE
COULD YOU HAVE. ONE FORTY ONE
CHECK YOU MAY BE NEEDED ON YOUR
SITE IS A NEW GLASS. ONE FORTY
FIVE ONE FORTY FIVE GONZALEZ IS
. I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS EDGAR CHAVEZ
AND THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF HE
WERE PROMISED NEIGHBORHOODS
CALLING HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF ASSISTANCE FOR PRIVATE. ISSUE
FOR. WE APPRECIATE OF COMMERCE
INTO FUNDING PROMISING AND WE
RESPECT THE VERGE LEGISLATURE TO
FULLY FUND MARKLEEVILLE DECLARE
ORGANIZATIONS WITH THE BUDGET
REQUEST CHAMPION BY SEPTEMBER
BONTA. IF PLACE BASED
INVESTMENTS FORTY FRAMEWORK FOR
A WHOLE CHILD WHOLE FAMILY
APPROACH NEEDED TO ENSURE THAT
OUR LOW INCOME FAMILIES ARE
STANDARD IN AN EQUITABLE AND
PROBABLY. BY MAKING OUR
SITUATIONS MORE EFFICIENT YOUR
COMMUNITY BASED INFRASTRUCTURE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANKS COLOR PLEASE. ONE FIFTY
ONE PLEASE GO IN. THANK YOU SO
MUCH GOOD AFTERNOON KAREN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS DONNA HOFFMAN
CULLEN AND I'M CALLING
RPRESENTING COUNCIL BERTHON
MEREKA BAIK CRIME INVESTING KIDS
MISSION READINESS AND READY
NATION I'M CALLING ABOUT ISSUE
FORTY SEVEN TODAY AND FUNDING
RELATED TO CHILD CARE PROGRAM.
BURKE BUT HERE WITH THE HI FOR.
OUR SYSTEM PARTICULARLY THE
WAITING FAMILY B. HARM OF
POLICIES INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT.
HOWEVER ARE GOING FOR ABOUT A
LACK WITH BASS TO ADDRESS LEAD
THIRTY HOW INDUSTRY. ESPECIALLY
IN A TIME OF HIGH INFLATION
INCREASE PRICES. THANK YOU FOR
HEALTHCARE INDUSTRY AFLOAT WE
MUST NOT FORCE SURE THAT WE HAVE
A. THE CARE FOR HOW AGAIN
CHILDREN. OUR BUDGET SURPLUS NOT
REFER THREE OF OUR SHOW INDUSTRY
FEET AND THEN TO PUT AND
GENERATION FOR SUCCESS. WE TO
START IN YOUR IF YOU'RE- THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MEXICO
PLEASE. WHY FIFTY FIVE. WHICH
WILL. GOOD AFTERNOON THAT AND
SHE MEMBERS MY IS JEAN FROM THE
BRACE FUTURES EDGED PARTNERS AND
I'M CALLING YOU STRONG OF
ASSISTANCE FOR FROM
NEIGHBORHOODS IF YOU FORTY
SEVEN. HEY THINK COLLUSION
TWELVE MILLION DOLLARS TO FUND.
NEIGHBORHOODS AND WE RISK URGE
ALLEGED TO FULLY FOR MORE CRADLE
TO CAREER ORGANIZATIONS. IT IS
TO KEEP TRACK OVER COPY FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS FAMILIES THIS IS A
BUDGET REQUEST CHAMPION BY
STANLEY MEMBER BONTA THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE TIME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANKS CALLER
PLEASE. LINE SEVENTEEN IS GOING
TO. I JUST CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES ACTUALLY
FACT IS GRATEFUL FOR THE NEW
COST THE CURRENT BEST MENTION
THE NAME REVISED IN MILLION FOR
RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION FOR
INTENSIVE FAMILY FUNDING WELL
THIS FUNDING IS WELCOME AND MEET
THE CREDIT THE FACT THAT SUPPORT
THE REQUEST. A THANK YOU. FOR A
HUNDRED MILLION ON. AND THAT THE
STATE IS REQUIRED TO COVER UNDER
PROPOSITION THIRTY. AND A
HUNDRED MILLION FOR THE FIRST
PROGRAM WHICH WILL. HELP ENSURE
THAT ALL COUNTY JERSEY FAMILY
PLANNING FUNDING INDEPENDENT
MANNER INSTEAD OF UTILIZING THE
PROPOSED GRANT PROGRAM WITH
COUNTY MATCH. I REGARDING
UPDATING COUNTY ADMIN FUNNY OF
COURSE INCREASED AMOUNT BY THE
MAYOR VISION FOR CALFRESH UNTIL
THE NEW BUDGETING METHODOLOGIES
DEVELOPED WE CONTINUE TO HAVE IT
FOR AN ADDITIONAL SIXTY MILLION
ANNUALLY. WHICH IS CRITICALLY
NEEDED TO HELP DIGITAL ACCESS TO
SPECIAL BENEFITS. FOR CAO WORKS
WITH SUPPORT OF FIFTY FIVE
MILLION BACK THOUGH FOR THE
PROPOSED AT COUNTY ELIGIBILITY
REYES. WILL HELP MAKE SHIFT
SOURCE PLAY. SIR THE FAMILY THE
TO RE ENGAGE WORKFORCE. I
FINALLY BUT I THE FACT THAT
PROVIDE. PHOTO THE FACT SHEET
VETERANS FROM THE ANNEXED START. ANY SUCCESSFUL IN THIS PROGRAM
I LOOK FOR DIFFERENT GETTING
THESE AND ISSUES. THANK VERY
MUCH CALLER PLEASE. LINE FIVE
PLEASE GO. JOSH DUGGAR ON BEHALF
OF MULTIPLE CLIENTS TO STAY
FOCUSED ON DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITY ISSUES FIRST ON
BEHALF OF THE EAST BAY
INNOVATION STRATEGY TO EMPOWER
PEOPLE WE ARE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
THE FIVE MILLION PDF PILOT FOR
REMOTE SUPPORT WE'VE BEEN
GETTING BIRTH ANOTHER PILOT WITH
OUR STAKEHOLDER I MEAN FOR THAT
MANY ON THIRD. HELLO THIS CAN
PROMOTE FORTY. AND OFFERED FOR
MORE CLUE THAN IN. WHAT FOR P.
WITH AND DEVELOPMENTAL THE- AND
WE ARE EXCITED TO WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION WHAT LATER TO
FULLY ALIGN OUR COLLECTIVE.
THANK YOU ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY. WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE EAST INDIA
COMPLIANCE BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
REPORT ARMAND. ENCOURAGE MAKING
THAT INFORMATION AVAILABLE TO
THE PUBLICUPON. WE ARE ALSO
SUPPORTED OF THE YES VISION
ALTHOUGH FOR WORK FOR STABILITY
PACKAGE AIMED AT ADDRESSING
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION OF
DIRECT SUPPORT PROFESSIONAL
INCLUDING A REMOTE SUPPORT I LET
IN. WORK A LITTLE BIT THAT GIVES
FUNDING TO THE PROVIDER AND THAT
CLICK POSSIBLE YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH TAX COLOR PLEASE. WHAT
IF THE SEVENTIES GOING TO. THE
DOCUMENT MANAGER MEMBERS MY NAME
IS CHRISTINE TRAN FROM GRACE AND
HELP TALKING CALIFORNIA CON
HERE'S SEAN SUPPORT OF IT YOUR
COLLEGE NEIGHBORHOOD UNDER ISSUE
FORTY SEVEN WE APPRECIATE THE
INCLUSION FOR MONDAY. ON THE
FORTHCOMING. SPECT YOU COULD YOU
FORTY FIVE PEOPLE WORK APPROVED
YOUR OR- TO WORK IN HIM TO MEET
. OF OUR FAMILY ARE SUPPORTED
FROM BEFORE BIRTH THROUGH
COLLEGE CAREER. FOR FUNDING FOR
THE ISSUE MIX NXP OF YOUR THE
ORDER. IT'S A ONE TIME NINETY
TWO FOR WORK. OUT THE CREATION
ACCOUNT FOR ACCORDING. AND HE
YEAH PROGRAMS YEAH BY FORMER
MEMBER ON AND HURT MY- BOX MEDIA.
FOUR HE'S GONNA. HI. THANK YOU
NOT I MEAN IT'S NOT THEN I WOULD
TELL HER NOW CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF ISSUE NUMBER FORTY
SEVEN OF THE DSS HEALTHCARE
ISSUES WE APPRECIATE THE NEW
INVESTMENTS THAT SUPPORT
BELIEVING THE FAMILY FEES AND A
ONE YEAR FUNDING FOR CHILD CARE
RATEINCREASES OVER GIVEN THE
LONGSTANDING CRISIS WITHIN THE
CHILD WITH THEM AT CENTRAL TO
THE RECOVERY OF THE ECONOMY AND
ENSURING SAFE AND NURTURING
EXPERIENCES FOR CHILDREN ARE
HAPPIER WORKERS. DANJEL FORTY
MILLION AND THAT MAKE AND
RAPIDLY INCREASING INFLATION
WHILE LONG TERM STRUCTURE
CHANGES ARE MADE OVER THE NEXT
YEAR WE ALIGN OURSELVES WITH
COLLEAGUES IN THE EASY ECO AFTER
PRIEST WRITER RATES TO FIND
SIGNIFIED WAGES FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO SUPPORT LOCAL HEAD
START PROGRAM INCREASE FUNDING
FOR INFRASTRUCTURE YEAH AND THE
RESTORATION OF THE EARLY
LEARNING. AND CARE WORKFORCE
THAT. I AM THANK. THANK YOU FOR
MUCH CODE. ONE FIFTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MADAM AND MY IS DONNA
COLD FROM HE WORKED NEIGHBOR.
AND I AM THEIR BUSINESS FOR OUR
COUNTY BOARD THAT. WE ARE STATIC
WHAT DO YOU OF THE PROMISED
NEIGHBOR IN THE MAYBE BY. THANK
YOU EVER SO AND WE HUMBLY ASK
YOUR SUPPORT THE FUND MORE CRAIG
TO CAREER ORGANISED. THAT
EXPANDING THE NAY OF PUBLIC
NEIGHBORHOOD AN ORGAN. WHICH
HAVE PROVEN THEIR DATA
COLLECTION THE TRANSFORMATION OF
NEIGHBORHOOD. THIS BUDGET
REQUESTS THE THINGS HAVE BEEN BY
IT SIMPLY MEANS THAT BONTA THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE SIXTY
THREE WAS GOING UP. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- MY NAME IS THE SENATE
ALLEN AND WE REPRESENT SPCS AND
THE PROMISE NAY BUT COMMUNITIES
OF CHULA VISTA AND SAN DIEGO
WHAT KIND OF A THING FOR
PROMISED A LIST UNDER ISSUE
FORTY SEVEN CAMPING BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA. ARE WE
REALLY APPRECIATE. LET'S PART OF
IT EXPERIENCE IS A THAT HAS A
MAJOR IMPACT IN OUR COMMUNITY. I
THINK THE I'M DAVE IF YOU TRY
YOU AT WHO'S BEEN TO PROMISE YOU
- MODEL A HINDERING. GRADUATE
FROM SCHOOL AND GOING TO CALL
AND CAREER- THE TOP HELP THEIR
COMMUNITY THE LINES THAT. ARE
AND STRATEGY TOGETHER A COMMON
OF GOALS AND RESPONSIBLE FROM
OUR MOST CRITICAL NEED. IN THE
COMMUNITY ITSELF- WE WOULD
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU
LEGISLATORS WHO- FULLY FROM
MARKET TO CAREER ORGANIZATIONS
WHO HAVE BEEN WORKING TO MAKE
SURE CHILDREN. IN SCHOOLS AND
FAMILIES- TO MOVE OUT OF
POVERTY. FAVORITE AT THANK YOU
VERY. MUCH THANKS CALLER PLEASE
. WINDS ONE WHO'S GOING. ONE ONE
PRODUCTS CALLING THE COURT I'M
THE COMPLETE CARE ACT IN THE OF
THE MARKET FOR AGES THE
PROPRIETOR MORTGAGE JUST MORE-
UNFORTUNATELY UP THEM CLOSER I
DO JUSTICE TO BILL ON LOOK
FORWARD TO THE COULD COMING ARE
THE AGE OF FOR THE MINUTE COUPLE
AM PROVIDED THEM WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE WE
APPRECIATE THE BOND. THOUSAND WE
WILL. OFFER CONTROL WHAT MADE BY
FOOD BE ABLE TO GET. IF YOU ARE
. OF AMONG OTHER THINGS THE
MILLION- HOUSING ALMOST FIFTY
CENTER BY- I AGING FOR.
PROVIDERS THAT ARE TO INCLUSIVE
. AND THEN WE ALSO INCOME TO
COME TO LOOK ALL MODOC AND ADOPT
LOCAL OF A THREE FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS. RELATED TO THE PROGRAM
HE MET ON THE LAW I JUST AS A AS
GOOD AS POLICY. ALL WITH AND WE
ALSO HAVE THE MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THE- APPROVAL TO A- ON. THE
PHONE. OUR ONLY- BUT A BUNCH
THERE A BIT SHORT AND THE THAT
IN COLLEGE OF. MOBILE MORE
DOLLAR.
BUT FOR THE FIFTY. WALDRON FOUR
FOUR ON A JOINT PROPOSAL COLLEGE
ON THE REGULAR OF TWO HUNDRED
ONE DOLLARS THE PHONE ITSELF
EXPLICITLY FOR ANY COUNTY ONTO A
JOB CALLED THE AT THE CHILD
WELFARE SECTOR IF YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR PROBLEMS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ONE FOUR WHICH UP.
AFTER CARE ACT AND MEMBER THIS
IS PATTY HUBER FROM JUSTICE IN
EIGHT- I WANTED TO YOU FOR
SUPPORTING LIVING AND BEING ABLE
TO AGE IN PLACE AND WE ARE
DISAPPOINTED THEREFORE THAT NONE
OF THE KEY MASTER PLAN FOR AGING
STAKEHOLDER PROPOSALS HERE THE
MAY REVISION WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR TO
INVEST SIGNIFICANT ONE TIME
FUNDS TO ADVANCE KEY MASTER PLAN
FOR A JINGLE. UP FIRST WE
SUPPORT AND APPRECIATE SECOND
STEP OF THE SFI SST INCREASE AND
TO PROVIDE A ONE TIME GRANT FOR
SSI RECIPIENTS. WE SUPPORT THE
STAKEHOLDER FOR SEVEN HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR
HOUSING STABILIZATION TO PREVENT
AND END HOMELESSNESS AMONG OLDER
ADULTS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES THIS PROPOSAL
ALIGNS WITH THE SENATE BUDGET
PRIORITY OF STABILIZING HOUSING
FOR THESE POPULATIONS. AND
ALIGNS WITH THE MASTER PLAN FOR
AGING GOAL OF ENDING
HOMELESSNESS. THIRD WE SUPPORT
TWENTY MILLION DOLLAR INCREASE
FUNDING FOR THE CARE GIVING
RESOURCE CENTERS WE UNDERSTAND
THAT- FIVE HUNDRED OR SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND HAS BEEN
ALLOCATED BUT WE THINK THAT THE
TWENTY MILLION IS NEEDED TO
BRING US UP TO PRE RECESSION
LEVELS. AND FINALLY WE DO OPPOSE
THE CARE COURTS PROPOSAL- WE
HAVE SERIOUS CONCERNS AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
REGARDING THOSE CONCERNS. YOU
VERY MUCH MUCH THANKS CULPRITS.
ONE THIRTY THREE IS GOING.
AFTERNOONS AND LYFT BUT I FEAR
THAT AND WANTING TO GET ON THE
BOARD ON IT YOU'RE FORTY SEVEN
AROUND THE CHILD WELFARE
INVESTMENTS APPRECIATE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE THAT ADDS
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS YOUR TODD
WALKER THEM PARTICULARLY FOR OUR
- HE IF YOU'RE NOT. THEIR OPENER
INTERLOCAL YEAH. AND YOU KNOW WE
ARE SUPPORT WITH ON BACK MAN THE
BY THE CALL LINE HERE BRING BACK
ADDITIONAL CODE IN THAT RELIEF.
WE ARE ONLY ABLE TO SECURE 33%
OF THE REQUEST THAT WE MADE. FOR
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET THAT CAME IN
AND JUST IN MARCH OF THIS YEAR.
SO RICHARD I JUST SAW THAT
LOOKING FOR CHILDREN NOW I FIVE
PUBLISHED ANOTHER STAKEHOLDER-
THE MURDER THE JOG YOUR BRAIN.
AND WE TAKE THE MAIN. AND OF THE
DOLLARS COUNTY AND ENCOURAGE
HERE AT THE PORT. ADVOCATE FOR
QUITE AT EVEN DOLLARS ENSURE
THAT WE CAN HAVE MORE TRAINING
NAVIGATION DR- WHICH WE CAN DRAW
DOWN FEDERAL FUNDS FOR THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANKS COLOR PLEASE. WHAT
THE SIX HAVE. YES THEY ARE GOOD
AT CHAIR AND OF THE TEAM AN
EFFORT ON A CALLING BEHALF THE
STATE IN THE COMMITTEE ORGANIZED
PROPERTY AND COAST CALIFORNIA
FIRST OF ALL WE JUST WANT THINK
ABOUT FOR NOW IN THE BUDGET- MY
CARPET THERE AT THE END THE
PILOT NAVIGATOR WRAPPING UP HIS
AND LOVE HER SO YOU CAN GO WITH
THAT- WERE ALSO ASKING RELIGIOUS
. LEGISLATURE TO ENHANCE AND
IMPROVE THE CURRENT PROGRAM BY
ADOPTING A COMMUNITY BASED
APPROACH OUTLINED IN AB TWENTY
SIX EIGHTY BY ARAMBULA AND WERE
ALSO- ONE A NAME THAT THE
NAVIGATORS CURRENTLY ASSISTS
WITH MEDI CAL ENROLLMENT AND
RETENTION AND WE ASK THE
LEGISLATURE TO SUPPORT ITS KEY
EQUITY. SOME THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE FOURTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS ACT. I'M CATHY
KELLEY EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
BAY AREA CAREGIVER RESOURCE
CENTER UNDER FAMILY CAREGIVER
ALLIANCE. WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE
DISCUSSION OF WITHIN CDA AND THE
MOVE FROM- DEPARTMENT HEALTH
CARE SERVICES. OF OUR NATIONALLY
RECOGNIZED SERVICE MODEL TO
SUPPORT UNPAID FAMILY CAREGIVERS
OF ADULTS WITH DEMENTIA
PARKINSON'S STROKE ANOTHER
CONCORD BEEN PARAMOUNT. USE OUR
DECADES OF EXPERIENCE DATA ON
FAMILY CARE GIVERS AND
INTEGRATIVE USE THAT ELEGY THE
SKILLED SERVICES WE CAN HELP
BUILD A MORE EFFECTIVE AND
EFFICIENT SERVICES SUPPORT THE
CRUX OF CARE GIVER SERVICES.
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO COLOR
PLEASE. ONE SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
REBECCA GONZALEZ BUT THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKER CALIFORNIA CHAPTER WHEN I
JOINED OTHER ADVOCATES WHO- I
TALK ABOUTDIRECTING THE BUDGET
SURPLUS THE COMMUNITY TURNED OUT
IN MANY SECTORS AT THE FIVE S.
AND P. BIRTH AGAIN. WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT THE SENATE
RIGHT- INCLUDED ACCELERATING THE
INCREASE IS THE F. I. S. AS HE
GRANTS AND PROVIDING A GRANT FOR
THOSE FOR FIFTEEN- AS YOU KNOW
IN MANY COUNTIES THE GRANT WOULD
NOT COVER THE COST OF THE STUDIO
APARTMENT AND THESE RECIPIENTS
ALSO NEED TO PAY FOR UTILITIES
FOOD MEDICINE TOILETRIES
CLOTHING AND OTHER NECESSITIES.
THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN FOR ON YOUR
ADDRESS FOR THE FIFTEEN UNITY
AND WE HOPE TO SEE THIS PROPOSAL
IN THE FINAL BUDGET THANK YOU
THANK. YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. WINDS FOUR TO SPLIT UP.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS A BUT
WHAT AT FUNDING THE ASSOCIATE
REGIONAL CENTER IN YOU WE
SUBMITTED OUR COMMENTS IN
WRITING TO BE SUBCOMMITTEE
MEMBERS THAT ACTEARLIER THIS
WEEK AND I JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT FOR BOB. ROSENKRANZ
AREA FIRST I WOULD STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE FOLLOWS WORKFORCE
INVESTMENT AND IF THEY HAVE BEEN
PUTTING IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENT. BUDGET YEAH DIDN'T
. THAT WE HAVE THE AND TOOLBOX
ON ONLY TWO RECRUIT ALSO READ.
CRITICAL AND DEDICATED STAFF. AS
WE THINK ABOUT THESE ESTIMATES
WE ALSO NEED TO THINK ABOUT LONG
TERM SOLUTIONS BUT GETTING
PEOPLE IN THE DOOR IS THE
CRITICAL FIRST FACT. AND PROVIDE
THEM WITH CAREER PATHWAYS AND- A
WAY TO ENVISION OF THE SYSTEM
FONG TERM IS ESSENTIAL. SECOND
WE APPRECIATE FOR THE HE
PROPOSED EXPANSION OF EARLY
START. THE GREAT NUMBER OF
CHILDREN WE AFTER IN THE LEAST
PROGRAM AND THAT ON A POSITIVE
ABOUT. READ THE BETTER WE ALL
ARE BUT WE WOULD JUST FALL OUT
THE NEED TO THINK ABOUT HOW TO
ENHANCE PROVIDER CAPACITY OR
POPULATION GIVEN THAT IT ALREADY
STRETCHED. AND FINALLY WE HAVE
IT ALTHOUGH RELATED TO- B. S.
FAMILY PROGRAM FIX FAMILY COSTS
IF ASIAN PROBE AND BIG KNOWLEDGE
MEANT BAD REQUIRING INCOME TAX
BRING CHILDREN AND- SERVICES BUT
THEY DEFINITELY IT IS AN
IMPORTANT THING TO A BUT WE
CONTINUE THIS PROPOSAL THAT
BEING USED BOTH PROGRAMS ARE
INTACT. OKAY CAN REMAIN ON THE
VERGE THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
YOU ARE STRUGGLING WITH YOUR
CONNECTION. NAY PLEASE AND A
PROPERTY CAN YOU TELL ME HOW
MANY MORE CALLS ARE IN THE QUEUE
. I WILL POSSIBLY THIRTY THREE
CALLS LEFT IN THE QUEUE OKAY
LET'S IS AN EXTREME OKAY LET'S
TAKE A- WE'RE GONNA TAKE A BRIEF
RECESS. WE'LL BE BACK IN ABOUT
FIVE MINUTES.
OKAY COLOR- A MODERATOR HER WE
READY FOR OUR NEXT CALLER. WE
ARE READY MANAGER NEXT WEEK WHEN
THE LINE NUMBER SEVENTY FIVE ONE
SEVENTY FIVE IS GOING TO. HI
CARE EGGMAN- THANK YOU FOR
TAKING CARE OF YOURSELF THE
GREAT- MY NAME IS SEAN YOUNG
WITH BUT INSTRUCTORS PERFECT IN
THE OFFICE OF THE CAMPUS FOR
TREASURER I'M CALLING TODAY IS A
MEMBER OF THE TRUTH AND JUSTICE
CHAO FOR COALITION. COALITION
WANTED TO TAKE. THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO COMMEND OUR GOVERNANCE
PROPOSALS IMPROVE MARKETS CHILD
SUPPORT SYSTEM ENSURE THAT.
ABOUT FOUR DOLLARS GO TO WEAR
THE SHIRT OFF. ON THIS GOVERNOR
AND LEGISLATURE WILL HAPPEN MORE
THAN ANY OTHER I'M IN OUR
STATE'S HISTORY OR FAMILIES IN
CHILD. AMERICA COALITION
RESPECTFULLY URGES THE
ADMINISTRATION- AND THE
LEGISLATURE DELBONIS TRACK
RECORD I'M INSURE THAT 1100% OF
CHILD WHAT CAN THE- BILL POOREST
CHILDREN PARENTS IN OUR STATE.
WE ARE FAMILIES CURRENTLY
RECEIVING IF THIS RECAP OF
SOMATIC CAL I'M A DETAIL BAKER
TWENTY TO TWENTY BUDGET
BLUEPRINT- I ALSO WANT TO ECHO
COMMENTS MADE BY THE WESTERN
CENTER HERE. I'M IN HIGHLIGHTS
AND MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS OF CHILD SUPPORT
PAYMENTS DID NOT GO TO LOW
INCOME FAMILIES. ACCOUNT WORKS
ON THE MAJORITY OF WHOM ARE
BLACK AND BROWN. ARE EXPECTED BY
THE STATE I'M OVER. THE POP. WE
KNOW THAT THE GOVERNOR AND
LARGEST SHARE OUR COLLISION
COMMITMENT TO. RACIAL AND-
JUSTICE. ASKING THIRTY ONE
THREE. OUT WORKING WITH CITIES
FAMILIES WOULD BE TRIMS. FOR
INCOME CAN BE OF COLOR. I WOULD
HOPE THAT HE IF HE KNOWLEDGE
THAT THE LEGISLATURE. WORK
TOGETHER AGAIN YOU HOLD FOR HALF
GROUP THE ALL FAMILY EACH FOR
JUSTIN I INDIAN. BUT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY TAX COURT PLEASE. THIS IS YOUR LIFE THREE WHO'S
GOING. GOOD AFTERNOON THE
TECHNICIAN ELECTRICIAN ON THE OF
THE CALIFORNIA FOR ACTIONS BY
WHERE GOING TO APPRECIATE OF THE
A TWELVE IN THE MAIN REVISED THE
FUNDING FOR THE THING FROM THE
FAVOR HAS RESPECTFULLY URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO FUND THE BUDGET
REQUEST CAN'T GET INSIDE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA WHICH
CALLED FOR MORE COMPREHENSIVE
CORPORATE CAREER. CRADOCK THE
CAREER ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS THE
STATE THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH TAX COLOR PLEASE. EXCELLENT
NUMBER TWO ONE THESE GLORIA. YES
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
PROVIDED BY THE LAST AND ISAAC
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF SOUTHERN
CAREGIVER RESOURCE CENTERS WHAT
ONE OF THE ELEVEN CARE GIVER
RESOURCE CENTERS TOGETHER WE
COVER THE- ENTIRE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA PROVIDING SERVICES TO
FAMILY CAREGIVERS I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY.
RECORD IN STATE THAT. GARCIA
PIECE THE TRANSFER OF OUR ALMOST
FORTY YEAR OLD SUITS YOUR C.
STATE WIDE. SYSTEM OF CARE FROM
THE AGE OF FIFTY AND THEN WE
LOOK FORWARD TO COOPERATING. AND
COLLABORATING WITH CDA AND THE
TRANSFER OF THE PROGRAM. I WANT
TO SAY THAT COLLABORATION IS THE
KEY WORD TO THIS BECAUSE WE-
WANT TO WORK HAND IN HAND WITH
CDA TO ENSURE THAT THE CONTINUED
EFFECTIVENESS. AND INTEGRITY OF
OUR SYSTEM WIDE CARE- THAT HAS
HELPED THOUSANDS OF UNPAID
FAMILY CAREGIVERS FOR ALMOST
FOUR DECADES. THE MORE MAJORITY
WHICH ARE CARING FOR LOVED ONES
WITH ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE AND
RELATED DISORDERS. CONTINUE ON
AGAIN AS A UNIFIED PROGRAM
ACROSS THE STATE. TO HELP ENSURE
THE FAMILIES- YOU HAVE ACCESS TO
OUR EVIDENCE BASED. DATA DRIVEN
PROGRAMS THAT HELP THEM STAY
HEALTHY EMPLOYED AND BETTER ABLE
TO CARE FOR THEIR LOVED ONES AT
HOME NO MATTER WHERE THEY LIVE
IN OUR STATE. OUR PROGRAMS AS AS
MENTIONED IS DATA DRIVEN AND
OVER 40% OF OUR POPULATION
SERVED ARE ETHNICALLY DIVERSE
INCLUDING SOME PEOPLE LIVING IN
THE MOST MORE AND RURAL
TERRITORIES. AND OUR FAMILIES
ARE PROVIDING. ALMOST DOUBLE THE
NUMBER OF UNPAID CARE HOURS PER
WEEK THAN THE NATIONAL AVERAGE
TO SOME OF THE MOST COMPLEX
CARES AT HOME. WHICH WITHOUT OUR
ASSISTANCE WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO
DO SO AND WOULD BE A GREAT RISK
FOR NURSING HOME. PLACEMENT THIS
ONE ARE. A WEEK. THE
TRANSFERRING WE WANT TO URGE.
THAT THERE BE A GOOD COLOR. SO
THAT WE COULD YOU OUR FOR.
DECADES OF EXPERIENCE AND
EXPERTISE AS THE SYSTEM OF CARE
FOR FAMILY CAREGIVERS AND STATE.
TO CONTINUE ON OVER AT TDA AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
A DIRECTOR SUSAN TOMORROW- THERE
AS WELL AND HER TEAM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. ONE SEVENTY SEVEN
IS GOING TO. GOOD AFTERNOON CARE
EGGMAN A NUMBER. MY NAME IS
TERRIBLE THAT FALL CALLING ON
BEHALF OF YOUNG INVINCIBLES A
NATIONAL NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
THAT ADVOCATES FOR YOUNG ADULTS
IN THE POLITICAL PROCESS. I'M
CALLING TO- TO THANK THE
GOVERNOR FOR HIS MAY REVISION
WHICH ARE BOUGHT FROM
HOMELESSNESS HOWEVER THE MAY
REVISION COULD NOT INCLUDE
FUNDING FOR THE CALIFORNIA. SIX
SOUTH OPPORTUNITY AN ACADEMIC
BILLION GUARANTEED INCOME
PROGRAM FOR HIGH SCHOOL SENIORS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS. IN
CALIFORNIA FIFTEEN THOUSAND HIGH
SCHOOL SENIORS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS WHAT BADLY AND LOSE
SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES AND ACCESS
TO FOOD AND SHELTER. THE
CALIFORNIA GUARANTEED INCOME
PROGRAM WILL PROVIDE EIGHTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS. IN DIRECT AND
GUARANTEED INCOME TO FUND THE
PROGRAM AND THE LONG TERM
INVESTMENT IN THE FUTURE IF YOU
CAN THE DON'T. PROGRAM WILL
PROVIDE ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS A
MONTH FOR FIVE MONTHS I WILL BE
INTERESTS WILL BE ADMINISTERED
THEIR CDS. WE URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THE PROGRAM AND INVEST
IN THE FUTURE OF FIFTEEN
THOUSAND YOUNG CALIFORNIANS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANKS ONE EIGHTY
ONE PLEASE AHEAD. KAPANEN MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MAKING GREATER
MONEY NOW AND I AND THE
COMMUNICATIONS DIRECTOR WITH
EFFECT NEIGHBORHOODS IN CHULA
VISTA AND SAN DIEGO I'M CALLING
YOU TODAY IN STRONG FOR THE
ASSISTANCE OF FUNDING FOR
PROMISE NEIGHBORHOODS UNDER
FORTY IF YOU FORTY SEVEN TODAY.
WE GREATLY APPRECIATE THE
INCLUSION OF THE TWELVE MILLION
THE FUNDING FIFTEEN FROM A FAVOR
HEADS AND WE RESPECTFULLY URGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO FULLY FUND
MORE CRADLE TO CAREER
ORGANIZATIONS WHO HAVE BEEN
WORKING TO MAKE SURE CHILDREN
SUCCEED IN SCHOOL AND FAMILIES
CAN MOVE OUT OF POVERTY. THIS IS
CURRENTLY A BUDGET REQUEST CAMP
INVITE ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA WE
HAVE WE HAVE DATA THAT PROVES
THAT FUNDING LIKE THIS CAN DO
FOR NEIGHBORHOOD AND NOW MORE
THAN EVER WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT OUR NEIGHBORHOODS AND
CREATE EVEN MORE OPPORTUNITIES.
IN THE IN THE STATE I MEAN WILL
ENSURE FAMILIES WITH THE
RESOURCES THEY. NEED TO THRIVE
THROUGHOUT. YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT
AND HEARING TODAY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH TO COURT PLEASE.
THANKS TO EIGHTY THREE FOR GOING
TO. MADAM CHAIRMAN BOB LANE WITH
THE K. COUNCIL- COMMUNITY BE
HEALTH AGENCY WERE HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S NAME
REVISION INVESTMENT IN CONTENT
AND ARE GRATEFUL FOR THE ISSUES
PRESENTED TODAY BUT WE'RE
WAITING TO SEE THE FINAL TRAILER
BILL AND FRIENDS IN GENERAL WE
WOULD LIKE TO DRAW YOUR
ATTENTION TO THE LACK OF FUNDING
INCLUDING INCLUDED FOR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT FOR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. WHILE WE ARE
PLANNING AT THE STATE THE END OF
THE PANDEMIC OUR PROVIDERS ARE
STILL SUFFERING FROM A WORKFORCE
CRISIS OUR MEMBERS. OF THE
DEMAND IN OUR- AND ABOUT IN
AREAS RELATED TO. INCREASE RATE
OR QUESTIONS. IN PEOPLE AGREED.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
TAX CODE PLEASE. ONE SEVENTY SO
IS GOING UP. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS ALISA PATTEN AND I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF EAST BAY
FAMILY DEFENDERS WERE IN OAKLAND
BASED LEGAL SERVICES NONPROFIT
WORKING TO KEEP FAMILIES
TOGETHER AND MINIMIZE THE TIME
CHILDREN SPEND IN FOSTER CARE.
I'M HERE TODAY TO SAY THAT
POVERTY SHOULDN'T BE A DIRECT
LINE TO LOSING YOUR KIDS IF THEY
FAMILY DEFENDER STAND FIRMLY
AGAINST ALL POLICIES THAT LEAD
FAMILIES LIVING IN POVERTY BEING
SEPARATED DUE. TO REFERRAL TO
THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM. AT THE
DEATH. IMPACT FAMILIES OF COLOR
BLACK FAMILIES HAVE A HIGHER
PROBABILITY OF SURVEILLANCE
CONTACT WITH MANDATED REPORTERS
CHANCE OF INVESTIGATION THE FLAG
CHANCE OF BEING LABELED AS
ABUSIVE OR NEGLECTFUL WANTS AN
INVESTIGATION OPENED LAST CHANCE
INFORMAL SERVICES BEING OFFERED
AT A HIGHER PROBABILITY OF
FAMILY SEPARATION EITHER
TEMPORARY OR PERMANENT. WE ARE
ASKING THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR TO PROVIDE FUNDING FOR
EXPERIENCED NONPROFIT LEGAL
SERVICE ORGANIZATIONS THAT CAN
PROVIDE PREVENTIVE LEGAL
SERVICES FOR THE FAMILY TO
ENSURE THEY ARE INFORMED OF
THEIR IMPORTANT RIGHT THE FAMILY
UNITY AND TO ADDRESS THE ISSUES
WHICH HAS LED THEM INTO CONTACT
WITH CHILD WELFARE. BY
PREVENTING ENTRY INTO THE FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM WITH ITS ATTENDANT
FROM FAMILY SEPARATIONS WE CAN
SUPPORT LOW INCOME FAMILIES TO
REMAIN STRONG AND INTACT WHICH
IN TURN PROMOTES HEALTHY AND
VIBRANT COMMUNITY. ADDITIONALLY
WE ARE ASKING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE STOP THE REFEREEING
OF TEL WORKING FAMILIES TO THE
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM YOU TO
FINANCIAL NEGLECT. THAT
LEGISLATURE PROVIDE FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE TO THE FAMILY THROUGH
THE FAMILY STABILIZATION PROGRAM. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
COURT. ONE SIXTY NINE WHO'S
GOING. THAT AFTERNOON- CHAU
NUMBERS COST FOR SANTOS POPS OUT
TO GO FORTH WITH FEDERAL
AUTHORITIES BERSERKER
LEGISLATION ABOUT THE FOOD FOR
ALL PROPOSAL OUR EXPENSE THE
FACT THAT AFFECTS ALL
CALIFORNIANS REGARDLESS OF THE-
PRICE ON THE CREATION STATUS
ADDITIONALLY WESTERN CENTER
STANDS FOR MILLIONS PROPERTIES
LISA FROM INSPIRATION TO BEING
REFERRED TO THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM SO THEY WERE ASKING ABOUT
THE STATE OF PROVIDE FUNDING FOR
EXPERIENCE NOT PROFIT PEOPLE.
SERVICE PRESERVATION. OPEN FOR
THINK PETITIONS SERVICES TO THE
PHARMACY CAL. BOB BAKKEN
DESERVED STOPPER FOR. ARE TOWER
. ARE DUE TO FINE ACTUALLY
COLLECTED A ALSO SYSTEM BUT
SHOULD FOR SO TO THE FROM. THE
FROM THE STATE. PROGRAM IF
LEGISLATURE OF ON TO OUR FUNDING
. FOR THESE TWO ARE THIS YEAR
WELL THAT'S TO. OUR DAILY- TO
FOR TO RUN THEY TRY OPTIONS. FOR
PREVENTION- PREVENTING THESE.
FOR INFECTIONS BUDGET THANK YOU
MONSTER THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
COURT PLEASE. NOT IN LINE NUMBER
A FIVE. SCHOOL. TO ONE EIGHTY
FIVE YOU MIGHT BE NEEDED THIS
WILL HAVE. HEY HEARING BECAUSE
YOUR YOUR LEFT PLEASE. YES ERIC
PAIN EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CENTRAL VALLEY URBAN INSTITUTE-
AND WE'D LIKE TO THANK THE
GOVERNMENT FOR INCLUDING
NAVIGATORS ENOUGH BUDGET- BUT WE
ASK THAT THE LEGISLATOR TO
ENHANCE AND IMPROVE THE CURRENT
PROGRAM BY ADOPTING THE
COMMUNITY BASED APPROACH
OUTLINED IN AB TWENTY SIX
EIGHTEEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER RANDY
GROUP BILL- BECAUSE WE BELIEVE
NAVIGATORS AT THAT'S WHAT
MATTERS HELLO MOM AND RETENTION
AND WE AFTER LEGISLATIVE
SUPPORT. HEALTH EQUITY ON RACIAL
JUSTICE PRIORITY. IN ADDITION
TO- WE NOT THE AN ALLOCATE AND
FOR THE HEALTH AND RACIAL
JUSTICE BUT FIND AND WE WOULD
JUST ASK PHONE SUPPORT FROM THE
LEGISLATOR- AT THIS- FBOS IN THE
RECOVERY EFFORTS THE KOBE NINE.
A THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANKS FOR PLEASE
. ONE EIGHTY SIX WHO'S GOING TO. HI ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION WITH
THEM FIRMLY AGAINST POLICIES
THAT LEAD FAMILIES TO BEING
SEPARATED DUE TO BEING REFERRED
TO THE FAMILY REGULATION SYSTEM
AFTER THE LEGISLATURE PROVIDE
FUNDING FOR EXPERIENCE NONPROFIT
LEGAL SERVICE ORGANIZATION WE
CAN PROVIDE CREE PUT REPEATED
JANET LEGAL DIRECTOR FOR THE
FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA. BROUGH
AFTER THE LEGISLATURE STOP
REFERRING OF POWER WORKING-FAMILIES TO CHILD WELFARE DUE TO
FINANCIAL CLASS AND PROVIDE
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE TO THE
FAMILY FOR THE FAMILY THE
LOCATION GRAHAM ADDITIONALLY
WITH THE CREATION OF A PILOT
PROGRAM FOR AND HOW HOUSING AND
SECURE CURRENT AND FORMER FEC
RECORDS INCLUDE CONNECTIONS TO
CULTURALLY. COMPETENT FOR. WELL
HOW AND HOW WITH THE ISSUE
ACROSS CALIFORNIA KERN AND
FORMER WORKER HAVE BEEN
SPECIALLY HIGH RATE OF HIGH. BUT
ABOUT HOW OF THE IN THE FACT
TRADERS EXPERIENCED HOME AND
FORTY PER OF. FACT BUT- HAVING
BEEN IN ACCESS TO SHOP THERE.
HOUSING IF FOR CONNECTING TO
NEEDED FOR AND THEN HEALTH AND
OTHER SERVICE. AND IS A VIOLENT
PREVENTION MEASURE. THAT RECORD
OF TO BE HEALTHIER SAFE AND
HOUSING NOTHING OUR INSURING
THAT BECOME EVERY OUT THE YOU
THE YOU VERY MUCH TAX COURT
PLEASE. FIND YEAH. DEFINITELY
MADAM FINALLY WHAT NOT WORKERS
AND NOTHING LOCAL THIRTY NINE
THIRTY ONE OF EXPRESSED HER
SUPPORT FOR ISSUE NUMBER FORTY
CLEAN THE ICE THAT MINIMUM WAGE
DOESN'T WELCOME TO FOR THE
ONGOING FUNDS WITHOUT. BACK UP
TO FIVE IT'S SOMETHING WE OFFER
OFFICIATE EIGHTY HOUR LIMIT
EXEMPTION ONE HUNDRED SIXTY
DOLLARS FOR THE MOST SEVERE
CASES WE ALSO WANT TO EXPRESS
OUR OPPOSITION ISSUE NUMBER
FORTY FIVE THE PROPOSAL I FELT
COMPLETED TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
LANGUAGE WOULD REVEAL NUMEROUS
LONG STANDING PRECEDENT UNDER
WHICH PUBLIC ENTITIES THAT
FUNDING MINISTER THE PROGRAM ALL
RECOGNIZE THAT YOUR EMPLOYER
THAT PROVIDED UNDER THE STATUTE.
CHANGE WOULD BE DETRIMENTAL TO
THE PROGRAM AS A WHOLE AND WHY
WE'RE HOSTING THE ITEM LASTLY WE
LIKED UP WITH NO WORK FOR THE
FOLLOWING PROPOSALS THAT WERE
NOT IN A REVISION AFTER THE LAST
WEEK RELIEF- BOOK TWENTY WITH
THAT YEAH YOU AND YOU DIRTY
EIGHT WHICH WERE PROVIDED TO
DOLLARS DIFFERENTIAL FOR ISIS
PROVIDERS CARING FOR RECIPIENTS
EMERGENCIES. AMONG OTHER
PROVISIONS. POST CLOSING THE GAP
IN UNION ACCESS TO NEW EMPLOYEE
FOR ASIAN ARE. A TO SITE AND IN
PERSON OR ANYTHING. TO PROVIDE.
THEY ARE IMPROVE THE SERVICE
PROGRAM ISIS. WE PROPOSED POINT
FOUR MILLION WITH THAT YEAH YOU
TO ALLOW BY AUTOMATICALLY DEDUCT
. TAX CONTRIBUTIONS THE DIVERSE
AND LASTLY WORK SUPPORT BY
WORKERS TAX RATE THAT WOULD
ALLOW PUBLIC AND PRIVATE. WERE
AND UNION DO TO BE L. FOR A
REFUND TAX CREDIT EQUAL TO.
PERCENT OF UNION DO PAID UP THE
HUNDRED FIFTY TO. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR THANK YOU VERY MUCH NO
COLORFUL. ONE SEVENTY ONE PLEASE
GO. SO YOU'RE A MEMBER OF MANY
ACCEPTED ON FAITH ON BEHALF OF
BOTH THE CORPORATION FOR PART OF
HOUSING AND HOUSING CALIFORNIA
WE WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
SENATE FOR PRIORITIZING THE
NEEDS FOR SENIORS AND ADULTS
WITH DISABILITIES AND FOR THE
PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE
STABILIZATION AND PRESERVATION
OF HOUSING OPTIONS. FOR AT RISK
SENIORS AND PEOPLE WITH THE
FACILITY WE FURTHER RECOMMEND
FUNDING A TARGETED PROGRAM TO
PREVENT AND END HOMELESSNESS
AMONG OLDER ADULTS AND PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES FOR A ONE TIME
BUDGET REQUIRED FOR SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION OVER FOUR
YEARS THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL WILL
IMPLEMENT EFFECTIVE MODEL FOR
IDENTIFYING PEOPLE AT RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS. AND WALDRON BOTH
AND PROVIDING HOUSING CITIES
THAT ALLOW PEOPLE TO REMAIN IN
THEIR OWN INDEPENDENT HEALTH WE
EXPECT THE PROPOSAL TO PREVENT
AND END HOMELESSNESS FOR ABOUT.
FIFTEEN THOUSAND HOMELESS
CALIFORNIANS. I CAN'T REALLY
READ. OPPOSE CARE FOR PROPOSED-
WE HAVE NO THAT THAT FOR BUDGET
FOR IS INTENDED ADDRESS AND LEFT
AND THAT. HELPING BURKE WITH A
CERTAIN COMMUNITY TREATMENT.
EIGHT LAWS. THANK YOUNG. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH COURT. LINE FORTY
IT'S GOING. I COULD HAVE MEMBERS
THIS IS STEVE FROM BAY AREA OF
LEGAL AID- CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
THE SENATE VERSION OF THE BUDGET
WITH THE CALORIE INCREASES PRESS
A SCIENTIST BE GRANTED TO
PROVIDE STIMULUS FOR A FIVE. IBM
AND- CAL WORKS GRANT THE
DIFFERENTIAL THAT WE USE MORE OF
A BUDGET SURPLUS THE SPORT
INDIVIDUAL COMMUNITIES WERE MOST
IN NEED- I'VE ALSO- URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT- S. B. THIRTEEN HUNDRED
AN ASSOCIATIVE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE FOR STRENGTHENING
EFFORTS BY FOSTER YOUTH.
INCREASING ACCESS TESTIFIED FOR
FOSTER YOUTH INCLUDING NON MINOR
DEPENDENTS AND HELPING THEM TO
TRANSITION FROM FOSTER CARE AT
THE SITE- JUST PROVEN TO HELP TO
REDUCE. HOMELESSNESS AND- REDUCE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
INVOLVEMENT HAS NOT FELT. I ALSO
SUPPORT- PRIOR COMMENTS IN
SUPPORT OF ALL THE FOOD FOR ALL
PROGRAM. AND THE CONCERNS RAISED
ABOUT THE CHARACTER PROPOSAL AND
COURAGE YOU INSTEAD INVEST IN.
SERVICES AND PROGRAMS FOR PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
. LINE FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
. BOB JOHNSON ON NAME'S KATIE
CRUEL I'M WITH THE OFFICE ON
CAMPBELL CIRCLE BALBI FOR EVEN
TO COUNTY. WHERE THIRTY MILLION
SEEING DISABLED ABOUT AND
MILITARY VETERANS FOR NINETEEN
THE- I'M CALLING TO SUPPORT AB
TWO FIFTY ONE BIG WEST OF SIXTY
FOUR POINT ONE MILLION IN ONE
TIME STATE FINDING TO CREATE THE
BRIDGE THE PROPERTY FOR THE L.
THIS PROCESS AS QUICKLY TO
MITIGATION THAT'D BE LESS CRIME
PROGRAM. NOT DEFINED INC WILL
OUR MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
WHO HAVE CORPORATE COOLS
ENVIRONMENT WITH URGENTLY NEEDED
SAFETY UPGRADES THE VISION
COLLATION SYSTEM AND
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING WILL HELP
OF THREE COLTON FORTY IN DOING
THAT WELL NEXT OFTEN SHORTAGE
ARE WITH YOUR WAIT STAFF IN
NORTH THE THERAPIST DRIVER AIDS
HE'S DOWN THE LIGHTS DURING
SUNDAY MAKE CARING FOR HUNDREDS
OF THE LATEST WILL. THE THERE.
I'LL BE DELIVERED MEALS SEVENTY
K. TO KEEP SO WE SUPPORT SAFE
ALL THE STORIES FOR OUR SENIORS
AND I THINK THAT WAGES FOR ARE
ACTUALLY STAFF AND VALUATIONS
ARE STUFF THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT PLEASE
. LINE EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR SEAN THE
MEAL WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY ASSOCIATION OR COUNTY
CA WHO REPRESENTS THE TWENTY
THREE COMMUNITY CHOICE
AGGREGATORS SERVING THE
ELECTRICITY NEEDS OF OVER ELEVEN
MILLION CALIFORNIANS IN OVER TWO
HUNDRED CITIES AND COUNTIES- WE
ARE CALLING IN ON- ITEM FIFTY
TWO- WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE ONE
POINT TWO BILLION PROPOSED BY
THE GOVERNOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
RELIGIOUS PAYMENT PLAN PROGRAM-
THAT WAS INITIALLY ESTABLISHED
IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET AND-
REALLY PUSHED BY THIS BY THE
SENATE WE THANK YOU FOR THAT- AS
YOU KNOW THIS FUNDING IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TO HELPING
THOSE WHO WERE FINANCIALLY
IMPACTED BY THE PANDEMIC. AND
UNABLE TO PAY THEIR UTILITY
BILLS- AS NOTED BY THE L. A. L.
DISCOUNT PROGRAM WAS INCREDIBLY
SUCCESSFUL LAST YEAR WITH MONEY
GOING OUT THE DOOR NOT ONLY
EFFICIENTLY BUT ACCURATELY- AND
WE WANT TO APPLAUD THE WORK-
FEAST IN STAFF OVER THERE FOR A
FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS ONE ISSUE
WE WOULD LIKE TO RAISE WHILE THE
STRONG SUPPORT. THE PROPOSAL-
UNLIKE LAST YEAR'S THIS PROPOSAL
DOES HAVE SOME TAX IMPLICATIONS
FOR THE REPAIR DUE TO THIRTY-
THE FUNDS BEING USED- THAT COULD
HAVE SOME UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES AND WE HOPE THAT
THIS ISSUE IS RESOLVED AS THE
BUDGET NEGOTIATIONS CONTINUE
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY. MUCH
DISCOUNT PLEASE. LINE FIFTY
PLEASE GO TO. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND THEN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS DR
MILAN THE WESLEY WITH HEALTH
CARE REFORM TENER WE SERVE OVER
FIFTY SOLD FIFTY THOUSAND
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES IN
NORTHERN LOS ANGELES AND SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY THANK THE
GOVERNOR FOR THE BEST THAT'S
LISTED IN THE- FEW NUMBER. HOW
ARE HOWEVER WITH THE OF OUR- IN
THE NAY. DURING THE I THINK HOW
CAN WORKFORCE FOR. CURRENT
PROVIDER REIMBURSEMENT RATES ARE
BASED ON TWENTY EIGHTEEN
REGIONAL MARKET RATE OPERATE
HEALTHCARE PROGRAM. IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THE MINIMUM WAGE IN
CALIFORNIA WAS ELEVEN DOLLARS
PER HOUR. AND TWENTY ONE VIEW
THE MINIMUM WAGE IN CALIFORNIA
IT'S FIFTEEN DOLLARS PER HOUR
THAT IS A 27% INCREASE FOR THE
COST OF WORKERS' SALARIES. SINCE
THE REGIONAL MARKET SURVEY WE
OUT ALL THAT WERE IMPACTED THE
NAY REVISION HER. NOT. IF YOU
NOW. WHAT INCREASE OF 30% TO PAY
OUT THAT. AND WE SEE THIS ONE-
THROUGHOUT THE- AND WITH THAT
SAID WE HAVE THE TWO WORK FOR ON
BATTLING WITH HE AND THEY'RE
HIGHLY AND EDUCATED WORKFORCE
FELL IT HINDERS THEIR ABILITY
RETAIN THAT WORK FOR AND WE NEED
TO WORK FOR ACTUALLY TAKING MORE
AND ORDER AT INDUSTRY SUCH AS AN
OUT WHERE THEY'RE ACTUALLY
GETTING FINE AND FINING BONUSES-
AND MAKING AS MUCH AS- SEVENTEEN
TO EIGHTEEN FIFTY TWO DOLLARS AN
HOUR BUT WE ASK FOR- INCREASES
IN RATE IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE
THE ENTIRE CAMPUS. IF THE PHONE
. THIRTY WORK DURING THE- DEATH
OF THE CHILD WORK FOR THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. ONE EIGHTY FOUR THE
SCHOOL. HI GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS DANIEL CONSTRUCTS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION FOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS YEAH
FIVE FOUR EIGHT WE'RE IF I
DESERVE THE RIGHT BURKE THAT
SERVES THE MEMBERS THE SITUATION
FOR CALIFORNIANS AND SEVEN
CENTERS. WE ARE CALLING PORTS OF
THIS THE- YOU MAY REVISION
CARDIO ARE AND SPECIFICALLY THE
- A REVISION INCLUDING TEN
MILLION ONCE A FEDERAL FUNDING-
FORD COMMUNITY- THIS WOULD BE OF
GREAT BENEFIT TO- ARE CONSUMERS
WHO ARE. INTERESTING FOR NURSING
HOMES INTENDING TIRES THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TAX COLOR
PLEASE. LINE SEVENTY NINE IS
GOING UP. GOOD AFTERNOON AND
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ACT
ALTHOUGH WITH THE CALIFORNIA BE
REPAIRED WE WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
AND APPRECIATE THE THIRTEENTH
PLAN FAR PROPOSAL IN THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY TENTH BUDGET-
BURKE HEALTH FOOD BUT WERE
DISAPPOINTED THAT NO ADDITIONAL
**** WITH PROPOSED IN THE
REVISED. ARE WE ARE WITH A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY THIRD IN THE
BUDGET FOR HEALTH FOOD REFLECT
THE SITUATION THE BANK THERE
YESTERDAY I'M CURRENTLY 20% OF
CALIFORNIANS ARE STILL FOOD
INSECURE IT'S BEEN RISING SINCE
JANUARY I THINK THEY'RE
RECEIVING LESS BROAD SUPPORT.
ALL YOU HAVE TO BE LOOKING AT
LOSING THEIR EMERGENCY
ALLOTMENTS WANTS THE FEDERAL
PUBLIC THE END AT THE TOP ALL OF
THAT ARE AND WE'RE SEEING A FOR
PROFIT IT WOULD REALLY IMPACTING
THREE BANKS AS WELL AS
INDIVIDUALS. THE FACT BY
CREATING.
PRESS THREE FISH TO. THE SENATE
BUDGET SAND INCLUDES AND A
HUNDRED EMAIL THE ONE TIME FIND
OUT IN. THANKS AND WHILE AS
MAKING I FEEL FOR. I'M FINE I
JUST WANTED TO AFTER COMMENTS BY
TALKING FOUNDER LAYING BACK ON
FROM THE BUTTE EVERYDAY AND THE
NEED TO ENSURE THAT OUR NEEDS
ARE PROPERLY RESOURCE SO THAT
THEY CAN CONTINUE TRANSFER
ACCESS TO CRITICAL THINKING THAT
LIKE RUSHED. YEAH FROM THE WEST
FEDERAL ONE PROPERTY FOR THE
NEED TO. WITH THE FAT PROGRAMS.
REGARDLESS OUT AT ALL AGES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO THAT THANK YOU
VERY. FOR PLATE. MY MOTHER
SEVENTY. PLEASE GO TO. COULD NOT
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS JIM
ROBERTS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC
AUTHORITY FOR ARE YOU JUST NOT.
REGARDING THE H. OF THE-
PROVIDER SYSTEM WE HAVE THE
INCREASE OF UP TO A HUNDRED
SIXTY HOURS FOR RECIPIENTS TO
ACCESS. THE BACKUP PROVIDER
SYSTEM AND FOR PUSHING UP THE
IMPLEMENTATION DATE TO OCTOBER
WE HAVE TO LOOK FORWARD TO
REVIEWING THE FED TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH TAX
COURT PLEASE. ONE EIGHTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M SURE
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS JORDAN LINDSEY
WITH THE TO CALIFORNIA IN THE
NOTICEABLE PALSY CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATION- ONE AND MAKE YOU
COMMENTS WE APPRECIATE AND
SUPPORT REVISED PROPOSALS TO
EXPAND EARLY START ELIGIBILITY
AND THE PROPOSAL SERVICES SYSTEM
AS WELL. THE BILL IN THE POLISH
REMOVES BOARDS HOWEVER WE WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT A CONCERN TO RESUME
WITH THE- ELIZABETH. ABOUT THE
PURPOSE OF THE STARTING JAN ONE.
WIRE WE GO TO. FEASIBLE OUR
FAMILY ON OUR CHEN FUND HAS
OBVIOUSLY BEEN DOING JUST FINE
WITHOUT THOSE FEES THESE FEES
ARE ABSOLUTELY A ROADBLOCK
SERVICES FOR SOME DAMAGE AND I
HIGHLY ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEE.
TO RETHINK THE PROPOSAL. IN
REGARDS THE MINISTRATIONS
PROPOSAL ON WORK FOR STABILITY
WHICH IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
FOR THE BALLOT SERVICES SYSTEM
RIGHT NOW I WILL MAKE COMMENTS
REPRESENTING THE LAN OF A
COALITION. WHILE THE PROPOSALS
FOR. IT THEY DON'T GO NEARLY
ENOUGH TO SOLVE OR STOPPING. THE
ROOT CAUSE OF THE DISABILITY
STATEN CRISIS IS HAVING
COMPETITIVE WAGES WITHIN THE
LARBRE LARGER LABOR FORCE MARKET
PLACE. THE DBS RATE STUDY
IDENTIFIED WHAT THOSE WAGES
COULD BE BUT WE ARE FAR AWAY
FROM THOSE GRADES AND IN THIS
KIND OF SURPLUS WE ARE STILL
JUST ADVOCATE. IT BUT WHEN I'M
IN COLLEGE- INSTEAD- PROPOSES
THE FOLLOWING PROPOSALS TO SOLVE
THE STAFFING CRISIS ONE HIRE
MORE DIRECT SUPPORT PROFESSIONAL
BY ACCELERATING THE
IMPLEMENTATION IMPLEMENTATION.
OF THE GST RATE MODELS ENSURE
THOSE MODELS ARE UPDATED EVERY
THREE YEARS TO CREATE A
SUSTAINABLE SYSTEM THIS WAS
INCLUDED IN THE SENATE'S. BUDGET
PRIORITIES THANK YOU AGAIN.
NUMBER TWO HIRE MORE REGIONAL
CENTER SERVICE COORDINATORS BY
FIXING THE OUTDATED CORE
STAFFING FORMULA. WE HOPE THAT
IS INCLUDED AS WELL IN THE FINAL
BUDGET. ATIONS IMMEDIATE
STRATEGY THIS IS A MEDIA
STRATEGY TO ADDRESS THE
WORKFORCE CRISIS AND WE BELIEVE
EIGHT OR ADEQUATE STRATEGY BUT-
WE ALSO DO SUPPORT THOSE IN THE
NAY REVISED- FINALLY ON BEHALF
OF THE ART. QUESTIONS TODAY ON
ACCELERATING THE AS A SIGN THAT
SAYS PM CRACKS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIX
CORE PLEASE. ONE EIGHTY NINE
PLEASE GOING UP. HELLO THIS IS
KEVIN COSTA FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA WE
CALL ON THE PORT OF FULLY
FUNDING PROMISED NEIGHBORHOODS
AND CRADLE TO CAREER NETWORK AND
WE'D ALSO LIKE TO SEE AN
INCREASE AND HELP WORK GRANT AT
A LEVEL THAT KEEPS ALL FAMILIES
OUT OF THE PROPERTY THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TAX COURT
PLEASE. ONE NINETY ONE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON LAUGHTER THANK
YOU FOR SPENDING SO MUCH TIME
LISTENING TO OUR COMMON YOU
PEOPLE FOR THE JEWISH FAMILY
SERVICE LOS ANGELES AND I WANNA.
YOUR CALL PLEASE COMMENT. YEAH
FIVE THEY LINE MOST INCLUDING
EXTERNAL THE ACCELERATE YEAH I
AM HE GRANT INCREASE INCREASE
AND CAL WORKS AT THE ALSO WANT
TO OUT THE DID NOT INVENT THE
DISH FUNDING INTO YOUR MEALS
MAKING THAT MIGHT BE. NEXT PRICE
DEFLATOR THE YEAR MENDOZA DROP
OFF THERE ARE MANY WITH AND WE
APPRECIATE SENATE LEADERSHIP AND
TAKING OF THOSE. MUCH PLEASE.
WHY NINETY THREE IS GOING TO.
MADAM CHAIR. ROBERT HARRIS I'M
BEHALF BESSIE I YOU FELT. WELL
WE'D LIKE TO REALLY COMMAND LIVE
ARMY THANK YOU OUTSIDE THE BOX
IN TERMS OF. STRATEGY CURRENT
FOR THE BILL THE BILL LIKE THIS
SITE AND IN TURN FOR WORKERS.
AND THE TUITION. PROGRAM WE HAVE
SOME OF THE SAME QUESTIONS AND
THAT'S THE L. A. L. A. AND ON
TOP. OF THAT WE THINK THAT WE
WOULD LOOK AT THESE AS ADDITIVE.
IT IT TO THE MAIN SOLUTIONS TO
THE PROBLEM WHAT YOU'RE LOOKING
CORD- SEND A BRADFORD SOUTH.
CHAMPIONED ACCELERATION OF THE A
B. IT'S- A BIT PARDON ME I'M
SORRY OF THE FOURTH HAPPENED FOR
ME AND ALSO THIS IS NOT A BUDGET
BLUEPRINT FOR THE ACCELERATION
OF THE RATE STUDY WE WOULD ALSO
LIKE MATTHEW BARNEY FOR THE
INNOVATIVE I WENT WORKING MORE
REMOTE SUPPORTS HELLO. BURKE
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR EXCELLO THE
EARLY START ELIGIBLE. AND THE
FINANCIAL SERVICES FOR SELF
DETERMINATION PROGRAMS THAT HELP
PEOPLE GET SERVICES AND FINALLY
OR WE WOULD LIKE MEN OR OF
GETTING RID OF IT YOU HAVE A
BILLING YEAH. THAT'S IT. BUT YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. ONE SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HER MOTHER ROBERT
CROWFOOT ALL RIGHT I'M GOING TO
A GOOD CALL BACK BY WHICH IS
BASED IN SACRAMENTO. RIGHT IS A
RENTAL PEOPLE ON IT OR THE RAMPS
AT YOU TO PLEASE. OF WOULD NOT.
SO THE POST REPORTS. I WANT
REYES SITES IF THIS AMOUNT. IN.
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. I SIX
HUNDRED DOLLAR GROSS. IT ALSO
CAN YOU HAVE SOME FUN FOR HOW
FOR THE HOMELESS POPULATION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE SIXTEEN
IT'S GOING TO. HI CAN YOU HEAR
ME WE CAN'T PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU THANK YOU AGAIN MADAM
CHAIR- MY NAME IS SOMETHING I
REALIZED I AND THAT PARENT
PARTNER COORDINATOR HERE WITH
PARENTS ANONYMOUS I'M ALSO
LIKING THAT NATIVE AMERICAN
MOTHER OF STABBING. AND ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT I WANT TO SHARE
IT THAT THE ALPINE PARENTS
ANONYMOUS HOT LINE SAVE MY SON'S
LIFE AND WENT BACK. ITEM BABY IN
IT URGING THAT YOU CONTINUE ON
THE FINDING OF FOUR POINT EIGHT
MILLION PER YEAR FOR THE NEXT
THREE YEARS- WE HAVE I KNOW
HUNDREDS AND PERRANCE. SAID IN A
LETTER ON HOW IMPORTANT IT IS TO
THEM AND THEIR FAMILIES. HELP
LINE IS STILL RIGHT OKAY EVERY
ONE AND APPARENTLY ROLE CHILDREN
AND YOUTH OF ALL AGES WHERE THEY
CAN BE. FREE EMOTIONAL SUPPORT.
SEVEN DAYS OF. ESPECIALLY IN THE
WHEN YEAH HEY AND WE'RE FOR LEFT
OUT THERE AND I THINK HE HAD THE
HEARING AND ASKED- A MOTHER WITH
CHILDREN THAT HAVE NEEDS AND
NEEDED THE SUPPORT IS FINDING IT
SO IMPORTANT AND WE NEEDED TO
CONTINUE I AM EIGHT. OUR
CHILDREN FLIGHT PATTERN AND ANY
WORKING IF THEY. GET THIS KIND
SUPPORT- SORRY I GOT A LITTLE
EMOTIONAL THERE IT IS VERY
IMPORTANT AND THERE'S NO OTHER
WORDS THAT I CAN PUT OUT THERE
OTHER THAN LEAD I AM BEGGING YOU
CAN CAN YOU DEFINING FOR PARENTS
ANONYMOUS HELPLINE THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT.
OR PLEASE. LINE NINETY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE MOMENT. ONE
THIRTY NINETY SIX. THANK YOU ARE
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE ELECTED
MISS ACCEPTED RECORDS CENTRAL
VALLEY IMMIGRANT AGGRESSION
COLLABORATIVE BASIC FRESNO
PUBLIC SERVICE IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES IN ALL EIGHT COUNTIES
IN THE TOKEN VALLEY I'M CALLING
TO DRAW YOUR ATTENTION TO THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT JUSTICE
FELLOWSHIP. AN ITEM ON PAGE
EIGHTEEN OF THE AGENDA WORK
PLEASE DROUGHT THE GOVERNOR TOLD
AT THAT POINT FOR NEARLY GENERAL
FUND ONE TIME INVESTMENT IN BOTH
TWENTY TWENTY TWO ONE POINT.
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. TWENTY
FOUR. BOB THE STATE'S ONLY OF
WHAT WE REQUEST THAT SO ASKING
FOR A TOTAL THREE MILLION
DOLLARS BOND WOULD. US TO TWO
VERY THINGS ONE IS TO PUT I'M
NOT YEAR TO VOTE WHO LEGAL
FELLOWS THAT WERE RECRUITED
TRAINED AND THEN ASSIGNED TO
CENTRAL VALLEY AND CENTRAL COAST
IMMIGRANT NONPROFIT. INITIALIZER
PROVIDERS. IT WOULD ALSO ALLOW
US TO RECRUIT TRAIN AND DEPLOY
OUR SECOND COHORT OF FELLOWS
BURKE WOULD BE DIFFERENT ALSO
THROUGH ORGANIZATIONS IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND CENTRAL
COAST. REGION'S OF CALIFORNIA WE
VERY LIMITED RESOURCES TO SERVE
IN THE CURRENT FAMILIES IN THE
CENTER BY THE- THERE ARE OVER
NINE THOUSAND IMMIGRANTS. IT IS
A CONSERVE OUR POPULATION. IN
THIS MARKET PRESIDENT OF THE
MIDDLE DOLLARS WE KNOW IT'S
MAKING A DIFFERENCE RIGHT NOW
AND WILL CONTINUE TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE IF IT HAS BEEN
PRESIDENT OF THE APPROPRIATE
LEVEL OF THIRTY ONE DOLLARS. TO
ONCE AGAIN SUPPORT AFTER YOU'RE
A CRITICAL WORK RECRUIT TRAIN A
SECOND COHORT OF REBUTTALS THANK
YOU MUCH FOR YOUR ATTENTION AND
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH TAX CUTS. MAYBE FOR FISCAL
AHEAD OF. THE NATURE MINIMUM
JERRY KALRA NEAREST AND COMING
IN SUPPORT OF PEOPLE BOTH OF
THEM ARE NOT IN IN THE REVIVE ON
CHILD CARE NEEDS AND HOW FAST
AND ONE AGAIN THANK FULLER JUST
ADMIN FOR THE INVEST IN LAST
YEAR'S BUT THE SERVICE. A STATE
REIMBURSEMENT FROM SIR IN CHILD
CARE BUT WITH HIGH INFLATION THE
COST OF FOOD OR MORE THAN TEN
FOR OVER THE PAST YEAR CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS. SO HOW. ARE WE-
COMMITTEE THE BUILDING LAST
YEAR'S ABOUT BY FOR. FREE MEALS
TO ALL THREE SCHOOL LUNCH CARE
AT STATE IS NOW. TO FOR ALL.
EIGHTY WITHOUT ADEQUATE FUNDING
AND- THE CARE FOR PROGRAM THE
POWER TO FILL THE GAP IN
EQUITABLE. TO HEALTH YOU NIELSEN
CHILD CARE WATERBOARDING THE
STABILITY OF THE CHILD CARE WORK
OR- ALSO URGED THE LEGISLATURE
INVEST BOTH GOOD NUTRITION AND
LOCAL AGRICULTURE BY FUNDING THE
CALFRESH WRITTEN FESTIVAL
SUPPLEMENTAL BENEFIT EXPANSION.
THAT PROPOSAL WOULD BUILD ON
APPROVED PILOT TO REDUCE HUNGER
WHILE ALSO SUPPORTING CALIFORNIA
FARMERS ARE IN DISTRESS. ALL I
THINK WE CAN PRINT FULL FOR FOOD
FOR ALL THE FEEDBACK EXPANSION
IN THE SENATE BUDGET PLAN I
DON'T EXPECT SUPPORT FOR THAT
HEALTH FOOD BUDGET REQUEST FOR.
THE WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE
ADMINISTRATION- TO ENSURE THE
NUTRITION THAT IS EXCEPT
EQUITABLE AND MEET THE NEEDS OF
ALL CALIFORNIANS WHO DECEIVED
AND HEALTHY FOOD ON THE TABLE
THANKS THANK YOU VERY MUCH TAX
CORPORATE. LINE NINETY NINE
PLEASE GOING UP. HELLO THANK YOU
MY NAME IS RACHEL FRIEDMAN A
MEMBER OF THE TRUTH AND JUSTICE
WE HAVE FOUR COALITION. DURING
THAT 1100% OF CHILD SUPPORT
PAYMENTS GO TO ALL LOW INCOME
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES WOULD BE
TRANSFORMATIVE. FOR FAMILIES IN
OUR STATE OUR COALITION PRAISES
THE GOVERNOR'S CURRENT PROPOSAL
TO SEND ALL CHILD SUPPORT
PAYMENTS TO FAMILIES FORMERLY
RECEIVED PUBLIC ASSISTANCE. NOW
THE GOVERNOR NEWSOM HAS AND I'M
WAVERING COMMITMENT UP WHAT WELL
AS CHILDREN IN. CALIFORNIA WHICH
IF I RESPECTFULLY ASK THE
LEGISLATURE TO PLEASE EXPAND
PROPOSALS ALSO INCLUDE AT. LEAST
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND FAMILIES.
THAT ARE CURRENTLY IN THE
HOUSEWORK PROGRAMS THAT THEY
REACH THEIR FULL CHILD SUPPORT
PAYMENTS TO. LOW INCOME HARD
WORKING PARENTS DESERVE ALL
THEIR CHILD SUPPORT DOLLARS TO
GO DIRECTLY TO THEIR KIDS. NOT
INTERCEPTED IN CAPS BY THE STATE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH TAX COLOR PLEASE. LINE
PLEASE GO TO. JUST THANK YOU.
MANY MEMBERS I SHERRY BURN
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
SILICON VALLEY LOOKING LEARNING
CENTER AND CHAIR OF THE AGING
SERVICES COOPER GLOBAL SPINAL
KERR COUNTY AND CONTRADICT THE
COR ITEM FORTY NINE TO TEN
MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT IN THE
COMMUNITY LIVING FOR HREE YEARS
CALIFORNIA 28-7 FROM THE PEOPLE
THEY WERE CHARGED. ST ACCORDING
. AND INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES EMOTIONAL MOTION
WHAT IS THE MOST THEIR OWN HOW
IN THE COMMUNITY WHAT WOULD WORK
TO MOVE HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE
ANNUAL BETWEEN THE LIVING
FEDERAL TREMENDOUSLY ASSIST
WITHOUT MORE NURSING RESIDENTS
BEING ABLE TO TRANSITION INTO
INDEPENDENT AND SUPPORTED HOW.
ALSO RIGHT. HE PREPARED AND
RESPONSE FROM ITSELF FOR THE
MILITARY AS WELL AS EXCEL FOR K.
AS HE FINALLY I. THE RECALL
SEVEN HUNDRED NINE DOLLARS. IN
HANDLING IN A DARING A TWENTY
FIVE FORTY SEVEN WELL HOW DID.
PLAN TO PREVENT HOME WITH
BUILDER GULF INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES. WE WORK HARD. THE
HOW THE RESIDENTS ARE CURRENT
HOW MUCH WE MUST NOT FORGET THE
THOUSANDS OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
RESIDENTS RIGHT HI CHRIS I'M
LIVING IN A HOUSING DUE TO
RAPIDLY INCREASING RENT AND FLAT
INCOME. OUR OUR THE HOUSE THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COMMENT ON THE REVISED BUDGET
PROPOSAL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE ONE OH
ONE IS GOING TO. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS LOCAL
CALLING AREA YEAH CALIFORNIA
CANNOT HELP NETWORK SEAT AND WE
ARE PLEASED TO RENEW COMMITMENT
TO EXPAND HEALTH CARE ALREADY.
ADDRESS THE LETTER TO PUT THE
IMPLEMENTATION GIVEN THE URGENT
NEED FOR HEALTH CARE IN THE
COMMUNITY ADDITIONALLY EXPENSE
UP TO ENSURE THAT YOUNG DURING
TWENTY HIGHER VIEW THE COMPLETE
FOR ALL AGES CALIFORNIA COPPER.
SH.
AS WE POTENTIALLY FACE THE END
OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY
COULD NOT FALL IN VARIOUS
MEDICAL ELIGIBILITY CHANGES
PUTTING THE EXPANSION TO ALL
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS WE URGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO APPROACH. IT
IS FOR WHAT- EIGHTY TWENTY SIX
EIGHTY- BY DOCTOR ARAMBULA ON
BEHALF OF THE NETWORKING GROUPS
TOOK SPONSORING HEALTHEQUITY IN
RACIAL JUSTICE WE ARE.
DISAPPOINTED BACKING BUT NOT. A
REVISED CERTAINLY THE SENATE.
AND LEADERSHIP IN PRIOR. THE
HEALTH EQUITY INITIAL JUSTICE
FUNDING GETTING THIS YEAR THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH TAX
COLOR PLEASE. ONE THIRTY SIX.
HELLO MY NAME IS RYAN FROM
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND I HAVE
A- KIND OF RADICAL PROPOSAL-
IT'S GOING TO RUN IT BY YOU GUYS
BUT JUST CONSIDERING WE HAVE.
BUT THE PANDEMIC BEING OVER- I'D
SAY ABOUT 90% OF OUR HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES- PROBABLY AREN'T
. THE TO THE COUNTY LEVEL- SO
THAT THE CONSIDERATION THAT MAY
BE- YOU KNOW ALL THESE BILLIONS
AND BILLIONS OF DOLLARS COULD GO
TO MAYBE CHECK I MEAN SOMETHING
LIKE THAT WELL I'M JUST PRIOR TO
BEING A LOT OF WEIGHT. SPECIALLY
SERVICES AND THEN MY OTHER
SUGGESTION IS THAT THE SOURCE
FUNDING PLANNED PARENTHOOD AT
LIKE ONE BILLION- WE MIGHT AS
WELL- AT LEAST PROVIDE. SURE
MASON PLANNED PARENTHOOD OR-
VARIOUS ADOPTION AGENCIES- THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. YES COLOR PLEASE. ONE ONE HUNDRED PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CONFERENCING GRATEFUL FOR
YOUR OPENNESS TO THE COMMENTS
HERE AND WE ARE- ALIGNING OUR
COMMENTS WITH THE WESTERN CENTER
ON POVERTY AND THE OTHERS WHO
BELIEVE IN KEEPING LOVING
PROTECTIVE FAMILIES TOGETHER AND
SO WE ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE
TO- INCIDENTS AND STOPPING THE
REFERRAL OF HOW IT WORKS
FAMILIES THE CHILD WELFARE
SIMPLY DUE TO FINANCIAL NEGLECT
RECOGNIZING THAT- POVERTY ITSELF
DOES NOT. NEGLECT IN THAT I'M
LOVING PROTECTIVE FAMILIES
EXPERIENCING POVERTY SHOULD BE
LIFTED P- WE WOULD ENCOURAGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO PROVIDE
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE TO THE
FAMILIES THROUGH FOR THE FAMILY
STABILIZATION PROGRAM- AND THAT
IF THE LEGISLATURE IS NOT ABLE
TO FIND THE FAMILY FEUD FISHING
PROGRAM A FURTHER THIS YEAR THAT
IT. WOULD ENCOURAGE THAT ELLIE
UP TO DO A STUDY ON ON THE
POSSIBILITIES OF- ON THE
ASSEMBLY STABILISATION PROGRAMME
AND PREVENT THE DETENTION.
POLICE AT REFERRAL TO CHILD
WELFARE- WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT FAMILIES ARE KEPT TOGETHER
AND THAT LIVING PROTECTIVE ARE
LIFTED UP AND MAINTAINED THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THE UPPER HOW MANY CALLS DO WE
STILL HAVE ON THE LINE. NINE
OKAY. ALL RIGHT THE HAVE ABILITY
WE GET THROUGH THOSE I HAVE A
FOUR THIRTY I'M TALKING ABOUT MY
SON MEETING ON SOME OF THESE
THINGS THAT WILL BE TALKED ABOUT
TODAY THAT I NEED TO GET TO SO
LET'S GO AND SEE IF WE CAN GET
THROUGH THEM. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. REGULAR ONE ONE OLD FOR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD MORNING
JERRY AND MEMBERS- LIKE THIS GOT
BROKE OVER MY FIRST DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA INC POLICY CENTER
WE CAN ORDER THE LEGISLATURE FOR
THE EFFORTS TO POSITION
CALIFORNIA THE FIRST THE MAKE
COMPREHENSIVE HEALTH CARE A
REALITY FOR ALL INCOME ELIGIBLE
. REGARDING YEAH MEDICAL
COVERAGE LOW INCOME ADULTS AGES
TWENTY SIX TWENTY NINE WITH
THANKS FOR TAKING THE LEADERSHIP
FOR INCLUDING US IN OUR
PUBLICATION DATE BUT ARE HOPING
TO HIGHLIGHT- THE- UPWARDS OF
FORTY THOUSAND UNDOCUMENTED
YOUNG ADULTS LOSE MEDICAL
COVERAGE BETWEEN THE END OF THE
PUBLIC EMERGENCY IN JANUARY.
POLICE ARE. FOR YOUR HELP-
BETTER TURN TWENTY SIX WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT YOU
NEED TO SUPPORT FOR ALL BY
INCLUDED TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
FOUR MILLION BEGINNING IN TWENTY
TWENTY THREE TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
THE BOOK UPON LAST YEAR'S
EXPANSION OF THE CALIFORNIA
WOULD ASSISTANCE FROM. GEN I'M
WE GET. WE ARE- IT IT ONLY ON.
ACTUALLY WE ARE ALSO. OF
GOVERNOR'S. FOR ROCK RESPONSE
FOR. YOU AND SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION. FIVE MILLION BEHALF OR
FOLLOWING ORGANIZATIONS THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER IMMIGRANT LEGAL RESOURCE
CENTER. CENTRAL VALLEY IMMIGRANT
INTEGRATION COLLABORATIVE
CALIFORNIA CHANGE LAWYERS.
IMMIGRANT DEFENSE ADVOCATE.
IMMIGRANT LEGAL DEFENSE IN THE
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE FOR
IMMIGRANT JUSTICE. WE HOPE THE
SENATE WILL MAINTAIN AND EXPAND
THE MAIN REVISION PROPOSAL. FOR
TWO POINT FIVE MILLION- FOR THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT JUSTICE
FELLOWSHIP WE HOPE THAT IT WILL
GET FROM IT AND- THANK YOU.
MEXICALI PLEASE PLEASE TRY TO
KEEP YOUR COMMENTS VERY BRIEF SO. WE CAN GET THROUGH THAT LAST
CALLS. ONE ONE LOS TWO GOING TO
. GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE
MEMBERS DOUBLE AT THE ALL
APPLICATIONS THAT'S HOW. WE WANT
TO FORGET THE NEEDS AND BRING
CLEAN UP THE REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
PRACTICE. THAT ARE CRITICAL. TO
ENSURE ACCESS TO ABORTION.
FOUNDED IN OUR- I WANT ALSO WANT
TO URGE THE SENATE. PLEASE
INCLUDE OUR REQUEST FOR TEN MIN
DOLLARS ONCE ALLOCATE TO BACK A
LOT OF CREDIT FOR FEDERAL.
FUNDING FOR FAMILY PLANNING
THINKING IT THE TITLE TRANSFER
GRAHAM IF WE FAIL TO SECURE THE
DOLLARS TO A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
NEED HEALTH INSURANCE. R. EIGHT
LIKE THE BILL CRITICAL REFERS IS
THE. FOR THE DELIVERY OF. AND
ACTUALLY COME. SERVICES I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THIS CALL
PLEASE. ONE THIRTEEN IS GONNA.
GOOD AFTERNOON HEARING MEMBERS
STAFF NEEDS ARE AND WHAT THE
COMMUNITY HEALTH COUNCILS IN LOS
ANGELES I THANK THE GOVERNOR TO
MINISTRATION FOR INCLUDING
FUNDING FOR HEALTH NAVIGATOR THE
MAYOR VISION NAVIGATOR THANK
CREDIBLY ESSENTIAL PARTICULARLY
RIGHT NOW IS THE EXPAND MEDI CAL
ELIGIBILITY AND PREPARE FOR THE
- I CAN SEE. CAN HOWEVER WE DO
ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
IMPROVE THE NAVIGATORS PROGRAM
BY ADOPTING THE COMMUNITY
CENTERED APPROACH THAT IT
OUTLINES AND ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SIX EIGHTY GIVEN THE
TREMENDOUS CHANGES OCCURRING IN
MEDIC HOW RIGHT NOW WE NEED TO
ENSURE THE NAVIGATION SERVICES
ARE BEING PROVIDED BY THOSE
CLOSEST TO THE COMMUNITIES THAT
THEY SERVE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OKAY THAT WILL BE OUR-
FINAL CALL- SO IF YOU HAVE IF
YOU'RE STILL ON THE LINE DIDN'T
GET THROUGH THEM WE PLEASE
ENCOURAGE YOU TO. FIRST PROVIDE
COMMENT. IN WRITING- AGAIN THIS
CONCLUDES THE HEARING ON HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES.